we only have five minutes
it's really a full opportunity and maybe
a couple questions he will answer mr
ballard who is president of the
organization will open
the ballot yes
we welcome all of you here and uh
certainly we are welcoming bishop tutu
here this evening and all his
distinguished guests whom he's brought
with him and the distinguished guests
who are going to be here this evening
bishop tutu
please don't know i i don't have
anything you you you ask your questions
to uh how did you come up here
almost three weeks in the united states
what have you accomplished i have uh i
have been quite um overcome by
the welcome that we've received
everywhere we've been i mean speaking
almost always to overflow crowds and
there's been just a tremendous
outpouring of love and caring about this
islamic situation i i didn't know there
was so much passion
among students but also amongst adults i
mean in churches and i think i mean that
the south african issue is quite clearly
on the front burner
in this country and i'm going to be able
to be a good conduit i hope to take back
to all of our people black and white
letting them know just how much
everybody cares about what is happening
at home and how much they want to see
a resolution
of that crisis i mean it will be a
tremendous country when we no longer
have to invest so much energy
defending apartheid or are taking apart
it and i just think i mean that
the mood that i sense
is one which
your legislators could not afford to
ignore
um certainly not the white house
yes okay goodbye thank you thank you
okay
well i mean there's always been violence
the violence of apartheid
what we're trying to say is can the
international community help us to keep
the level of that violence as low as
possible our people are peace loving to
a fault and
if the international community helps us
there is the possibility the outside
possibility of
a resolution reasonably peacefully if
not then we are for the birds
we're running late thank you very much
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
up next reverend desmond tutu the
anglican archbishop of cape town briefs
members of the house foreign affairs
subcommittee on africa on recent
developments in south africa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the great privileges of
serving in the congress the past several
years for me personally
has been to come to know
and to appreciate this individual
he's truly one of the great figures of
our time
a man of peace of non-violence
who has
displayed enormous courage
in the face of extraordinary duress
constant threats to both his personal
safety and
and to his own freedom inside south
africa
on behalf of the cause of freedom
archbishop tudo's visit to washington is
timely in that we have just passed
out of our committee
new legislation calling for a total
economic embargo
including disinvestment
from south africa
that legislation was crafted out of the
sense that it represents the only
viable
means
nonviolent means
of
moving this government of south africa
to
recognize the necessity of abandoning
apartheid and moving to
begin the process of negotiations
that will see the creation of a
democratic non-racial society in south
africa
but that is legislation that's very
controversial
in our own society
and in this congress
and so today we look forward to hearing
from archbishop tutu
both as to recent developments that are
in process
in south africa itself
as to the reactions to this legislation
that have already been generated within
south africa and into his own personal
views as to the appropriateness of this
kind of of effort and this meaning for
the process of change
inside south africa
it gives me
very great pleasure
to introduce all of you
to archbishop desmond tutu
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much congressman wolfie
and
friends
sometimes when you get to hear yourself
being introduced it's good to remember
some things like
what happened to me on one occasion
traveling from johannesburg
to
durban
and as usual minding my own business
when the
air hostess came along and said excuse
me sir
one of the
passengers would like you to
autograph a book for her
and
i thought to myself oh well there are
some people who who know a good thing
when they see it and i was trying to
look suitably modest
when she came and as i was taking out my
pen she said
of course you you are
bishop mozarella and you
which sort of put me properly in my
place
but thank you very very much indeed um
for
this opportunity to share with
yourselves
and it does give me the opportunity of
expressing on behalf of many of those
who are victims of
apartheid our very deep appreciation
for
the concern and the caring
and that so many of you
have
demonstrated
and your commitment to
our struggle for
justice and peace
and in south africa
i am
a christian leader
by definition this means that i am
totally opposed to any materialistic
atheistic
ideology
and so i am firmly opposed
to
marxist leninism and
communism
i have consistently also stated
my unequivocal opposition
to all forms of violence
whether it has been the violence of
a vicious and evil
system such as apartheid is or the
violence of those who seek
to end this inhumane scourge which most
major christian denominations have
condemned as a heresy i have myself in
recent correspondence with the south
african state president
provided him with what ought to be ample
evidence to demonstrate that apartheid
is evil is immoral is unchristian
and unbiblical
consequently we are committed in the
church of which i am archbishop and
metropolitan
to oppose the system
non-violently
thereby demonstrating
that we had much rather obey god than
men
and it was in
line with this particular commitment
that some of us on february the 29th
were involved in
the
procession from
saint george's cathedral in cape town
which was intended to have been a
procession to
the houses of parliament nearby
in order to present to the state
president a
petition and as you may
know
they arrested the first
row of church leaders and then
unleashed a water cannon on on the
others and someone who is awake
said because
the
petition which we were carrying um
caught waterlogged he said well now we
are going to be presenting a
watered-down petition
but it was in in line with this deep
commitment
and to non-violence but also to a firm
opposition to apartheid that we
did what we we have done
i come
before this
committee
for this briefing as a member of the
black people of south africa
so i am speaking about what is
experiential
what is
existential
when i talk about the
humiliations and the deprivations
the anguish of those who are victims of
the injustice and oppression of
apartheid
i am not describing
the experience of those of us who are
black in south africa
i was born in a black ghetto
and even now
despite what may have been said by some
people in usa today
and
even now my home
is in the black ghetto of soweto my
official residence
is in bishop's court in cape town which
is indeed
an effluent
and salubrious and exclusive suburb
segregated for white occupancy
i live in bishop's court
deliberately in defiance of the
government's laws
contained in the group areas act
when i became archbishop i told the
south african government that i was
going to live in bishop's court and i
was not going to ask for permission to
be exempted from the provisions of the
group areas act it was part of
my campaign
as part of the campaign of many others
who are committed to non-violence
and to disobey
laws that
i believe
do not oblige obedience since they are
unjust
i have served
as a pastor
in in a way to perish and now that i am
archbishop many parishes
in the diocese of cape town are found in
ghetto areas set aside for black
africans and those whom in south africa
are called coloreds
i want to know
what the south african government
still has to do
so that the world would be filled with
so much revulsion and outrage that it
would have
it would move heaven and earth
to read the world of the scourge of
apartheid
just as it was filled with revulsion and
outrage to read the world of the scourge
of nazism
it sometimes takes
our breath away
the things that the south african
government is able to get away with
the southern government has detained
children
some as young as 7 8 9 10 we were
involved with my wife on one occasion
when i was still bishop of johannesburg
with
having to deal
with the arrest of over 800 school
children
and my wife and a number of
women
went and formed a barricade at the
police station
where they said to the soldiers in their
caspers that you have to
drive over our bodies
in order to carry these children in
into the jail
and i
sought to intervene
with the police authorities on that
occasion
because
the mothers had expected that their
children had gone to school
where
normally they would be safe
but on this particular occasion
when mothers returned from work
they found
that their children had been taken
into custody
they came on the afternoon and were told
that they couldn't get their children
they came the following day and it was
about
midday
when
i was allowed to come with a senior
police officer to this particular scene
and there the mothers were standing
outside the fence of the police station
and a very tense
situation was developing
and soldiers were standing
with their rifles trained
on the bellies
of these mothers
schools were beginning
to
get out and and
and and one was just worried about what
the students would do when they saw
scenes such as this
mercifully
god is good
and
we were
ultimately able to persuade
that police officer
that they ought to release those
children
but children are in detention
some have been in detention
for over a year
held
some in communication
isolated from
family from doctors from lawyers
the
the minister of law and order
says these children are detained because
they have been doing naughty things and
you say ah
that is fine then you obviously have
evidence
why don't you produce this evidence
in a court of law so that it is tested
and even though we may still be
upset and
made to feel sad that children might
have to go to jail
at least then there is the semblance
of the law of
the rule of law being maintained
dear friends
some of these children have been
incarcerated
with hardened criminals
if white children
had been detained
by say mr mugabe
in the same way
would it be that the west represented by
its governments
would have looked on
with
the equanimity with which it has done in
the case of our children
what must
our people still suffer
so that the world
recognizing their anguish
would then say
we can't allow
this to continue
just as much as the world
decided that it was not going to allow
hitler to continue
pushing babies
into gas chambers
we have
many of us down the years told you you
know our children receive an inferior
education which condemns them
to a stunted
emotional
intellectual and even physical
growth
because they are victims
of an inferior education
deliberately designed
so that our children can grow up to fit
specific
roles in society
as perpetual serves
we've spoken to you about the horror of
forced population removals
when
people have been
uprooted from their traditional homes
and dumbed as if they were rubbish in
poverty stricken pandustan
homelands
where people starve because
of deliberate government policy not
because
there is no food in a land that
is a net exporter of food
where black family life
is undermined
by deliberate government policy because
the father
must leave his wife and children in the
rural area while she goes for 11 months
of the year to live in a single sex
hostel
as a migrant worker
children
cannot have a healthy family life
children are at risk
suffering from preventable deficiency
diseases
quasiacol malnutrition
what
what must we still
say
that we have not said
how long must we continue to make a
display of our anguish and our pain as
if we were professional masochists who
enjoyed this thing
before
you can
be sure that the world is going to be
filled with
outrage
and seek to help
change all of this
the south african government
exercises a terrorism against its own
people since 1984
over 2 000 people have been killed
and
the statistics are that
most of those have been killed by the
security forces
you have seen until the severe glands on
the media
the brutality that is inherent in
apartheid
when you used to see on your tv screens
scenes of police using dogs and quirks
and
tear gas and rubber bullets and live
ammunition
on people who were protesting
non-violently
you have seen
how apartheid has exported its terrorism
in mozambique
a state department report has indicated
that renamo supported by the south
african government
has
perpetrated
untold atrocities
over a hundred thousand people have been
killed just like that
we went to mozambique because it is part
of
the province over which ecclesiastical
province over which i have jurisdiction
and we saw
some of the victims of renamo
what must the south african government
still do
so that you will
make the moral decision
that no administration ever
would want to collaborate with apartheid
just as
no
administration whether republican or
democratic would have collaborated with
nazism
apart apartheid has caused continues to
cause untold unnecessary suffering to
the people of namibia to the people of
botswana to the people of zimbabwe of
angola
a party it has
has got its
death squads
who've killed dallas in september in
paris
killed a man in a hospital bed in
lesotho
have injured in early sex in maputo
what must still happen
what must still happen
when you have a government that sits
loosely to all the ideals which you hold
dear in your country
severe
press censorship
the alternative press
weekly mail
new nation
the new nation has been suspended and
yesterday we learned that another
of our alternative press
south
newspaper in cape town
has also been suspended
why are they scared of
people getting information about what is
happening in our country
if they have got nothing to hide
why
do they have a new constitution in 1984
that excludes 73 percent of its
population
from any participation
why
should 17 18 organizations
have been virtually banned and and
persons involved in
trying
to change a party non-violently
also virtually banned
to stop communism
well the best recruiters for communism
must surely be the south african
government
and apartheid
friends
we
are deeply concerned
that
we should have this new south africa we
are going to have this new south africa
where
black and white will be able to live
amicably together
we want it to happen
reasonably
peacefully
you have tried
for 40 years to persuade the south
african government to change
and in recent years
in a very concerted way through
constructive engagement
you have failed
we don't want to use violence
we want to use non-violent methods
we have an incredible country with
incredible people
black and white people
and for me
although actually i do not and i'm not
going to say so i've said so many i do
not want sanctions just for the hell of
it
i do not want anything that would um
destroy our country
but i would say that the owners lies
with those who say they do not want
sanctions and yet do want change in
south africa
to provide us with
a viable option that will bring about
the attainment of our goal a new
non-racial
democratic south africa
people say sanctions don't work
sanctions are ineffective sanctions hurt
the ones that you want to help most of
all
but what you must do is to
increase
economic prosperity and
these things
will then
erode apart it
i wish that were true
i have no evidence myself that economic
prosperity has done anything
to change
the
iniquitous system under which we live in
south africa
any change that has happened in south
africa has happened because of pressure
if you talk about change in the sports
policy that happened because of the
sports boycott which stood south
africa's apartheid policy in sports on
its head
we have wonderful people white people
who want to to see a party end
i am myself
intrigued
by how suddenly there comes to be an
upsurge of altruism
all these wonderful people who suddenly
discover that they
they are concerned for the welfare of
white people of black people
but we don't want black people to suffer
as if black people were living in clover
it is the same people who have benefited
from black suffering over the years
without a squeak of conscience that they
were benefiting from cheap labor that
was provided by blacks they were
benefiting from migratory labor which
was provided by blacks they're
benefiting from blacks living in ghetto
areas
and now when we provide something
that may bring about the change that
most people say they want to have
we're told sanctions don't work
and yet they are applied at the drop of
a head to panama
to nicaragua
to poland
to libya
to most
countries
without so far as i can make out any
discussion about whether they are
effective whether they are likely to
hurt those you want to help most of all
and it is interesting if sanctions are
ineffective
why do we have all these wonderful
lobbies that are coming here to try to
dissuade you from passing
more stringent sanctions
i mean i'm sure that you
if you know that something is
ineffective
and somebody is spending time trying
to carry out this particular thing that
you know is ineffective you just sit on
the sidelines and you look at them and
you laugh at them
why
are white south africans and the south
african government jumping about like
they have got ends in their pants
over sanctions
i have yet to be called by a black
congregation in south africa
and asked bishop tutu why
are you
advocating sanctions when you know that
it is we who are going to suffer
every time i have had to give a
justification for my support for
sanctions it is said to be to white
congregations
i just find that odd
i come
to stand here
in support
of this new
bill that is before
congress
the dillon's bill
which is saying we need to move
further than we have gone
if we can get rid of apartheid without
sanctions
friends
i can assure you that i am going to be
the first to sing hallelujah
but the
evidence that is available to us is
that that is not likely
to happen
and so it is critically urgent
that you make a moral decision i've come
here to ask
not that you make a decision based on
economics or politics i'm asking you
make a moral decision are you on the
side
of injustice
or justice
are you on the side of oppression
or freedom are you on the side
of humanity or in humanity
and you know morality works
because you see
we are going to be free
whatever you do
or don't do
and i would hope i mean that you would
be people who would want to be around
when we are free
and we would be able to welcome you and
say
yeah
you helped us in the process of becoming
free
for you see
you are told that
south africa may retaliate
they are able to do so only because they
know
they can talk as neuter the world
knowing full well that president reagan
and mrs fletcher and charles le cole
will always come to their protection
when it comes to the crunch
and we are impressed with
all the rhetoric
about people's opposition to apartheid
we're not so impressed
about how they suddenly get cold feet
when they have to carry out action that
will put into effect
that rhetoric
that south africa cannot afford
not
to
to trade with you
where it can
south africa depends
on
the foreign market
and
if
you send out the important signal
that the south african government
does not deserve to operate in decent
society
not the south african people the
sovereign government and those who
support apartheid
you will have made an important point
because you are doing something that is
right because it is right
we have strategic resources
we have a strategic geographic position
so we are told
south africa is going to be free
and those resources
which was strategic before we
became free
won't suddenly become unstrategic
and our strategic geographical position
before we gained our freedom
once suddenly become
unstrategic
when south africa is free
and the freedom about which i speak
friends is a freedom for all of south
africa's people
black and white
can you imagine a free south africa
where
we will be able
to be
the launching pad for the world
certainly for
the subcontinent
and almost certainly for
all of the continent of africa
to propel it into the 21st century
because we have got the resources
natural and human
and i would
myself urge
that
if americans
want
a place in history
but they will support
the sanctions bill
and show
that they are concerned
for the welfare of all
south africans black and white
and we will come along and invite you
to come to
our celebrations of our liberation
and that ought to be soon
if you act appropriately
thank you
so
[Applause]
archbishop tutu has agreed to take
questions at this point and i'll invite
questions from anyone present
particularly i'd like to of course give
a preference to our colleagues first of
all the chairman the congressional black
caucus merv diamond
bishop
the opposition to the sanctions bill
center around the argument
that
the blacks
in south africa
will suffer they will be the victims of
sanctions
you respond to that
yes
thank you i i have tried to indicate
that
the actually the call for sanctions
happened ages ago
you know chief alberto truly
made
that call
because we were looking for this
non-violent option
it's a call that is being made by most
black
credible organizations
i have not yet been repudiated on the
score
that
this was something that blacks would not
accept
by any credible
black organization
or black leader any of those who have
done so have been the predictable ones
who operate within the system
and as i indicated here
i have not yet been
called to task by a black congregation
black people are suffering
and their suffering has come about as a
deliberate
matter of public policy
the south african government intends
that suffering to continue
because it has not
indicated that it wants to get rid of
apartheid and the source of our
suffering is apartheid and now people
have said
if
it means that to get rid of this courage
we need to take on
what may be additional suffering
we will
we will if if that is the price we have
to pay for our freedom
thanks gundersen
bishop i'm congressman gunderson happen
to be one of those republicans who's
visited your country and voted not only
for the sanctions a couple years ago but
voted to override the president's veto
i did that at the time because i felt
very strongly that we needed to make the
moral statement which you've alluded to
in your remarks
my question today however it focuses on
where do we go from making moral
statements to try to implement what i
would call effective policies
and frankly i think the problem is that
the united states taking unilateral
economic actions
in the absence of cooperation from japan
west germany britain etc frankly
produces
no results
number one i'd like you to comment on
that number two i'd like you to suggest
how do we as a government
move beyond the moral statements to that
effective policy that would allow all of
us to sing from the same hymn book if
you please
thank you very much um
i think you're quite right that um
it would be far more effective if we had
a global
approach as it were by
those countries that can
make that particular difference
i think
though
if we are
saying
who are likely in fact to persuade those
other governments to
act appropriately
no government
no country is in a better position than
the united states
as a superpower that what you do and has
ramifications in all kinds of ways and
therefore that moral stand that you take
um
sends out ripples
which
make the japanese
uneasy they are uneasy actually just now
discovering that they are
south africa's largest trading partner
and and they want to distance themselves
the british
the germans
would be equally
uneasy if you
with
all the moral
political military
economic clout that you have decided
that they're going to do
what was right
and and i i i would say that they they
have probably been
strengthened to hold back
or to be intransigent in their position
because of the position of the united
states i mean they they've been able to
to to know that they could invoke
a veto in the security council because
if they didn't do it they knew that the
united states would do it but if you
were to have said that we were
supporting what say foreign was doing
they were going to find it increasingly
difficult
but i still would want to say
you ought
speaking morally
you ought to do the right thing
because it is the right thing
and and and hope
that
there would be
a
a ground swell
and that would happen and i have no
doubt myself
that there would be that groundswell of
support for your stand because of who
the united states is now
i am not i am not very bright
as
most people have discovered and and and
so
i i wouldn't be able to provide you with
a blueprint as to the sorts of things
that ought to be happening but what you
are actually talking about is how do we
in fact get to empower blacks
and in the economic area
as
people consider disinvestment they are
involving some of them are involving the
workers now in in all of those
negotiations about how
can we best
and
remove ourselves in such a way that it
is of benefit to the underclass
and and i think that that
would be part of it
would be part of the purpose of
of working towards this new south africa
and i think i mean that other things
that are
also contained in the bill and i mean
the assistance to
um
refugees
and the scholarship things
those are important they are not sort of
ancillaries you are saying we want to
invest in human beings we want to
prepare people for the new south africa
and i would out of obviously say that
you would need to be talking to those of
our people
who
are making it their business to talk
about
the alternative
society when south africa is free
i think you are to be talking to our our
premier political organizations that are
not allowed to operate in south africa
the anc the pc those are people who are
part
who have been part of the the this the
past of south africa they are very much
a part of the president of south africa
and only ostriches
can pretend that they will not be a part
of the future
congressman hope
bishop i have a question
nice to see you again sir thank you i
can't uh
stand up here without uh thanking you
for just your presence and the presence
of your lovely wife
uh
if it were in my power i would make you
an honorary member of congress it is not
however this is how we feel about you
and what you're doing
i would just like to follow up on what
steve gunderson said and then move
forward a bit
i happen to believe
that
with steve that a consortium rather than
individual action is important
now it's very easy to say that the
united states has it in its power to do
this but the united states is not doing
it
and therefore uh the impact uh i am not
sure whether you speak in tokyo or
whether you talk in bonn or whether you
talk in the netherlands or in london
but
maybe
sparks will create something which will
affect us more than something internally
generated
and from a strictly a business
standpoint that is going to be something
which is going to be to me the telling
blow but let me ask you this question uh
you were talking about really in
economic terms the customer
we the customer providing sanctions what
about the sources what about those
important economic units within south
africa
who give lip service to what you believe
but do not practice it yeah
when a bank here
in new york
decided not to roll over alone
the value of the land
took an enormous dip
and quite suddenly
the business sector in south africa
discovered that the air around lusaka
was
salubrious and they were all
going in a trek to lusaka to talk to the
anc because they thought i mean
momentous
changes were probably around the corner
and now that the southern government
seems to
have got things under control with a
state of emergency and the price of gold
is what it is they've they've gone back
to their arrogant complacent selves
again
i i had
a dinner with four
of
the leading
economic
financial
business people in south africa
i ended up
with my hand in my head in my hands i
stopped talking
and because it was quite clear
to me at that point that
most of them not all of them i mean the
the there's a wonderful
person
and i i think i mean that you people
ought to hear more of
bob tucker the
ceo of the south african firm is a young
person who is very committed
and and and really means what he's
saying so far as i can make out
um
he had hosted that dinner
and
but i'm too many like him
and most of the others are not going to
act until they are hit
where it hurts the most their pocketbook
and and
all their protestations to the contrary
they are enjoying the present set up
they may come here and speak to you
in terms that may try to indicate that
they would like to see change they've
got
a cloud that they don't want to use
i have said so to them
and and and and they've pretended to an
impotence that they don't have
but you can actually
be the spur
to get them moving
because if you say to them unless one
two three things happen
we we are we are going to
to
stop
you having access to the dollar market
you won't be able to carry out
international trade because
you don't have the currency
which is used for international
settlements
they will begin to talk a different
language
but could i just say also the other
thing is
the blacks at home
do still have maybe a naive belief
that there are enough people who believe
in justice and human rights in your
country
and still believe that
if you tell people
in those countries about the awfulness
of what is happening that they will they
will take action
to indicate that concern
and and the workers i mean
in a situation
where people are are held down
workers were able to carry out a strike
at the height of unemployment
last year for
two weeks
i would have thought i mean the world
would say this does demonstrate
a very deep commitment on the part of
blacks one to change the system and two
to try to change it non-violently
and and the reaction of the south
african government is almost always a
violent reaction to non-violent
strategies
congressman clinton
congressman tutu i'm congressman from
the state of tennessee and i know you
spoke there just a few days ago and we
were really honored to have you in our
state
i guess my question's twofold
one looking ahead dreaming ahead do you
think we'll have total freedom
in south africa prior to the year 2000
and the second part of my question would
be you commented about education that
the blacks were receiving an inferior
education
when that time comes will the blacks
be prepared to lead and manage south
africa
i i think i mean that the answer to the
first question is it depends on what you
do
very much
when it's going to happen and
i would have hoped that
i was sufficiently
enough persuasive to
make you decide that um
if you if you if you weren't going to do
so that you would vote and get your your
chance to vote overwhelmingly for this
bill that is before or is coming before
congress um
with regard to the matter of education
our people are aware
that
we are not going to have a one-man band
operation
our people are
deeply committed to the non-racial
approach
and
we already do have a a classic example
in zimbabwe
i mean most people had had predicted
that the first general election under mr
mugabe would be the last the very second
and all those uh rhodesians white
rhodesians were fleeing to south africa
are flocking back to zimbabwe
because
although he didn't in a sense need them
politically he started off and he had
white cabinet ministers
not because they are white because but
because they are zimbabweans and because
they've got the ability
and our people would have we have no
problem i mean we have no problem about
having a south african
do something because they can do it
i mean we've got a little an example in
things like
our church operation
i wouldn't begin to claim to omniscience
and i know i lay claim to a lot of
things but i mean i wouldn't er in
modesty
and it's no skin of my nose to be able
to say
i know nothing about this will you
be the one who does that
i mean when they do it well i will get
the kudos as the as the captain of the
team
but it's silly to try to to
to pretend to an a
an omni
omniscience
omni competence that no human being has
and our people have no problem about
that
the one problem that we would have is
whether the person had a commitment to
south africa
and to the people of south africa that
is that would be that is going to be the
test let me just
maybe let me just give you a an
interesting
example of the kind of thing that i'm
talking about
the soweton
during the election
the last white all-white election
said to its readers
who would you have in your government
and
i mean it's not a serious thing and you
would have thought that black say well
to hell with it and we i mean this is
not a very serious thing we could we
could become as extreme as we love it's
quite interesting that
they've done this twice now and and the
same kind of thing has emerged
where blacks have sometimes included
even
doctor
prior nerd
the leader of the conservative party
in in a cabinet
which would be a cabinet made up of
south africans
who happen some of them to be black
and others to be white
and so what
the ranking member of my subcommittee uh
mr burke
bishop tutu i think everyone recognizes
that you're one of the truly great
leaders of south africa
and i've talked with a number of other
uh great black leaders over there
they are all
all of whom with whom i've talked are
opposed to apartheid but they don't
share your view of the sanctions
approach
the chief booth the lazy of the zulu
bishop laganyani bishop mokina
i had a number of people in my office
from in kata
they feel that
economic power will bring about change
as rapidly or more rapidly than
sanctions
and they think that sanctions will cause
a great hardship on the blacks over
there and they oppose it can you explain
to us why there's such a difference of
opinion
can you can you provide me even in your
party any example of unanimity on
anything
i i don't i don't i don't think that
that
is something that bothers me
i mean if i am in
a libertarian which i am
i
i will disagree with them but i will
defend to the death their right
to the
point of view which i think myself
are unacceptable
but i mean let them because you see
i have never actually come to anybody
and said
on the issue of sanctions
desmond tutu is speaking on behalf of
i have always made it quite clear i mean
i don't even speak on behalf of my
church
but i ought to make it clear
i made the call for sanctions
on
on the 2nd of april 1986
i know i remember the date because i i
didn't think it would be an auspicious
date to have chosen the first of april
and
and it was the second of april because
on the 14th of april
they went and elected
the archbishop of cape town and i wanted
them to know that i
supported sanctions and they must
elect whoever they want with their eyes
open
and you are elected in our church to to
be elected you have to have a two-thirds
majority
of
the votes in that elective
assembly and yet i don't claim to speak
on behalf of anybody and i mean they
speak
for whoever they speak
but you've you've seen some of the
you've seen some of the surveys
a survey that was shown in the
sunday times london indicated actually
that there were 70 percent
blacks who would say
for various reasons that they they did
support this particular strategy and
then if you have people who say no
tell me something new
i would just like to say yeah
that i had the good fortune of traveling
to uh
with my chairman
howard waltby
back in i guess about four years back
and we went to uh
zimbabwe
and for those of us
who were old enough to remember
the battles of
rhodesia between whites and blacks
i was fascinated and i just want to
i guess
tie up to what you have said
bishop tutu
that we had a chance to visit the
parliament
and there was ian smith
just going at it as usual
and i was fascinated because
sure ian smith was very much in
government he was the head of the white
uh
uh the the the white groups in the in
rhodesia at the time uh to try and keep
a separatist country but there he was
conformed to the fact that he was still
a member of parliament he was still
battling he was still doing everything
he could for his cause but he was doing
it in the confines of an elected
parliament
and i found that fascinating because
coupled with that
it seems to me that one of the biggest
problems and one that one of the biggest
problems one of the fears that america
many people here in the united states
have if in fact
blacks were to rule south africa where
would they get the talent well it became
very clear to us during our meeting with
mr mugabe and with his cabinet that he
did have within that cabinet
there were whites there were blacks and
they were working together then coupled
with that because it was myself and
another colleague remember the banking
committee
three zimbabwe three people
from the financial community who were
white came to visit with myself and the
other member of the banking committee
with absolutely no
no doubt in their mind that they would
never leave
zimbabwe they were there to stay they
were running the financial institutions
in zimbabwe and i felt that based on
everything that i had seen that the
transition even though the battle was
fierce the transition seemed without a
doubt to be working quite well so having
been in politics at that time an
elective office for a good 15 to 16
years i just want to
to to make it very clear to you in terms
of what you say that i have no doubt
that when a time comes
that it will be people both white black
people who are truly interested in south
africa as a nation and not in color that
they will join together it happened in
in zimbabwe which is your neighbor i'm
certain it can take place in south
africa because there are many talented
people there as well
thank you very much
let me express on behalf of all of my
colleagues and all those who are
president bishop to to our deep
appreciation for your
being with us this morning you've
honored us by your presence
my hope is that the message that you
have conveyed will be
understood
and heeded by this congress and by the
american people
on other occasions you have made the
point and i think it's one that we all
ought to
consider
that somehow we've had historically an
unique approach to the subject of south
africa
i think the question that we all need to
ask ourselves is
what would have been our policy all
these many decades
had there been a black minority in south
africa
imposing this horrendously dehumanizing
system of the part data over against a
white majority
would we have resisted the application
of sanctions
the point that you've made is that the
rest of the world recognizes the
enthusiasm with which we have applied
sanctions and so many other parts of
this world whether
soviet union or libya
or panama or nicaragua
but somehow we've turned this up in
south africa and we've had a very
different approach
i think there's a perception as a
consequence that we may have had a
racial double standard in our approach
to these human rights questions that i
think has
helped to call into question
unfortunately america's moral authority
and our political influence and in much
of the world
i think we i was never more proud
of my colleagues in the congress and
american people than when we had a
two-thirds majority
willing to go so far as to override a
president's veto that's never an easy
action to
impose the limited sanctions effort a
couple of years ago
my hope is
that there will be that same kind of
recognition that the same issues are
still before us
and that we'll be able to develop that
kind of bipartisan support once again in
the congress for
the new initiative
again thank you
[Music]
if you'd like more information on this
briefing by reverend desmond tutu you
can write to the house foreign affairs
subcommittee on africa in room 705 of
house annex number one washington dc
20515
[Music]
maritime strength in the 21st century
will be the topic of a speech by frank
carlucci
the secretary of defense will deliver
the commencement
[Music]
up next on c-span another in our
continuing series of speeches at the
national press club in washington we
hear now from archbishop desmond tutu of
south africa
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome to the
national press club
i'm lee roderick washington bureau chief
for scripps league newspapers and
president of the club
i'd like to welcome my fellow club
members and their guests to the audience
today
as well as those of you who are
listening to this program
over one of the more than 350 national
public radio stations
are watching on one of the 2600 systems
affiliated with c-span
the cable satellite public affairs
network
before going further i'd like to remind
our members of some coming events
on may 19th congressman claude pepper of
florida will be with us
on may 24th tom peters the co-author of
in search of excellence will be here
on may 26th senator bill bradley of new
jersey will be with us
june 1st agriculture secretary richard
lang
on june 2 gannett chairman al new hearth
and on june 6th former president gerald
ford will be here to present the first
gerald r ford prizes for distinguished
reporting on the presidency and national
defense
i'd like to remind excuse me those of
you in our audience that if you have
questions for our speakers today
my i trust you will
please write them on the cards furnished
at your tables and pass them up to me
i'll ask as many as time allows
i'd like now to introduce the guests at
our head table i'll ask each of them to
stand briefly as their names are read
i'll ask each of you in the audience to
please withhold your applause until all
the names are read
starting at my left and your right hola
wumi excuse me news agency of nigeria
karen sloan news editor of the
associated press broadcast
dave anderson u.s department of housing
urban development and the member of our
speakers committee who organized today's
luncheon
randy allen vice president of permit
video and press club secretary
sam donaldson white house correspondent
for abc news
leia tutu the wife of our speaker
going past our speaker for the moment to
greg spears regional reporter for night
rider newspapers the chairman of our
speakers committee
bill plant senior white house
correspondent cbs news
the right reverend john walker episcopal
bush
episcopal bishop of washington i'll get
that out bishop
episcopal anglican bishop of washington
and dean of washington cathedral
bob abernathy nbc news correspondent
james boiti west africa magazine
eleanor clift of newsweek
and norm kempster of the los angeles
times
[Applause]
before introducing our speaker i want to
take this opportunity
on behalf of the national press club to
express our deep disappointment in the
continuing actions against an
independent press in south africa
this week the government closed the
weekly anti-apartheid newspaper called
south
it was the second alternative newspaper
closed in the past month
and other newspapers have been warned
that they may be next we urge pretoria
to lift the broad press sanctions
imposed last year
and to not smother the last flames of a
free press in south africa
our speaker today is desmond tutu
anglican archbishop of cape town and
primate of the anglican church for all
of southern africa
he is a spiritual leader of some two
million two million anglicans i got
tongue-tied today two million anglicans
of all races
but his moral ministry is considerably
larger encompassing people of goodwill
in every nation
who are concerned over events in south
africa
where five million whites rule 26
million blacks
and other racial groups in a system
known as apartheid
his native country is the richest and
most highly developed in africa
south africa produces most of the
world's gold and more gem diamonds than
any other country
and is spectacularly beautiful
but its racial policies which were
codified 40 years ago to keep blacks
separate and decidedly unequal
have made south africa a pariah in the
world community
bishop tutu's acts of defiance in the
struggle against apartheid are many
he has criticized the government of
south africa for entrance intransigence
and criticized the reagan administration
for doing too little to encourage the
growth of democracy in that country
perhaps his most enduring legacy
will be his personal bravery
bishop tutu has often placed his life in
jeopardy by pleading for calm among
angry crowds in south africa's black
townships
in 1985 in a well-publicized incident
he emerged from a cemetery to find a mob
gathered around a man they had beaten
and were about to throw on a burning car
bishop tutu waded into the mob wrestled
the suspected collaborator away from
them and took him to safety
during the funeral preceding that
incident he had said quote
let us not use methods in the struggle
that we will be ashamed of
bishop tutu was born 56 years ago in a
gold mining town in the trance wall
he took a teaching degree and taught
school for several years
before resigning to protest the inferior
education mandated by the government for
black children
he then began to study theology
following in the footsteps of a man who
had impressed him deeply starting when
he was just 12 years old
the man was a white anglican minister
who one day tipped his hat to tutu's
mother who was working as a cook at a
missionary school for the blind
that simple act of courtesy impressed
him
with the notion that perhaps there was
hope that people one day of different
races could live peaceably together
after serving the anglican church as a
priest for 15 years he was named bishop
of lesotho in 1976
a post which he held until the selection
as bishop of johannesburg in 1985.
the following year he assumed his
present position of archbishop of cape
town bishop tutu has held a variety of
offices within his church as well as
positions within the world council of
churches and the south african council
of churches
the recipient of innumerable innumerable
awards honors and honorary degrees
is the author of two recent books on the
flight of south africa
he chairs the bishop tutu's southern
africa refugee scholarship fund and he
co-chairs the united democratic front in
the republic of south africa
the archbishop lives with his wife leia
in cape town they have three daughters
naomi fandy and umpo and i told the
input i would try to get her name right
because she's with us today somewhere
back in the corner maybe she can briefly
stand for us
there we go
empo by the way is a graduate of howard
university
in 1984 desmond tutu traveled to oslo
norway where he was awarded the nobel
prize for peace for his efforts to bring
about peaceful change in south africa
upon receiving that distinguished honor
he said that south africa's policy of
racial separation
breeds inju breeds injustice and
violence and that peace is invariably a
casualty of injustice
edgal arvik chairman of the norwegian
nobel committee stated quote
although
he has never learned to hate no one has
opposed injustice with a more burning
anger
courageous and fearless he opposes his
country's authorities
his fearless attitude has made him a
unifying symbol for all groups of
freedom campaigners in africa
the citation itself of the nobel award
read quote
this year's award should be seen as a
renewed recognition of the courage and
heroism
shown by black south africans in their
useful peace and their use of peaceful
methods in the struggle against
apartheid
bishop tutu himself has said that our
struggle is as much to free the
oppressor as the oppressed
if whites can accept that they are
infinite value before god
then they won't have to behave like
bullies
despite the frustration caused by the
intransigence of the south african
regime
desmond tutu has continued his calls
upon multinational corporations and
financial institutions
to withdraw financial support from south
africa
until apartheid has ended
nor has he lost faith in his non-violent
methods however he warns us quote
young blacks are becoming increasingly
committed to using violence despite my
calls for peaceful change if i were
younger he says i would have rejected
tutu a long time ago
archbishop tutu once told
time magazine
that the advocates of apartheid will
pull down the pillars of our nation even
if it means they perish in the process
they're really scared
that they're going to we are going to
treat them as they treated us
another conscience for south africa
novelist alan payton died just last
month
he and bishop tutu often disagreed in
the methods that should be used to try
to bring an end to apartheid
but both shared a concern
expressed there and
famous in peyton's book cry the beloved
country
and toward the end kamala in the book
says i have one great fear in my heart
one day when they have turned to loving
they will find we are turned to hating
please welcome to the national press
club archbishop desmond tutu
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
good afternoon
friends
thank you very much for
the great privilege
you have done me to
invite me to speak at this
important
forum
and i want to thank
bishop john walker for his part in that
you have an important vocation the
recent severe south african clamp on
the
media is a tribute to
your effectiveness
in reporting
the brutalities
of apartheid
and this must have helped in no small
measure
to create the kind of moral climate
which made it possible
to pass
sanctions legislation despite the
opposition
of the
administration here
you're having invited me
obviously proves the truth of the days
that distance lends enchantment to the
view
because you seem oblivious to my all too
evident what's which those back at home
are very quick to spot
and cause them to tell some delicious
two-two stories
one of them is about
how when i died um i went to
the pearly gates and um
saint peter said well no no you have to
go to the warmer place
and
a fortnight later there is a frenzy
knocking on on the doors of heaven
and when saint peter goes he finds
uh the devil standing there and he says
now what about you what what do you want
here the devil says well you sent bishop
to two down there and he's causing so
much trouble i have come to ask for
political asylum
[Applause]
back at home they also tell other
stories which feature a character called
fundamental
who is not over endowed with
intelligence he is browned off so they
say
because the united states and russia
have
their prestigious
space programs and so he announces that
south africa is to launch a spacecraft
to the sun no less
and knowledgeable people tell him
fundamentally it will be burned to
cinders long before
it gets anywhere near the sun and
nothing daunted from the murder retorts
you don't think we south africans are
stupid
well we will launch it at night
i don't think he is typical but we do
have some strange things happen in our
land
and i am about to publish a dictionary
to help people who are not too
knowledgeable
and about the strange use of language
that is characteristic of our country if
you heard someone say
now we have a law the extension of
university education act you would
assume
given the dictionary meaning of the
words that they meant what they were
saying
university education will now be made
more readily and more widely available
than formerly
everywhere else in the world not in
south africa
that law was enacted to stop so-called
open universities that admitted all
races from doing so and ethnic based
universities became the order of the day
that law is still in place
universities can today admit different
races but a
penalty if they exceed their racial
quota is paid south africa has a public
holiday called family day
now that must be proved positive if any
was required that we
set great store by the sanctity of
family life and we want to preserve this
hallowed institution
but what is this the stark reality
the economy of our beautiful land is
built on the iniquitous migratory labor
system according to which
the black father must leave
his family in the poverty-stricken
parent pantostan homeland
to work in the white men's town
leading in a natural life as a migrant
worker
in a single sex hostel for 11 months of
the year prey to
drunkenness prostitution and other ills
even the white dutch reformed church in
one of its synods and they are not given
to
criticizing a government has called the
system a cancer in our society
it is the only country in the world that
i know where it is a crime for a man to
sleep with his wife if he is a migrant
worker and she came to visit him without
permission in the city where he works
in a normal country you affirm those
concerned for justice peace and
reconciliation and you do all you can to
help them in their efforts in south
africa that is not so ashiku media
president of the united democratic front
very deeply
concerned with peace efforts to end the
carnage in peter marrisburg in natal has
been proscribed
is it because the south african
authorities gain political mileage out
of so-called black-on-black violence
mrs albertina sulu the mother of zoella
quesulu who is to be honored wonderfully
this evening
another ugf president
tried to end factional fighting in
a ghetto in cape town ktc
she has been stopped by the restriction
order
placed on her why
is it because the authorities want that
kind of unrest because of his propaganda
value
we have a
board of social responsibility worker
known there powerful who has worked like
anything to try to bring about peace
between war infections he is in
detention this is the fourth week of his
detention
you have heard of dr ivan thomas a young
white doctor
doing outstanding work in a clinic in a
black ghetto called crossroads near cape
town
he refused a call-up to serve in the
south african defense force because he
believed his hands were dedicated to
healing not killing
for this stand he is serving 21 months
as an ordinary convict in a criminal
jail in a normal country
he would be a hero
i went to his clinic and the dear old
black ladies his patients
prayed
with tears streaming down the aligned
faces for his protection he had been
carrying out invaluable work as an
apostle of racial harmony and
reconciliation
my friend
we have a beautiful country
with beautiful people
many many white south africans want to
see real change
which has to do with political power and
that is a miracle i believe i will white
need an excess of grace
to want to change a system that accorded
me such substantial privileges and power
just because i was white
white south africans are not horned
demons with hidden tales they are
ordinary human beings most of them
scared stiff but wouldn't you be if you
were outnumbered five to one
all that blacks want is to be able to
live as human beings created in the
image of god
and therefore of inestimable worth
in the land of their breath
where their dignity as human beings was
acknowledged
and respected blacks don't want to drive
white people into the sea
they just want a place in the sun
in a land where all south africans would
be south africans that is a tautology
but it is an important tautology a
citizen by definition shares in the
political
decision-making process
through the franchise
mr p w potter
is a very courageous man
and has done and said things
we had not expected to hear from a
nationalist
state president
but to turn an english expression around
he really does not have the convictions
of his courage
he has moved
away
from a party just enough to annoy his
right wing and nowhere nearly enough
to satisfy black aspirations and so
his newest constitution 1984 model
excludes 73 percent of the population
from any participation in political
decision making
it does not pretend
even to be remotely democratic
it enshrines ethnicity
and it enshrines and sanctifies white
minority domination
the crisis in south africa is about
political power
and that power is determined by the vote
is it not strange that an important man
such as chief garcia who tells you has
spoken here
can be a chief minister that is a prime
minister of his own homeland
who heads a massive movement
in qatar
that such a man held in high regard by
many in the west
should not vote in the land of his
behalf
whereas an 18 year old because he or she
is white
and since 1984 so-called colored or
indian can
mr p w broda's latest proposals are like
his other proposals and actions really
impressive as symbols with no substance
what is the point of blacks electing an
official the state president as members
of an electoral college
when he will thereafter not be
accountable to them at all will the
number of blacks on the electoral
college by any meaningful relationship
to black population numbers will plex be
free to choose whoever they want to
represent them and whoever thought we
wanted membership in the president's
council
the native representative council of
europe
was finally rejected by blacks as being
no better than a toy telephone your
messages never got through
the president's council would be worse
than a toy telephone
what we want is not crumbs of
concessions thrown from the masters
table at his whim
we want to be at that table deciding the
menu together and that means universal
suffrage
i thought that was what white told us
was the meaning of democracy
government of the people by the people
for the people
all the people
black and white genuine majority rule
not black majority rule but majority
rule
we want to pay a one tribute to all who
have held and continue to help us in our
liberation struggle the churches in this
country the people of the united states
the students
the free south africa movement the
anti-apartheid movement transafrica
the black congressional con
caucus the charles rangels the frank
ferraris the telums the grays the
warpies the solaces the kennedys i could
go on and on and on and on
the jesse jacksons
and all of you wonderful people engaged
in this exhilarating struggle to free
south africa for all of its people black
and white
and i stand here to say that the primary
violence in south africa comes from
apartheid
which has acted with brutal and careless
efficiency against defenseless people it
detains children
it starves them
it stuns their growth emotionally
physically and intellectually they
suffer from quite preventable
deficiency diseases it tortures and
maims its children it kills children
it sponsors state terrorism through
vigilante groups
in the black townships to gloat over
so-called black on black violence
it has since 1984 caused the deaths of
over 2 000 people most of these
by
the government security forces it still
forcibly moves and dumps people it is
uprooted and dumped over three and a
half million
it will move the people of a place
called levi camp in george despite the
fact that the government had promised
that foster removals had now stopped
all this is violent structural
legalized but violence all the same
our people have been peace loving to a
fault
in 1960
protesting
peacefully against the past laws
having campaigned since 1912
none violently for change in south
africa 69 of our people were shot most
of them in the back running away at
shopville and in the ensuing state of
emergency our political organizations
the nc and the pac were banned
they had till then been operating
legally and openly
and non-violently they said they had now
no option but to undertake the armed
struggle
people who support the contras and unita
against legitimate and popularly elected
governments condemn our freedom fighters
as terrorists and call these others
freedom fighters
we have never understood the convoluted
logic
i have said and i will say again
[Applause]
i support
the anc in its goal
[Music]
for
a non-racial democratic and just south
africa but i do not support its methods
i condemn the violence of apartheid
but i also condemn the violence of those
who want to overthrow apartheid i
acknowledge nelson mandela as my leader
and i am proud to do so
some call him a terrorist
[Applause]
they call jomo kenyatta a terrorist
they call robert mugabe a terrorist
they call samara michel a terrorist
pw border stood to attention side by
side with samora michel
today's terrorists have an
unconscionable habit of becoming
tomorrow's prime ministers and
presidents
has there not have been so even in
israel
i am glad that the world has been so
concerned about russian dissidents and
their fate
but why are our dissidents treated as if
they were a different breed
if there was no communism in russia i
suppose there would have been no sakura
being dissidents
equally if there were no apartheid there
would have been no need for the
mandela's the sisulus the mutu beings to
be dissidents
why is the world so indifferent to our
prisoners of conscience
mr pw brother broke another promise he
made he said he would consider the
release of nelson mandela
and the russians released professor
shakarov
and sharansky and the angolans released
major to toy
perhaps he did not think any of these
things was likely
sakurao
and sharansky they were released and
major detroit
was released
nelson still languishes in jail
due to celebrate his 70th birthday in
july
why is the united states and its
president and his congress and its
people not agitating
for his
release and holding mr pw to his word
apartheid exports is terrorism and
violence the south african government
has supported renamo in mozambique
a recent state department report shows
the appalling atrocities that these
terrorists have committed and continue
to commit against defenseless civilians
men women and children
my wife and i were in mozambique
at the end of last year and we've seen
some of the victims of this
violence
their help and on a mindless campaign of
brutality and carnage
that is reducing mozambique to a
wasteland it is quite unbelievable that
a former presidential candidate and some
senators and the congressmen in the
united states could actually think that
the people responsible for such
bestiality
should be supported
south africa has supported these vicious
renamo
terrorists
who killed dalsy september
in paris
who killed the anc man in a hospital bed
in maseru who injured alby sex
in maputo
who could want such people liquidated
whose death squads
could want to perpetrate such acts of
terrorism if not those of apartheid
apartheid can't tolerate the experience
experiments in non-racialism and
tolerance in zimbabwe botswana and other
frontline states and so apartheid is
helping on its policy of destabilization
it causes unnecessary and untold
suffering to the people of angola and
namibia
apartheid is a crime against humanity
and a threat to world peace apart it
must be destroyed
i don't want sanctions
i would sing alleluia
if apartheid could be ended without
sanctions
the world has tried for 40 years to
persuade the south african government
gently to end the party
the reagan administration has tried
constructive engagement for over six
years
all these efforts have ended in abject
and dismal failure apartheid remains
firmly in place protected aided and
abetted by the reagan administration by
mrs thatcher by chancellor cole
these people are perhaps not racist
their rhetoric against apartheid is
eloquent
but for the victims of apartheid
they are the most effective and the most
powerful allies
of and collaborators with the vicious
evil immoral and christian and biblical
policy of apartheid
for apartheid victims whether they are
in fact racist is of only irrelevant
academic interest
for apartheid victims capitalism and
free enterprise are the enemies of our
people
for capitalism and free enterprise as we
have experienced them
have been the most effective partners in
our oppression
they are the best recruiters for
communism
and those who aid in the bed are
bargained in the ways that i have
indicated
have domestic policies that are
consistent with their foreign policies
they have penalized the elderly the
disadvantaged students the poor
they have blamed them virtually
for their condition
they have said compassion caring and
concern for the weak are signs of
weakness
they have
favored the rich and the powerful
they have allowed the laws of the jungle
to apply most viciously in their
societies eat or be eaten
survival of the fittest
devil take the hindmost
and the weakest to the wall
chief albert do truly more than two
decades ago asked the world to apply
sanctions against the slavic government
to end our oppression
we see an upsurge of white altruism
on the part of those who claim that
sanctions will hurt those you intend to
help
that altruism is very touching
why is it not evident when you apply
sanctions to nicaragua
to panama to poland to libya
why not the same debate about the
effectiveness or otherwise of sanctions
and whether they will hurt those you
intend to help
in all of these other cases
and then this extraordinary stop history
in the case of south africa
there was an article recently from a
washington correspondent of some south
african newspapers who demonstrated how
the south african coal industry had
benefited from sanctions
now that is interesting
i would expect therefore that you would
get delegations coming from the south
african chamber of mines to lobby for
more sanctions to produce all these
beneficial results
but what is actually happening
who are coming here to lobby against
more sanctions remarkably it is all
these altruistic whites and a few
predictable blacks working within the
system
major black trade unions
members of kosato and others support
sanctions the owner's trolley
is on those who oppose sanctions to
produce a viable non
violent option to end apartheid they
have failed so far to do so reluctantly
but firmly i support the delhi's bill
that is to come before congress
it is such comprehensive mandatory
sanctions which will force the south
african private sector to come to its
senses to pressure in each turn the
south african government to go to the
negotiating table
i wish it were true that increased
economic prosperity would end the party
there is no evidence to support this
fondly held myth
some of the most repressive legislation
in our country was passed not when south
africa had a recession but when our
economy was booming
nothing has changed in south africa
without considerable external pressure
what must the south african government
still do
to arouse your anger and passion to read
the world of the scourge of apartheid
what must we still say
and do which we have not said or done to
engage your support and determination to
end apartheid
what must our people still suffer and
endure
to cause you to be galvanized into
action to end a party
there is severe censorship of the press
our alternative press is under threat
you have heard that new nation has been
suspended
south has been suspended the weekly mail
the sovereign all have a sort of
democracy hanging over over their heads
why are you not appalled by all of this
zoella quesulu and others languish in
jail held for months in detention
without trial why is your level of
tolerance so high in the case of south
africa
and why
is the u.s media
with notable exceptions suddenly so
timid and so coy about reporting stories
that in fact do appear in south african
newspapers
and yet
we are inundated
and i'm glad for this with stuff say on
poland isn't it ironic that there is
free a flow of information from a
communist country
than from one that claims to be western
and democratic
why don't you want to park the system
and demonstrate yet again just how
intolerant how undemocratic how and
western south africa is
how he does things of which repressive
totalitarian governments would be very
proud of
why can't the west tell south africa
that if it passes into law the promotion
of orderly internal politics bill
forbidding foreign funding to opposition
groups that are providing scholarships
legal defense and so on that if they
pass this into law
then they will break off diplomatic
relations or reduce the level of
diplomatic relations
no black jobs in south africa would be
at stake
why don't they say that unless certain
political conditions are met
to end the state of emergency to unpan
political organizations to release
political prisoners and detainees and
allow exile to return unmolested and
then talk on dismantling apartheid and a
new constitution with authentic
representatives of all the people that
they will suspend
telecommunications for a set period and
deny south africa access to the dollar
market
we are asking you to make not a
political
or economic
decision but asking to make a moral
decision
are you on the side of justice or
injustice
are you on the side of oppression or
freedom
are you on the side of humanity
or inhumanity i think president reagan a
highly popular man in the united states
i think mrs thatcher and chancellor cole
and i must add the japanese government
have made a moral decision
they have decided that south african
blacks are expendable
that profits
matter more than the lives of black
children
can you imagine a policy of constructive
engagement with nazism
why then with apartheid
once in a while
the world has to make a moral decision
about a major problem 50 years ago the
moral issue was nazism
in our day it is about it
and i should say
in the case of germans
perhaps you could say you understand
that they've probably not yet got out of
their systems
the madness of aryan
superiority
and the japanese
supported the nazis
but we can't understand it
in the case of the united states of
america
you can't understand it in the case of
britain
what will you tell your grandchildren
when they ask you what you did
will you be able to say my child
i helped the world
get rid of a scourge as horrible as
hitler's nazism
i helped to end apartheid
i helped to bring freedom for all in
south africa
south africa has strategic resources
south africa is important strategically
south africa will still have strategic
resources after liberation
south africa will still be of strategic
importance of the liberation
for we are going to be free
black and white together
and yes
we will remember who helped us to become
free
we want to invite the united states to
our liberation
celebration soon
the court the choice is yours
whether that will happen
help us
hear our creed occur
join the winning site
so
[Applause]
thank you bishop tutu
we have many questions from our audience
today
you said a few minutes ago
that uh you you cited different
individuals in south africa black and
white
who do
uh want sanctions and yet there have
been a number of polls
taken in south africa one of which was
released to some people as they came in
the club today
that indicate that uh if these polls are
correct that a majority of black south
africans indeed
oppose sanctions uh what is your
response to this
my son once told me that statistics
indicate that at the rate at which you
are going
every fifth car will be driverless
let me let me just say that i could i
can produce
surveys which are not my service
one appeared in the sunday times in
london
which indicated that 70 percent of
blacks
supported sanctions
but you see i i am not saying
i
am representing blacks
i have come to make my point of view
i say
that is what i believe to be right
and other people have a right to say
differently
but
i am archbishop of a church that is 80
black
and 20 white
i have still to be called by a black
congregation
justify your call for sanctions all the
calls that i have had to answer
come from my white congregations
i have not yet had one
credible
black organization or leader
i've said so in my speech
accept the predictable ones
say bishop tutu
you have no right to do what you are
doing
let me ask you specifically about uh
chief bootalezzi of the kwazulu
uh he as i understand is is opposed to
sanctions and yet he certainly is a
credible leader of the largest group of
blacks in south africa
i i am a libertarian
and as a libertarian
i would say that i will
i will
defend to the death
his right or anybody else's right to
their point of view
just show me even in this wonderful
country
any
instance where you say that on every
issue there is unanimity
[Applause]
a two-part question
what is the level of sanctions you
believe is necessary to force the white
south african government to
fundamentally change its apartheid
policy
and number two if no level of sanctions
does it would you favor some form of
military force by the international
community against the present government
the level
it's a very straightforward question the
level is the is the level which will end
the party
i mean that that is the that is the
point the point of sanctions is not to
destroy that country
the point of sanctions is to try to
knock sense into the heads of those who
rule in that country
and say to them you know
we want to sit with you we want to sit
with you we want we want to be able to
share this beautiful country with you
and we've got a wonderful example of
what happens when blacks actually get
power everybody said when mr mugabe's
party won that general election the
first general election under
independence would be the last
ian smith
remained a member of parliament
after a bruising war
we are stepping up obviously we are
stepping up the nt depending on the
intransigence of the south african
government
i would hope i mean that
the second part of your question would
not need to be answered
it would not need to be answered if this
country did what it ought to do
how do black south africans regard the
united states as a model of western
democracy after seven years of reagan
policy
our people are actually
in in a strange way
very sophisticated
uh politically
as regard the reagan administration you
should ask how wild south africans most
whites are up against regard
and then you will know that
if they say
they share
then you can say we are quite sure that
it will be the opposite with blacks
in terms of our perception
america is the pits
no no no
only insofar as that
constructive engagement
goes
the people of america
the students
the inter-party movement
all of those who helped to change the
moral climate in this country so that
you passed
sanctions legislation
made people say hey
the american people are different from
their government
and the american people
are admired
you can say a lot of awful things about
your country but you you still have to
say that this is the one country in the
world
where a black person
could become a serious
presidential candidate
and and so when you sometimes feel
that we're being nasty to you
know that there are a lot of things that
we admire
and we will actually have a naive
faith in you
[Applause]
does disinvestment in south africa by
american companies really make sense
aren't japanese businesses and other
foreign investors moving in to fill the
void
i
i said
you do something that is right because
it is right
now i won't use the analogy
there's an analogy that i often use and
my wife doesn't like it so i won't i
want to use that analogy i'll use a
slightly more elegant analogy
i notice that you're disappointed
you go up to someone and you say look
they are going to steal your car
if i don't steal it
they are going to steal it so i'm going
to steal it
[Applause]
there are a number of questions in our
audience
who asks something like this how do you
think the black on black violence can be
stopped
to create a united opposition to
apartheid is there any hope for such
coming together of the groups
in such a way
yeah
i've got a fellow bishop from from our
province in south africa
richard kraft the bishop of pretoria
and
he would bear out
that we are very deeply concerned about
violence whether it is black on black
violence
and we've been
doing all we could
to try to stop it
but as i have indicated here
one the state has a stake
in in this kind of thing
in the in the in the natal area
you would have thought that
if they were going to
restrict anybody then they would have to
restrict people on both sides of that of
that strife but they they they take away
the one person with whom any
negotiations for peace ought to happen
but let me
let me become slightly more
philosophical and say
we
in asking that question almost always
sort of at the back of our minds
want to suggest that it is a phenomenon
peculiar
to south african blacks
it isn't
you know
that when the children of israel left
left egypt
all those many many many millennia ago
the moment they they got out there was
already strife
within
that community
many said we want to go back to the
fleshpots in egypt and people have not
changed
people are still the same there are
people who still think that they can
they can line their pockets
by
collaborating with their oppressors
it happened in germany as well
jews collaborated with with the german
authorities
and
and whenever you are striving for
justice
people treat with short shrift those
they consider to be
traitors
you should look at what they are doing
in northern ireland
black south africans happen to be
human beings you may not i mean that
sounds a scientific uh discovery of
momentous
they are human beings and we
who say we believe in the bible
ought to know
the reality of the bible the bible says
there is something called
original sin
it is for real
today's oppressed
can and often become tomorrow's
oppressors
and we who are believers are not to be
surprised that that is so
we ought to say
it is remarkable
that not more are like that
there have been concerns expressed that
if south africa indeed gains one man one
vote
that tribal animosities will result in a
bloodbath for example between groups
such as the kosa and the zulu what is
your response to that
on one occasion
at the gathering i was i thought i was
really going great guns and saying
we most of us are detribalized
and i was saying
i have a course of father and uh and and
my mother is a mutual
what does that make me and i thought i'd
really put a wonderful point
and and harry belafonte sitting at the
back said a zulu
but but the point actually the point is
if you take the anc as a paradigm
the anc has had
dr morocco as its president dr morocco
is a mutual
it has had dr truma who is torso as a
president it has had
albert leutulli who is zulu
and
in order to demonstrate
the eagerness of our people to come
together at all at our political
meetings in the townships
extraordinarily the language that is
used is english
because it is the lingua franca
and who are the people who have been
interested in exacerbating tribalism
the government
they they they know but that's an old
floyd dividing rule
divide and rule i
well yes
you know people
will find excuses
when they want to delay the inevitable
you people said the much the same thing
about zimbabwe
but there they've come together
i mean one doesn't say it is all hungry
dory but
shouldn't the world be saying
we have a remarkable thing that has
happened here
after one of the most bruising
bush wars
when mugabe wins
on the night of his victory he says the
policy of our government is going to be
reconstruction rehabilitation
reconciliation
and the world ought to have said
you are a liar
but
you go to zimbabwe today
and you walk the streets of harare
you are amazed i mean i don't know why
we should be amazed but it is the most
relaxed
country it is the most relaxed
and
white people who fled
rhodesians who fled to south africa
are flocking back to zimbabwe
because
who says they don't have problems they
have problems after your own
independence yeah
didn't you
soon have a a civil war
but i mean i think we we
we ought we ought to be saying let us
assist
these experiments what has your country
done
you know your country is very strange i
said what must the south africans still
do to anger you
zimbabwe
annoyed your government
by how it voted in the u.n
it wasn't violating
human rights
and
you know that up to now
your aid to zimbabwe has been docked
just like that
and here is a country that is seeking to
show the world
that it is possible
even after a thing like that
war of liberation for people of all
races
to live together amicably
and you ought to be saying we want to
invest there
so that that ex the south africans don't
want that experiment to succeed
they don't want that experiment in
botswana to succeed
they will destabilize like hell
and for goodness sake
why do you want to help them do that why
do you want to help them to do that
have the press restrictions in south
africa resulted in less violence there
what is the proper role for foreign
correspondents working in south africa
i
i really get
sad
that people
can actually ask that question
i mean suggest that
our children
are prepared to run the gauntlet
of tear gas of police dogs of the kind
of things that you used to see
on your screens just in order to satisfy
you here
that they want to perform
that our children want to be killed
just in order to satisfy you
i i think it's a disgrace
for anybody to say that of our children
that
our children go out in front of cameras
just in order to make the world think
we are oppressed
i think it's a scandalous thing for you
people to think that our children are in
detention now
despite the fact that your cameras are
not there
our people are being uprooted now
and and treated as if they were rubbish
your cameras are not there
what the hell does the southern
government
need to hide
if it is nothing to hide
and i i just think i mean that
do be kind to us
i don't enjoy coming to this country
and come
and display our pain
as if i'm an actor
i'm talking about things that are
matters of life and death my dear
friends
and you
you
you have a critical role to play
don't think i mean i am a masochist who
enjoys showing off my pain and the pain
of our people
i come here because i still think that
a moral appeal to you
can work
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
we have come near the end of our time
before asking one final question
bishop tutu i would like to present you
with a certificate of our appreciation
for being here
and the national press club paperweight
thank you thank you thank you
one final question
in the stress and danger of your
position what sustains you personally in
your work
i don't think we have to spend too much
time on that
if if you are engaged in a liberation
struggle
you expect for there to be casualties
and
nobody is given special exemption
and wonderfully
nobody is indispensable
[Applause]
that ends our luncheon thank you
[Music]
you've been watching an address at the
national press club by archbishop
desmond tutu of south africa
we'd like to remind our viewers that
tomorrow evening will air the hubert
humphrey awards ceremony held by the
leadership conference on civil rights
that's sunday at 11 pm eastern time 8
pacific
[Music]
[Music]
on wednesday transafrica held a forum
suggesting ways the united states might
help in bringing about the end to
apartheid in south africa
coming up next we bring you that meeting
among those you'll hear from are
lawmakers south african archbishop
desmond tutu and the reverend jesse
jackson
[Music]
good morning
all of us are honored to be here today
with desmond tutu alan bosack and bears
nowday
8 000 miles is a long way to come
for a congressional forum
in fact it is a journey much longer than
that a journey that all of us are a part
of
a journey that has become the greatest
human rights struggle of our time
the journey to freedom and justice for
all the people of south africa
we are here today to learn from our
three courageous guests
more than any others they have aroused
the conscience of the world against the
fundamental inhumanity of apartheid
our hope is that this forum can be a new
beginning
none of us can be satisfied with the
divided american voice of the past
united states cannot end apartheid
that is a challenge for south africa and
south africans but the united states has
a role to play
with our heritage and history america of
all nations
shares the goal of a free south africa
and america helps most in that struggle
when america speaks with one voice
works with one heart
and thinks with one mind immobilizing
other nations to our cause
part of our discussion this morning will
center on the role
of international economic sanctions and
their impact on south africa
no one in congress expected the modest
u.s sanctions enacted in 1986 to end
apartheid or even have a major impact
but we did expect the sanctions to
become part of a coordinated worldwide
effort to produce the kind of pressure
that could make a difference with the
south african regime
that is why in the legislation itself
congress call for international
cooperation
but the sanctions legislation of 1986
was not the only measure vetoed by the
past administration
they also veto the united nations
resolution that would have made
international cooperation possible
now we are in a new congress
and a new administration
instead of rushing to re-fight all
battles we intend to seek new
possibilities
if the new administration is ready and
willing to move forward against
apartheid we can move forward together
under the leadership of the president
i would hope that the president bush
will meet personally with our
distinguished visitors
all of us hope that the divisions of the
past eight years
are behind us
but symbols are no substitute for
substance
kinder and gentler does not mean
apartheid
now is the time to move ahead not stand
in place
now is the time to work with other
nations not go it alone
now is the time to end apartheid
it is my privilege now to introduce one
of the strongest allies in this effort a
man who is a leader of civil rights in
our own country
and human rights around the world
majority leader of the united states
senate
senator george mitchell
thank you very much
senator kennedy i
extend a warm welcome to all of the
participants here today
particularly to our distinguished south
african guests archbishop tutu reverend
bosack and reverend nade
we have an important task before us
we recognize apartheid in south africa
for what it is
an affront to god
and to human decency
a system intolerable to all peoples
especially to the people of south africa
themselves
sadly
since the united states enacted the
comprehensive anti-apartheid act of in
1986
the situation in south africa has grown
worse
a nationwide state of emergency is in
effect
stripping non-white south africans of
their most fundamental human rights
anti-apartheid organizations have been
banned
and media censorship has resulted in a
virtual news blackout
tens of thousands of south africans have
been detained since 1986
some have been held without charge or
trial
for more than a thousand days
clearly
the international community
including the united states must do
everything in its power
to promote the immediate dismantling of
the repressive system of apartheid
now is the time to formulate
a new policy
toward this end
the openness of the bush administration
signified by the presence here today of
hermann cohen the new assistant
secretary of state for african affairs
is encouraging
i commend the administration's
stated willingness
to make south africa a high priority
no policy can succeed
unless the executive and legislative
branches
are unified in their approach
i welcome the administration's stated
willingness to consider
all forms of measures to end apartheid
and its commitment to pursuing
multilateral action
toward that objective
i am convinced that the combined
energies of those assembled here today
can create new alternatives for the
united states and its allies to pursue
we agree upon the end the abolition of
apartheid
we must now reach agreement upon the
means
we must find an effective and
sustainable policy to achieve
our shared goal a unified
bipartisan approach can
and i hope will emerge from discussions
such as those held here today
in this important work
i wish us all
godspeed
it is now my pleasure to introduce the
distinguished gentleman from texas
the honorable jim wright speaker of the
house of representatives
senator kennedy has spoken of the
journey longer
than 8 000 miles
which has been made by our three
distinguished guests today
and in a sense it is a journey even
longer than that that
we continue
by our presence here
2 000 years ago
on mars hill in athens
paul of tarsus spoke of
a god who had created of one blood all
the nations of men for to dwell on the
face of the earth
and a little over 200 years ago
thomas jefferson in writing the
declaration of independence
spoke that
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
and are endowed by the creator with
certain unalienable rights among them
life and liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
those rights if they're to have meaning
surely must
include the right to live where one will
to
work where one
will
to associate with
whomever one will
and those rights are being
systematically denied
in south africa to 28 million
black people
and so here in this place that has been
called the repository of the democratic
principle
we welcome you to this forum
and we take great pride in welcoming our
three
outstanding guests
as we continue this journey together
to the time when
the search for peace
among the nations
of the earth will be also a search for
justice and in which we may join
multilaterally
and the insistence that apartheid must
end
thank you for letting us be here and
welcome
to
this form
man who continues to inspire the members
of congress
and millions of americans
and millions of people all over the of
the world
the leader of transafrica randall
robinson
thank you senator kennedy
today we are honored to have with us
three of south africa's and indeed the
world's most respected human rights
leaders
they have traveled a great distance to
discuss with leaders of our nation
ways in which we might all join to
enhance chances for a democratic result
in south africa
introductions of our distinguished
guests
will be made by congressman howard
wolfie
congressman ronald ellums
and senator paul simon
congressman wolfie
thank you very much randall
i'm delighted to have the honor today of
introducing the reverend alan bosack a
man of singular courage drive and
intellect in the struggle to end
apartheid
he is a friend whose outrage over the
true nature of the apartheid regime and
his vision of the responsibilities of
the world have left a deep mark not only
in the chambers of the american congress
but also in the minds of the american
people
today as we again struggle with the
challenge of south africa
we're immensely fortunate that alan is
present as he has been at many early
difficult points of decision
to interpret the evolving realities of
south africa
and to advise us of what we here can do
to assist
alan's imprint is now permanent
expansive and constantly evolving
it was his leadership in 1982 which led
the world alliance of churches
representing some 70 million people
worldwide to declare apartheid a heresy
a critical step in eroding the
intellectual and religious basis of that
system
the following day he was elected
president of that body a position he
still holds
this is leadership in 1983 that helped
to inspire the formation of the united
democratic front the multi-racial
umbrella organization of hundreds of
groups that exposed the bankruptcy of
the south african government's new
constitutional provisions
and successfully boycotted the
tricameral elections of august of 84.
as the police state has assumed ever
greater power in maintaining white
minority rule
it has been alan who took the lead in
branding the south african defense
forces one of the most sophisticated
murder machines in history
at great personal risk he has repeatedly
defied these very forces the severe
restrictions placed on him the arrests
and periods of milita of solitary
confinement to lead peaceful protest
marches to issue demands that community
leaders and black townships be left in
peace
to organize community meetings and
consumer boycotts and to speak loudly to
the world of the realities of south
african repression
when scores were gunned down in the
eastern cape in 1985 and the 25th
anniversary of sharpville
it was alan who with reverend bayer's
nade led hundreds to parliament were
surrounded by police they sang onward
christian soldiers
when scores were killed and thousands
displaced in crossroads it was alan who
called the world's attention to the
human devastation wrought by police and
vigilante action
and let me say finally that
there are few foreign policy issues that
arouse
in americans deeper feelings and more
intense passions than the issue of south
africa
for the struggle against apartheid and
for freedom and democracy in south
africa evokes so much of our own history
and activates so many of the same fears
and prejudices in america that are at
the core of the south african struggle
we're privileged today to have present
three leaders who have helped all of us
to understand that the continuing
struggles for social justice in america
and south africa are in fact inseparable
for that we are all under debt
congressman bellam
thank you very much mr chairman it is
now my distinguished pleasure to
introduce one of our
uh distinguished um
guest of the
morning
mr baird
buyers nordic
who is the son of a dutch reformed
church minister who fought in the
anglo-boer war
and dr norton himself is trained in
theology from 1940 until 1963
dr northey served as a minister of the
dutch reform church eventually assuming
a senior position in the church
hierarchy in 1960 he became the first
editor
of a new ecumenical monthly magazine pro
verite
the main contributions of dr norte and
the paper
were their opposition to the policy of
apartheid and the promotion of the
growth of the ecumenical movement in
south africa
in 1963 dr norte gave up his position as
a minister of the dutch reform church
and accepted the position of the first
director of a new multiracial
organization of christians the christian
institute the south african government
declared pro-verte and christian
institute unlawful in 1977
and placed severe restrictions on dr
noughty by means of a banning order
which was finally lifted in 1984.
in
1985 through 1987 dr nordy served as
general secretary of the south african
council of churches currently he is
active in the ecumenical field in south
africa and acts as an advisor and
consultant to various bodies he is a
trustee of various organizations in
south africa which assists disadvantaged
people in educational and other spheres
dr norte is the recipient of a number of
honorary degrees numerous awards
underscoring his commitment to human
beings
in 1984 dr norte was a candidate for the
nobel peace prize it is with those words
that i introduced our distinguished
guest for the morning dr bears nordic
senator simon
it is an honor to be able to introduce
bishop tutu
in an informal casual remark last night
maurice tepelzman talking about u.s
soviet relations said it's amazing how
well u.s
and soviets
can get along once the ice starts to
melt
i think the same is true in south africa
if we can get that ice melting so that
the fears of whites diminish in the
hopelessness
of the blacks
can also be reduced
i think we'll be amazed how well people
can get along
but that will happen only
if justice
can come to south africa
and our three guests here from south
africa have stood courageously for
justice
it is easy
for those of us who are americans here
to stand up for justice
it is not so easy for our guests
and they have stood up with great
courage
if you were to take a poll around the
world
about who stands up for justice in this
world i am sure
one of the winners in any such poll
would be bishop tutu
because he has come to symbolize
justice
for the people of the world
and particularly
in south africa
it's an honor
to introduce him here today
thank you we will hear first from
reverend bosak followed by reverend
norday
followed by archbishop desmond tutu
reverend bosai thank you mr robinson
thank you senator kennedy ladies and
gentlemen good morning
i must begin by expressing our thanks
for this forum and for the opportunity
at this particular time
in the history of our country
at this time in the history of the
united states to once again be able to
focus
on the relationships between the us and
south africa and the focus especially on
those areas where we ask the question
what is it
that we can do
to try and bring the situation in south
africa to such a conclusion
that we will not face the kind of blood
spilling that so many in our country are
already fearing
and that we could stop the bloodshed
that is already happening
i must also begin by first of all
apologizing for the reverend frank
jakani
who was to be part of our delegation
came to the united states but became
very seriously ill
he is in a hospital in wisconsin and he
is stable and doing
reasonably well under the circumstances
but we miss him in this delegation and
i'm sure he would want us to tell you
how much he would have wanted to be here
and to apologize in his behalf
ladies and gentlemen
there are many who have speculated about
this visit
and there are many who have expected us
to come here
to offer what some people would call yet
another indictment of the south african
government
we have not come here to do that in the
first instance
because the south african government
itself is its own indictment
for if south africa had been a
democratic country
if our people had had the right to vote
if our people had had the opportunity to
express freely our own political opinion
and preferences in our political will
if our leadership had not been
imprisoned for so long now
and if the organizations of our people
had not been banned
the south african government in its
present form would not have existed
so the fact that it does exist in in the
way that it exists today is its own
indictment
it is not necessary for us here to come
and make that point
the deeds of the south african
government itself
are its own indictment
that is the state of emergency which
remains the cover for continued
oppression and the brutalization of our
people including legalized murder
there is a non-existence of a truly free
press
so that the opinions of our people
cannot be discussed or debated or
expressed
there is the constant threat to those
who fight for justice
coupled with the violence without which
apartheid cannot exist the most recent
most horrendous example being the
cold-blooded assassination of david
webster
there is the deadly dissatisfaction yes
indeed
the seething anger just below the
surface in our townships
and these all in effect form an
indictment of the south african
government
and for all who have eyes to see
will know that beyond the ability of the
south african government to muzzle the
press and therefore to keep large
sections of the world community ignorant
of what is happening beyond that ability
still lives the reality which black
south africans and all people of good
will in that country must face day after
day after day
and we also know that unless the south
african government is willing to lift
the state of emergency and allow the
normal
discussion of the issues of the day
which all face south africans unless
that happens there will not be the
lessening of violence that we are going
through every day
there are those who have expected us to
come here to quote unveil something new
unquote
i would have loved to do that today
but in a sense we are here not to unveil
anything new but to simply remind you of
our people's long struggle against
racism oppression and injustice and
apartheid
and right through this history
there was a search for justice and peace
for all our people we should always be
in the hallmark of the struggle
and for all these years black south
africans have pleaded
for negotiations
that vote chief luthori we have found
that we have stood before a locked door
our willingness to work towards peaceful
settlement of the problems of our
country is well documented
from the earliest petitions to the
throne of england
to the conviction expressed in the
freedom charter of the early 50s that
south africa belongs to all of its
children black as well as white to the
most recent proposals of the african
national congress which also are
documented for all to read and i would
venture to say that no reasonable person
could basically disagree in what we have
been saying all these years about the
future of our own country in that sense
ladies and gentlemen what
we have come to say to you cannot be
anything new
and i am proud of the fact that we do
not have to offer anything new but
simply have to underline with you this
morning the basic commitment that has
always been present in the struggle of
oppressed people in south africa for our
freedom
it is really you know in a in
a sense it is really up to the south
african government
to offer something new
it is up to the south african government
to finally learn the language of
religion the language of justice and
language of democracy and to offer us
something else in the place of the
language of threat and violence and
oppression
something else in the place of the
defense of white minority rule and
apartheid we have not up to this moment
heard anything that is substantially new
we are here to hope that we will go find
a way in which the south african
government can be brought to the
realization that it must learn to speak
this new language in order to open up
opportunities for peaceful change in
south africa and is in this search that
we are here to invite the united states
of america its government and its people
to help us to make sure that these
avenues are found and once found that
they are vigorously explored
out of this long and proud tradition
we have certain affirmations that have
crystallized
we are committed ladies and gentlemen to
democracy
and for us that means one person one
vote in a unitary state
trust that means meaningful
participation of all our people at all
levels of government
for us that means also in a country
where 85 percent of its inhabitants are
black that we are working toward black
majority rule we are not working towards
the exclusion of everybody else but the
realities have to be
tabled here today quite clearly and
quite unashamedly
we are working towards an independent
judiciary
we are committed to the principles of
equality before the law
the principle of the rule of law the
principle of due process
we want a bill of rights that would be
respected by the government as well as
by the people
we are committed to an economy where
people matter
where there shall be the reasonable
redistribution of wealth and the
resources to benefit all of south
africa's people we are committed to a
society in which the rights of people
will be held sacred in which the rights
of children the rights of women the
rights of those who form the weakest
part of our societies will be called
sacrament
there is a time in the life of every
nation nelson mandela said
where you either fight or submit
in the light of that decisions have been
made in the democratic struggle in south
africa decisions that now include armed
struggle
we
are here to reaffirm once again
that we are still looking for another
way
we have come to express our conviction
that the south african government is not
committed to peace and justice that
there is no sign that it is committed to
a negotiated settlement and in as much
as this is happening in namibia
we are convinced that it is happening
because of the concerted pressure that
had been put on the south african
government
without that same kind of pressure put
on the south african government
vis-a-vis south africa the same process
towards the negotiated settlement will
not happen in south africa itself
and so we are here to say to you also
that this pressure is absolutely needed
diplomatic pressure political pressure
economic pressure
we are here to affirm once again that
targeted well-selected sanctions can be
the most meaningful tool to bring the
south african government to the
negotiating table we are not here to
tell you that sanctions will solve all
our problems we're certainly not here to
tell you that sanctions we see as a
means in it as an end in itself
sanctions are however a very very very
important means to gain the end that we
are looking for and i for myself would
mention that financial sanctions with an
eye on the possibility of the debt
crisis again come next june 1990 the
question of oil the question of airlinks
the question of coal and gold are me the
kind of sanctions that we should be
concentrating on which i feel would be
far more effective if we can get this in
the kind of way that has been proposed
in the united states already what i'm
asking is for the united states to take
the sanction package that it has
to add these targeted sanctions and to
make sure that it takes the lead in
creating the kind of forum
internationally where this could not
only be discussed but the sanctions
could actually be applied
and
i would end by
saying to the u.s administration we have
come to a point where you can take the
lead
we have come to say to you
that we black people in south africa can
actually fight pretoria on its own
it is extraordinary difficult however to
fight pretoria and london and bond and
washington and tokyo at the same time
and so we're here for you to make
choices
side with those in south africa who are
for democracy and freedom and justice of
our people it would be very good if this
administration would take the bold
initiative in the absence of mr nelson
mandela to invite president oliver tombo
of the african national congress to talk
to him so that he can see for himself
what kind of a person those many south
africans who take them as it take him as
their leader have chosen and why
these are the initiatives that we hope
that they will take at this particular
time
in our question to you will you today
make the decision stand with us so that
in south africa violence can be stopped
a catastrophe can be averted and our
people's freedom black and white can be
guaranteed and the us can in this
country yet play the proud role it has
denied itself for so many years thank
you
thank you dr bosack
now we will hear from reverend norday
mr robinson
our sponsors ladies and gentlemen
i think it is important to ask right at
the beginning what seems to me to be a
fundamental question
why is this moment
so appropriate for the u s government
to take a decisive stand
with regard to the crisis in south
africa
i speak to you as an african honor
knowing that i understand
even though they may disavowed us
the deepest feelings and the fears
of the afrikaner people who at the
present moment rule
south africa
at the present moment
the national party political leadership
of africanus
is
divided
and in confusion
the resignation of hunus
as well as
estava butter of the labor party in the
town
are indications of the inner tensions
which there are at present
within the national spot
add to that please the lack of vision of
f w the clerk who is to become the new
state prison
in a policy speech which he made on
saturday
it is true that on the one hand he
called for drastic and speedy changes
but he also strongly rejected majority
rule
on a common voter's role
it is true that he stated that the
national party policy was
based on the principle of justice for
all
but he wants to build it
on separate power bases for the
different ethnic groups in south africa
if there is one re one lesson that the
united states and its history has
learned the world and especially south
africa
it is this that you cannot have a
separate but equal political policy
in a country which is geographically and
economically integrated
and as long as the nationalist party and
as long as the whites of south africa
refuse to face
and to accept that for them at the
present moment unpalatable truth
we will have no peace
and justice in our country
as far as mr clark is concerned he
wishes to gain the support of the
majority of our people
the blacks
on involving the so-called moderate
blacks
in national forms of different kinds
in which they will participate in some
vague form of political inclusion
towards some form
of participation
in the political decisions of the
country
but if even manga suitable
declines to be included in this kind of
discussion
and whilst we know that the vast
majority of those who are included by
the government
are community councillors
in their within the whole framework of
the national party policy
there is not the least possibility that
anything meaningful could come out of
that
there is a severe danger that the
outside world again
as in the past
will be confused
and even may be fooled
by the new image of a new
leader the report
has appeared two days ago in our press
of fw declared possibly meeting with
margaret thatcher
and with president bush
i want to emphasize very strongly the
fact
that in the past number of years time
and again
both the business community inside south
africa and the outside world
have been fooled and misled
by claims which were made by the
nationalist party that a new approach
with a new image and a new direction was
being presented to the world
as long as the nationalist party refuses
to face the fundamental challenge
our political rights of the vast
majority of our people 28 million out of
32
no form of so-called reform
no new approach
can make any fundamental difference to
the struggle in our country
and that is why there's the urgent need
for significant pressure
on the south african government
no meaningful change i am convinced
especially on the africanus will be
possible except through significant
pressure
as has already been indicated by dr alan
busan
we've seen this very clearly time and
again that the most recent example is
that of angola
where superior arms
linked to the escalating cost of defence
forced south africa
to negotiate with regard to namibia
could i add another aspect of the
situation in our country which needs to
be taken into account
there are the serious economic problems
that we are facing
the growing external debt
the high rate of inflation
officially stated by the government to
be 14
but generally accepted in our country by
knowledgeable people to be now 31
there is the growing unemployment
an employment which is not in the first
place linked to the question of
sanctions but was there long before any
mention of sanctions were made in our
country
there is the growing cost of defence
and above all
there is the political mood of our
people at the grassroots
the mood which is generally not known
and not felt
because of the extensive media
repression which is taking place
but which is there
which is active
and which could become much more
meaningful
and possibly also dangerous
there is the growing conflict between
the political status quo
both black and white on the one hand and
the the actions for liberation
undertaken by the majority of our people
in their struggle for freedom
mention has been made by the emergency
regulations and the effect that they
have had in our having
the detentions and the bannings and the
hunger strikes of people
expressing the clear indication
of what lives in the hearts of our
people
there is the conflict in the black
community presented by the south african
government as a conflict of violence
between black and black on the face of
it yes
that is how it is seen but in the
deepest sense of the word
it is a conflict between the political
status quo on the one hand and those who
are struggling for liberation on the
other hand and please do not be fooled
by that kind of government propaganda
i wish to close by asking three
questions
those of us who have come here to the
united states
what are we asking
the answer is in the founding statement
which has been presented to you
and we know that we can call upon you
to read and reflect upon it very
carefully
as expressing our deep and heartfelt
convictions
the second question is
is what we're asking is it reasonable
and realistic
we believe that to be the case
and for those who disagree with us
who may say that this is not the case we
are asking the one
fundamental and serious question
if you do not agree with us
what is the alternative that you present
for the sake of justice and peace in our
country
the third question is
which country at the present moment can
play the most meaningful and decisive
role in assisting us in south africa to
achieve that goal
i am convinced that because of the
specific developments which have taken
place
in the world
including here in the united states
in the ussr and elsewhere
the one country
which at the present moment is in the
decisive position
to steer our country and to influence it
towards meaningful negotiation for the
sake of justice and peace
is the united states
administration
we know that
the general indication has been given
that margaret thatcher would be given
the opportunity to take the lead
we've made the point in our founding
statement
that although there is a
minority influence which he can indicate
with regard to the whites
we would wish to plead and to emphasize
with you
that the united kingdom has got very
little credibility as far as the
feelings of the majority of our people
are concerned
and that is why we plead with you
and we ask that you should heed our call
for the sake of justice and peace
of both black and white
i speak as a white person
i speak as an african
i speak as somebody
with all the love of my heart would wish
to see
that we
obtain a new country and a new future
where all of us
black and white
will be able to live in understanding
and in harmony and in peace it is
possible
we call upon you help us
thank you reverend noah day archbishop
desmond tutu
thank you very much
i start by expressing
profound gratitude to
transafrica
forum especially to randall robinson to
senator kennedy
senators kennedy simon and congressman
ron dellums and howard warby and to you
all dear friends gathered on this
momentous and unprecedented occasion
our thanks to very profound and
heartfelt thanks to the american people
for your concern for the suffering
message of our people in south africa
for your commitment to our struggle for
a non-racial just
and democratic south africa
thank you
all of you who have been ready to bring
all sorts of treasures
to bear on the south african government
political diplomatic
sports
cultural and academic pressures
to get the south african government to
the negotiating table
those pressures especially
the pressures of
economic
sanctions
are effective
and are working
why else
the publication of the result of a poll
yesterday to show that blacks are
opposed to sanctions
what a wonderful coincidence
south africa is now negotiating over
namibia
and as dr bears
nadir indicated
we believe
that that is so because sanctions made
it increasingly difficult for south
africa to continue her destabilizing war
in angola
we have come here primarily
as dr busak
has indicated
we have come here primarily
to underscore our concern
to end apartheid
that is the fundamental
reason for us being here
and if apartheid could end without
sanctions
i would as i have said many times before
be the first to shout alleluia
our primary purpose is to enlist your
support
to get the south african government to
the negotiating table
to
usher in the new south africa
whose coming is as inevitable
as the sun's rising
in the east
nothing can stop us
black and white
in south africa becoming truly free
in a genuine
non-racial democracy
we are committed
to
the negotiating
stunts
we have been involved
in negotiations
i
in a personal capacity
since 1975
when
i wrote
to the then prime minister of south
africa
a month
before june 16 1976
we three
together with
frank chikani
have on various occasions
indicated our
commitment to negotiation we have been
negotiating very recently with the
minister of law and order
dear friends
on the 6th of september
1989
south africa will go to the polls
a record i think third time
in three years
a very terrible orgy
of elections
1989
is 11 years
to the beginning of the 21st century
i am an archbishop
i am metropolitan
of the church of the province of
southern africa
i am a nobel laureate
i will not participate
in that election
i will not participate because
by law i cannot participate
chief gadja bhutel
will not participate
because by law he cannot participate
as 73 percent
of the population
of south africa
11 years from the beginning of the 21st
century
they will not participate in elections
because they are elections based on race
elections are the normal non-violent
democratic way of changing a system you
don't like
that method is excluded
for our people who are non-violent to a
fault
even today still
seeking to use non-violent strategies
such as rent and consumer boycotts
in the face of
state violence
violence
detention without child even the
detention of children
in the face of the activity of death
squads
in the face of the violence of forced
population removals
we are committed to non-violence
and to negotiation
on september the 6th
1939
50 years ago
the world went to war
against the scourge
of nazism
on september the 6th
1989
another scourge
apartheid
which says a child of god
is less than a child of god
because of a biological irrelevance
skin color
is going to hold
an election
we are not asking you
to go
[Music]
to a military war
against apartheid
but you have the opportunity
of taking the moral leadership of the
world in the struggle against apartheid
we are asking you in 1989
50 years after the start of world war ii
11 years before the start of the 21st
century
help us
please help us end a part eight
it is a fundamentally unstable system
based on injustice
and it can be maintained
only by the violence of brutal
repression censorship and state of
emergency
and the abrogation of the rule of law
your intervention is critical
we don't want our land destroyed
apartheid is destroying our land and its
peoples
and the peoples of the surrounding
countries
help us
and the pressure of financial sanctions
such as those which dr alan busta
referred to
are crucial
you can end about 8 tomorrow
if you wish
friends
we are going to be free
what will you tell your children
you did
to help us in the process of becoming
free
friends
we are going to be free
and we want to be able
to invite you
come
celebrate with us
our freedom
[Applause]
thank you very much archbishop tutu i
will now open the floor for a general
discussion
so that all who wish to speak may have
an opportunity to do so please limit to
two minutes your comments or questions
to our distinguished guests
each speaker will be entitled to one
follow-up question or comment of 30
seconds or less
the lights before me will serve as our
timekeeper
please indicate your desire to speak by
raising your name card and keeping it
raised until your signal is acknowledged
i will recognize those who wish to speak
and the order in which your names are
taken down
we will begin our comments with
congressman stephen solars congressman
solas
thank you very much
randall let me say first how pleased i
am to see the panelists today whom i've
been honored and privileged to meet on
several occasions in south africa
i think there's probably a profound
sense on the part of all of us here
today
that their hopes or our hopes
their struggle is our struggle
and their triumph will be our triumph
the question that preoccupies us of
course is how we can most effectively
contribute
to the eventual establishment
of a more decent and democratic
government in south africa in which all
of the people of the country can
participate as equals
and here i think we confront
a serious and significant tactical
question
on which the advice and judgment
of our guests would be most helpful
we have for the last
couple of years attempted without
success
largely because of opposition in the
senate
to enact a comprehensive sanctions bill
it has passed on two occasions in the
house
with the leadership of ron dellums and
howard wolfie and and others but we have
run into resistance in the senate
and i think it would be helpful if you
could let us know whether
in light of that resistance from your
point of view
it would be helpful if we were to seek
an incremental increase in sanctions a
ratcheting up of sanctions
even if it falls short of comprehensive
sanctions
if it appeared that it might be possible
to muster the
support that would be necessary to enact
legislation along those lines
or whether you feel at this particular
point in the struggle
it would be best for us to continue the
fight
for comprehensive sanctions
even if it might take us somewhat longer
to enact that kind of legislation
the bishop has indicated that i shall
respond and i shall be obedient
mr solas yes that that is a very crucial
question and i have indicated in my
remarks
that what we think is necessary now at
this point is to look
for those sanctions which could be most
effective
it will take
my guesses a long time to get the kind
of comprehensive sanctions that the
trade unions in south africa are still
asking for and so many people are still
arguing for
my own feeling is very very clear
if the united states could
upgrade the sanctions get an incremental
sanction package together
and if it could be if it could include
those specific things that we have
mentioned
and if the u.s
would take the lead
in making sure that the european
partners and most specifically japan
would join you
in that package of sanctions
even if
just the sanctions that you have
the u.s would take to the united nations
and make that
the basis for work within the u.n with
regard to south africa i am absolutely
sure that both
the physical impact of those sanctions
and the psychological impact of those
sanctions could be responsible for a
very remarkable change in climate in the
south african situation which could tell
the south african government that either
it will begin to be reasonable and talk
about how the situation is going to be
fundamentally changed and begin to talk
with the authentic leaders of the black
people in south africa or if they don't
do that then again we will have to they
will have to face the kind of sanctions
package that we are talking about
by by feeling is if you could do that
it would be better it would be more
effective than trying to wait and see
whether five years from now we will be
able to read some concerns about
comprehensive sanctions that we may not
even get at that time
congressman font roy
thank you mr chairman and
i too want to express our heartfelt
appreciation to our guests for
this historic gathering senator sarbanes
and i chair subcommittees respectively
in the house and senate that are
addressing themselves to the question of
third world debt
and we are determined in this congress
to give some leadership on that question
my question runs to the fact that as you
know on june the 30th next year 1990
the
standstill agreement
which was negotiated by
the banks in five western nations
come to an end and 11 billion dollars
is
coming due
additionally we understand another one
billion dollars in bonds come due
my question is
what should we be doing
with respect to at least those five
nations the uk
switzerland west germany
france and the united states
to
make sure that
south africa is
required to pay up
uh and in that regard specifically i'd
like to know
what should we be saying
to
those banks which on the committee from
the united states manufacturers hanover
city corps and
morgan guaranty trust
ought to be the percentage repayment
required
over the next few years on that debt
robinson
i think it's a very important question
and i'm very grateful for that
because
the whole question of the rescheduling
of loans and the repayment of the debt
to my mind is at the present moment
the most important
and the most sensitive aspect of the
economic situation of south africa
in no other area
south african government is so sensitive
and so concerned
as about the whole question of the
repayment of the loans and the
possibility of obtaining new loans
all the studies which have been
undertaken
all the facts which have been presented
and which are available prove the point
that
if there is any meaningful
and effective pressure which comes
from the different western governments
and through them on bankers and those
financial institutions which make
available those loans
there is no doubt about it
that this is the area where the most
significant pressure can be applied
in order to force the south african
government to come into some form of
meaningful negotiation
there's another point where i think that
needs to be made constantly the
argument is being used that
sanctions are harming the black
people of south africa most
this is an area where all of us
both and especially white and black
will feel these pressures which are
being applied upon us
and we're in the first place the white
community will respond by saying
we cannot continue along these lines
and therefore i would plead
that the united states takes the lead
in putting the necessary pressure on the
other western governments
on those agencies which are in positions
of power
to see to it
that the whole appeal which is being
made with regard to the rescheduling of
the existing loans the whole question of
providing further loans that this is
being taken seriously
this gives the south african government
the opportunity
to respond to it
to indicate clearly to what degree they
would be willing to come to terms with a
this appeal for negotiation
i'm convinced that this is the most
effective point of pressure which could
be applied at the present moment and for
the next year
i would like to add
that
this should not be seen as a punitive
strategy
it is crucial to understand that we are
saying it is
conditional
that
we want negotiation
and
here is an opportunity for the united
states to be able to say to south africa
we're not saying we're not going to let
you have the loans
you're going to have the loans provided
and it is crucial
that you we please and we say
lift the state of emergency
release
detainees and political prisoners and
our leaders and allow
exiles to return home
and pen our political organizations
make it possible for free political
activity
to happen
and then
that is the climate
when you can sit down with the authentic
acknowledged leaders and representatives
i mean nothing could be more reasonable
we are not wanting to global it's our
country
we love that country i said to the state
president
i think i love this country more than
you
because
our people fought against the nazis
you didn't
mr jenkins
thank you very much i'm delighted to be
permitted to participate uh
bishop's a pleasure
uh this is a distinguished gathering
uh
i want to raise a question of some
things we're attempting to do in new
york and given the the uh the real heavy
solution some of you have discussed i
wonder if this is useful we we hope it
is we have a law that
prohibits the city from doing business
with those that are still in south
africa and as you know
there there are some companies that
circumvent this through uh
franchising and licensing and
distribution agreements and so we have
now come
the new law that that we've asked for uh
gotten certain cooperation so far the
law is has uh been introduced
and uh
and there have been some hearings held i
have a fear that there are those forces
that would wish to water this down a bit
like let's give them more time
we we resist this we think it's
important this this amendment to the
existing law
would prohibit
dealing with those persons who are using
non-equity
devices but who are in fact really still
in south africa and
my question is if you think this would
be useful i would invite
some of you distinguished citizens to
come on the occasion of the next hearing
and let people in new york know that
this legislation might be useful in the
overall battle if indeed you think it's
so
it seems if we're quite uncertain no
we're not uncertain we're very clear
about that
because the answer is a very clear
definite one please
for not a single moment
water down anything
see to it that what is being done in
that respect you know is not only being
done by you but also by other
cities so that the pressures are there
and are being filled we are in south
africa we are sick and tired of the ways
and means in which
the
legitimate and the valid appeals for
meaningful pressure in which these are
being circumvented in so many ways so
our plea with for you is please go along
and whatever we can do to assist you in
that matter and i may i add to that
that we are doing this for the sake
of all our people
not only for the blacks
also for the whites and especially also
for the afrikaners who are in government
i have spoken to some of them not in the
very leading positions but many others
will privately express to us and say we
are in serious trouble we know that we
haven't got the answers please apply
these pressures we would like to assist
you because all of us including the
african arms would like to move along
into a new country please be aware of
the fact that there are many more than
we realize when their hearts are saying
what desmond due to and ellen brewster
and others are saying this is the truth
that we need to hear
mr dellums
thank you very much mr chairman as i
listen carefully this morning what i
hear not only is
the need for globally applied sanctions
but in the context of the house and the
senate um
a call for integr incremental movement
my thought is is that those members and
incremental movement particularly on the
part of the senate my thought is that
those members of the senate who are
there
for incremental movement are there for
the whole package
i'm supremely confident and optimistic
that the house of representatives a
third time can pass comprehensive
sanctions what we're really talking
about in this room with respect to
sanctions is a procedural matter in the
united states senate i am absolutely
convinced that the majority of the
senators would pass a comprehensive
sanction bill the question is whether
you can
mobilize 60 members of the senate
to move us past a filibuster in that
regard from this conference ought to be
some strategy that is able to say uh to
our republican colleagues that whether
you agree or not with the issue of
comprehensive sanctions
that the the moral imperative and the
great human tragedy that is evolving in
south africa is such that whether they
agree or not they ought to be willing to
join with correct thinking members of
the senate uh to at least allow the
senate to have a straight up or down
vote on this matter and whether they
agree or not it seems to me the moral
imperative should drive them to join
with the majority of the senate to move
past the filibuster because it's at the
level of the filibuster that you stop
the sanctions so i'm i'm not sure you
guarantee anything by watering yourself
down talking about incremental movement
i think if the great pressure is
comprehensive sanctions i think they can
be gotten but the strategy ought to be
how can you
address yourself to the procedural issue
of getting beyond the filibuster in the
in the united states senate
many of us
are hopeful that we with a new
administration
and a new president
that will have new leadership
i think that is what this country wants
i think it expressed it in a measured
way in the 1986 sanctions legislation
i think that is what the american people
want
and we invite
this president and the administration
to spell out the path
that will put this nation firmly
on the side of liberation and freedom
the end of apartheid
we invite
this administration
to reverse
its role of recent years in vetoing
the various
economic sanction proposals that have
been before the united nations
and we invite this nation to lead the
way with the
economic eight countries
to develop a coordinated policy
that will be meaningful
so i would uh hope
congressman dellums that we can do it
with the administration in a bipartisan
way
that is our hope
but if we
are unable to get that type of
leadership
i would certainly uh expect
that
the kind of bipartisan support
that was fashioned and shaped in 1986
for meaningful
continuous action
will be very much there because they
will have listened to the voice of
conscience
the three
that uh individual who've spoken to the
voice of conscience to the american
people this morning
mr
labonte thank you uh it's it's certainly
an honor to participate here this
morning
as part of the corporate world
uh i think your plan as you've
unveiled it in the discussions last
evening and this morning
uh are really an inspiration to those of
us who care about freedom of expression
uh around the world and
uh as a company
that has no ties to south africa we
want to join with others and have made
it part of our own mission
to join with other corporations
to
take some stands which can further your
interest
we believe that joining corporations
with special purpose causes like this
can do
many many things that haven't been able
to be done by government
we're looking forward to participating
with you
and really encourage you to continue to
talk
continue to enroll us
where we're here to help
and look forward to rapid change in
south africa
thank you
i just want to respond very warmly to
that intervention
and to stress again
that our intentions
are not punitive
we want a new south africa
a south africa where all of its people
will be able to participate
freely and fully in all activities
and we will be saying to yourselves and
others
yes we want to work for
this post-apartheid
south africa
and for goodness sake please help us
invest
in the future
invest
in justice
invest
in humanity
ms hundergal
this question is to any of the three um
for the sake of argument let's say that
the u.s has enacted the tougher
sanctions that you outlined reverend
vocek
and has enlisted the cooperation of
other governments in the world
at the same time the anc does not
renounce violence on the one hand
and on the other hand the state may or
may not have released mandela but has
not released other political prisoners
has not unbanned ban the currently
banned political organizations
including the anc
what is the scenario that you therefore
envision having enacted these sanctions
that would get the government to the
negotiating table
and are any are there any incremental
steps towards negotiation that you would
sanction
i would
i would respond in this way i mean i
cannot even conceive of a situation
where if you have these sanctions that
we have outlined
you have them in place
and they are effective because they will
be
if they are done in the way that we have
asked them to be done
i cannot conceive of a situation where
the south african government will say we
will dig in our heels we will not
release mr mandela we will not legalize
all of these banned organizations we
will not create the climate uh for four
negotiations neither can i conceive
of a situation in which the african
national congress for instance that you
have mentioned would say we will not
renounce violence the anc
in 1986 with the package that was put
together by the commonwealth persons
eminent person commonwealth eminent
persons group
in that package anc had already said we
will agree to all of the conditions that
the commonwealth epg had worked out with
the democratic movement inside the
country and with the south african
government that included the suspension
of violence
so that is on record as far as the anc
is concerned um once you have a
situation in which this kind of
concerted effort
is entered into by
uh the international community just as
it was impossible for the south african
government to resist that kind of
pressure on the namibia issue and
concerning angola so it will be
impossible for the government to resist
that kind of pleasure with regard to the
domestic situation in south africa and
by the same token i do not think the anc
will even contemplate saying we will not
do this or that or the other the anc
will i think have to
keep its word that it had given in 1986
with the approval of the people inside
of south africa otherwise i think it
will unleash the kind of dynamic in
black politics that it would not want
and i cannot even think of a situation
where we will have to deal with all
these impossibilities that you have
outlined almost
referenced
would you sanction incremental steps
though towards the negotiation
that depends on what you mean i mean if
uh
say say we have say we have um
a situation where the banks would say to
the south african government we have now
decided to put it to you that unless you
fulfill these conditions that have risen
out of our discussions with
representatives of the black people in
south africa we will not roll over the
dip
you have a situation in which the
nations of the world join
in an effective oil boycott
and where the pressures are there
if you have that situation uh what else
is there if you have all the airlines
cut off what else is there that you can
do the only other thing
for my point of view would be to say all
right that let's look for ways in which
to increase
the incidence of violence in the south
african situation itself what we are
asking for is exactly for these steps in
order to forestall them in order to make
sure that that it would not even be
considered to cut down on the violence
that is already happening and to make
sure that we preclude an escalation in
the violence in south africa that is why
we are asking for these essentially
peaceful measures to make sure that by
adhering to these
way of both of these parties would find
it would be to their advantage
to begin to listen to these voices of
reason and come to the negotiation table
and both of them would be under
tremendous pressure from the people
inside south africa
reverend jackson
archbishop tutu
dr naughty
reverend bozak
i want to congratulate and thank you
again for
your witness keeping hope alive and all
of us
to randall robinson who in effect made
this forum possible
and to congressman dellums who's
challenged to our congress to be
decisive
fundamentally along with demonstrations
lifted us to this place
as i'm concerned about our vision
and our tolerance of the situation
as a nation we are doing less than our
best
we do not have a policy
in the senate not in the house not in
the white house
to end the party we do not have a policy
to end a party
as a nation we're pulling back
with an incoherent tentative resistance
while japan increases its investment
measurably
nato allies that we subsidize sell arm
to south africa
invest in south africa
conduct tourist trades and vacation in
south africa
for city corps extends relief of loans
to south africa
i've tried to visit your country several
times the last few years
always to be turned down by south africa
but that's not
so bad
our own government is not offended
by south africa denying our citizens
access to visit you
in your homes and in your churches
we have quite a different disposition to
libya
the fact is we have to a libya a
commitment to sanctions with a military
attitude
we have neither in fact as a government
toward south africa
the democratic party's declared south
africa to be a terrorist state
mr bush declared it to be a racist state
so i hope mr bush will meet with the
three of you as well as oliver tombo
this date takes on special meaning for
us because it is
the 35th anniversary of the 54th supreme
court
decision
and yet we are still struggling for a a
full comprehensive vote and right act i
close on this simply in terms of our
tolerance
ken gonna puts it best if the racial
equation were reversed
if the majority were white
oppressed by a minority of black south
africans
us foreign policy would be fundamentally
different
towards south africa our tolerance with
apartheid
extends
that system and that is our challenge to
see both to end the tolerance of the
system as well as a vision to see south
africa not just as a state but as a
kingdom
as an empire that extends throughout the
southern
african region
senator bourne
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to begin by thanking our guests for
being here and for thanking them for the
spirit which they express
i have to say i was not prepared for the
intensity of the reaction that i had to
my visit in south africa where i got to
see two of you
recently a few things have touched me
and touched my life as much as the
spirit that i found there
visits with the two of you visits with
mrs sulu and others
expressing uh managing to express a
spirit of love and understanding and
love of country and wanting to bring
people together
in spite of the kind of capricious
actions of the government which are all
the more cruel because they are so
capricious attending the sentencing
hearing at the delmas trial for example
and seeing how the limits of legitimate
political activity are kept so uncertain
is to make it impossible for people to
plan and to be active
uh i can't think of a cruel crueler kind
of a system than that that kind of
uncertainty that you're left hanging in
and the spirit with which you respond to
it
to me is amazing i
i would say and this is on an optimistic
note and following on what senator
kennedy has said
after i returned
then president-elect bush asked me to
come down to the white house we had a
talk of an hour and a half just the two
of us together
i took with me the human rights
commission reports which had been shared
with me with members of the commission
there about the detentions
about a week
after he was inaugurated as president he
called me back again he discussed and
asked questions that indicated that he
had personally read those reports
i do think we have an opportunity a
changed attitude in the administration i
think there is sincere concern
and the word concerted action i think is
so important as long as the house and
the senate the executive branch are all
divided we can't speak with the same
authority and force as we could if we
were united
i think we should make an effort now to
begin negotiations between the house the
senate and the administration
i think we should put it to the
president that he must now make a show
of good faith publicly in terms of some
of the things that he said privately
we've got to change our position in the
united nations and elsewhere senator
kennedy has said we have to seek the
support from allied nations for
financial sanctions and i agree that
those are the sanctions that have the
greatest effect
and we must have strong public
statements from the administration of
moral outrage
i think once those credentials are
demonstrated
and once there's been a show of good
faith we should then work together
to try to have a program that will give
us the greatest leverage ratcheting up
the pressure and ratcheting it down in
return for specific positive
improvements so i would urge that
that through all channels
we try to begin these negotiations we
let the president know we're willing to
try to work together
after a show of good faith and strong
action on his part
thank you i
we have now about 25 minutes left of
general discussion
i would ask all of us to understand that
the lights are unforgiving
so that we all get an opportunity to
speak there are a number of others who
wish to speak and we want everyone who
wishes to to get that opportunity mr
lucy
thank you mr chairman just a quick
two-part question
uh in the opening presentations of each
of our guests i i didn't hear either
speak to the status of the black trade
union movement in south africa now in
terms of
its role
both as a part of the liberation
struggle and certainly his efforts to
survive under what appears to be a
change in the laws that govern trade
union activity i wish if we could
respond to that
and then secondly uh if there are any
views that they would our guests would
care to share certainly with our
congressional leadership
as to how we could move our policy
um to be more supportive of the black
trade union movement a la salad
allah history
so that it can play a much more
effective role in the struggle
beyond just the eight to four hour eight
to five work hours of their workers they
represent
i'm very grateful for that reply
for that question uh in which i would
like to reply
by saying that before i left
south africa i had extensive discussions
with leaders
of kosatu
the udf
of individual trade unions in south
africa with regard to the whole position
of the trade unions
i think it is important also to
emphasize that one of the issues which
were raised in those discussions with
the old question of sanctions
and
we knew that something of that kind
would be forthcoming with regard to this
uh publication you know of the large
number of people who would be
against sanctions especially blacks
i think it is important to realize
first of all that your trade unions
south africa
are waging a tremendously difficult
battle
in their claim for labor rights and for
human rights in south africa
i think it is also important to realize
that in a certain sense they are in the
position of leadership
with regard to obtaining
not only
the normal democratic rights that
workers have in western countries
but also the political voice that they
wish to add
kusato as you know has been very
severely
restricted in participating in any
meaningful direct or indirect political
activity
that creates a tremendous problem for
them
the national union of mine workers
is engaged in a deep and serious
struggle
with regard to the whole issue of
justice regarding your minds
and regarding the position which they
occupy
i would wish to plead that more than
ever
there should be a clear and decisive
indication
of the part
of the united states administration on
the part of the trade unions and others
to give those trade unions who are
struggling for justice in south africa
all the necessary moral and where
necessary financial support that they
deserve
without the trade unions and their very
meaningful action
the whole struggle for a non-violent
change in south africa
could only be very seriously delayed
and therefore
as far as we are concerned
we have indicated to the trade unions
our deep appreciation for what they're
doing
we have indicated them the fact that we
know that the laborers of south africa
are paying a much heavier price
for their struggle for justice than
perhaps any other specific group in
south africa and our plea with you is
pleased to give them the necessary
support and they will themselves
indicate
the
the individual trade unions they will
indicate very clearly what they would
wish to have a view in their struggle
for justice especially when it leaves it
needs the old question of this
investment and the way in which for
instance american companies leaving
south africa are claiming to disinvest
totally whereas we know that in number
of cases this is not taking place and
they have stated very clearly reasonable
demands that they wish to make you know
of those companies in the way in which
the change in south africa could be
brought about i'll have 20 minutes left
of general discussion
uh to speak uh reverend lawyer mr
templesmen
congressman wolpe miss davis congressman
kennedy dr hill
senator lautenberg mr wilkins
congressman daimler and
congressman leach
we have 10 speakers and we'll have to
cut the time down to one minute if there
are others who wish to speak
let us recognize you now to note your
names congressman payne
and mr ferraro
dr ladna
so we now have 13 who wish to speak and
the time remaining the clock has been
reset to one minute
reverend lowry
thank you mr chairman i shall speak as
rapidly as possible certainly it's good
to see all three of these persons here
at one time
uh thank them for their invitation to
share in a celebration honoring dr king
last year and asked them to invite me
again and this time use a little more
influence on your ambassador to give me
a visa
i want to extend warm greetings to you
and we are extremely hopeful that
this administration will show the same
level of moral outrage
at state terror in south africa
as it is presently demonstrating about
panama
and when it does we'll see
more progressive movement toward the end
of apartheid my question i have two
questions
eliminate one and ask only this one
there's considerable controversy
uh around the issue of divestment
and since some of us have been very
heavily involved while all three of you
are here
would you address one of you or all of
you
the impact or at least the potential
impact if there's not been time to
evaluate it of divestment and if there's
any particular style or form of
divestment that has been more effective
than others
well we should have to say for myself
personally i have always said that
divestment is almost a second level
strategy it is something that we use
because the sanctions that we have asked
for people are not willing to give in
other words if we could have
um
the types of sanctions that we have
mentioned this morning
then you could almost say
this investment would become of less
importance because
by its very nature it takes so long to
take effect the kind of disinvestment
movement that was started in
1983-84 we are only beginning to see the
results now and indeed it does have an
impact there is no doubt about it in its
own way it has an impact it has all
kinds of other difficulties that we have
to face what happens when a company does
this invest will that company honor his
word and for instance enter into
discussions with the trade unions as dr
naudia has just mentioned when that
happens much of the unhappiness in terms
of how companies this invest
at the moment could be circumvented
could be changed could be forestall in
the real sense
so at the moment i would say we should
not even think
of lessening also the impact of this
investment whilst the other sanctions we
have asked for are not put in place when
companies have this investment and uh in
the process have gone to the community
have talked with us have discussed with
the unions have spoken with the
community leaders and have set to put
together a plan
as to how they will best invest and what
will happen to the money that is left in
the country almost in all those cases a
totally different scenario has emerged
and it is that kind of thing that we are
saying to the companies it is not
to do as has been happening with mobile
for instance that is not the only option
you have another way of just investing
with involving the community uh which
would have to have the biggest say as to
how you do it and what happens after
that and when that happens the situation
will be different but it seems to me for
the time being
unless we do get the kind of effective
sanctions we've been talking about this
morning
this investment will remain a very
important tool for us to use
mr templesmen
first of all i want to express my
gratitude for the organ to the
organizers of this meeting and to you
randall particular because i think no
one has done more than you have
to create a constituency for african
issues in this country and our political
system
works better when there is a
constituency there
my question
needs supposed to be characterized it is
not a substitute
or an alternative it's in addition to
the pressures that you were talking
about
and
bill lucy
raised a portion of that when he touched
upon the labor union question i believe
there is at the moment a
fairly
large and increasing constituency that
would like to find
areas
where one could be
effective in being helpful in the
empowerment of the movement in addition
to the breath the to the one of bringing
pressure
we at the african-american institute in
recent months have had increasing
interest on the part of a great many
whether it be foundations of individuals
coming to us and say what is it that we
can do
and we are groping
and i think
in
some of the
preliminary discussions with the
administration one here is the
possibility of a foundation being
created it's all preliminary but
nevertheless there is an element there
that is looking mr templeton only
because time is expiring i'm
what can you suggest what can be done
uh as an organizing as an organized
mechanism where we can get some better
guidance from you on what would be
effective that's the question
thank you very much
we have
constantly been speaking about
the post about it south africa we've
constantly been speaking about the
empowerment of people and we do want
our people back home the government the
white community to realize
that we have not come here
looking for big whips
just because we are sadistic
we would be saying to you yes there are
areas where you can already be making
significant
investments in
people the development of people
we've got foundations already within
south africa that are
involved with the mass democratic
movement and are
seeking precisely that kind of
empowerment of people and therefore
our approach to this whole problem of
south africa
whilst it zeros in specifically on the
question of the negotiation
for a new kind of south africa also says
we've already got to be doing this kind
of things i mean we've got universities
such as the university of the western
cape
which is clearly in in the forefront
of institutions that are preparing
people for this new south africa those
are the kinds of institutions in which
we would want to see you
put your money
congressman wolfy
thank you randall
the argument that has been raised by the
opponents of sanctions and disinvestment
increasingly is summarized by the term
empowerment which is used just now in a
different context that is
that the argument has been presented is
that movement of corporations outside of
south africa will weaken the empowerment
of blacks and that is that kind of
economic process that will lead
ultimately to political democratization
the mobile oil pull out recently
announced has kind of refocused that
debate there were some that testified
publicly that somehow that was a bad
because it was going to weaken the
process of black empowerment i wonder if
we could ask our guests to respond to
that kind of concern
yes i um
i am very much concerned that the term
that we have used over the many many
years and trying to get people to
understand what this is all about
empowerment by which we meant the
political empowerment of black people to
make it possible for us through our vote
to make
changes in the system to make it
possible for us to participate as any
normal person would want to participate
in any normal democratic society in the
decisions that affect our day-to-day
life
and the decisions that we have to make
in order
to run
a government in that country that is now
being changed and people are saying well
you cannot simply talk about a political
empowerment because that comes only
after economic empowerment it rests on
the fallacy i think that people think
that within the apartment system it is
actually possible to empower black
people
economically and that the economic
empowerment that would come to a very
small section of selected black people
within the present system that that
would actually make
political change inevitable
people forget
that economic growth
to talk very simply is not even possible
within inappropriate society if you take
the kind of money that is necessary
simply to keep the system intact the
more than 50 billion rand that is needed
per year just to keep apartheid the
structures there i'm not even talking
about all those other little adventures
that the south african government gets
itself into and therefore us too
in angola and muslim back and elsewhere
just the kind of money it takes to keep
the system there it is not possible you
can see how it is the very apartheid
system that is making it impossible for
the country to have the kind of economic
growth that we need and therefore to
create the kind of wealth that is
necessary to make redistribution
possible and to bring black people into
the mark and that is the kind of thing
we are trying to say you have to get rid
of a party in order for the economy to
be sound and once you then begin to talk
about empowerment it will have to happen
within a different political and
economic framework than the one we have
now which is designed
simply to be for the benefit of a very
very small minority of our people
ms davis
within the uh
parameters of of the the need for pres
and to look at
a point that you all made in relation to
the the
shift in in in namibia and the the
impact that that pressures had on moving
south africa to negotiate with libya
because it is the current position of
our administration that south africa is
now adhering scrupulously to the
agreements
it is on the other hand our view
gathered from news that is coming out of
namibia and particularly from the
council of churches
that south africa is in fact engaging in
all kinds of violations of the agreement
both in terms of ongoing violence and
also you know total failure to meet the
timetable
so that what i would
would like to pose to you is your view
on
the correct u.s administration position
at this point in terms of pressure
should we be
urging the administration to
extend and expand its pressure on south
africa or is this now a period where we
really trust south africa's word on on
namibia what is the news that you have
as you're much more dire
of
the the
actual situation inside and the way in
which south africa is always not
adhering
it is very clear that south africa is
trying to adhere as much as possible to
the agreement because there are so many
advantages for the african government if
they now
should say we're no longer interested in
the independence of namibia they know
what will happen they will lose all of
the goodwill that have been built up in
in in the international community
and they will revert back to the basic
thing if this does not happen the only
other thing that will keep them to the
agreement would be unprecedented
pressure by all these western powers who
have limited themselves now through the
u.n resolution
to the independence of namibia
so i mean what we are saying to the
administration
is for eight years now at least
what we feel what we
have as opinions about our society our
experiences of the south african
government have not been heard in
washington or in the white house to be
precise
what we hope this administration will do
at this time when it is trying to make
sure that his policy vis-a-vis south
africa will be the correct one is to
open up that avenue so that black voices
from south africa can be heard in the
administration and by simply hearing
those voices and taking us seriously as
we should be taken seriously for the
first time in so many many years i am
absolutely convinced that the
administration will be dispute of all
kinds of illusions about the south
african government and will be listening
to those people who will say this is
what we feel and in the life of that
would be able to make much more balanced
decisions we must now hear from eight
speakers in five minutes
and i i ask our speakers to uh
to edit themselves i also ask our
distinguished guests to
restrain themselves as much as possible
congressman kennedy
thank you very much
first of all i want to obviously welcome
our three guests i think if you look
around this table there most of the
people here would uh strongly support
congressman dellumsville and and were
hopeful of the senate coming around
on the other hand it does seem to me
that we have one representative here of
the administration
somebody who has inherited a job that uh
was previously
filled by chester crocker who
uh
who presided over the constructive
engagement policy which obviously didn't
work and i wonder if mr cohen might have
some comments on what the
the uh what we're calling for this
morning whether or not you think that
the president should in fact meet the
uh three visitors and what you're sent
personally
of our nation's commitment to south
africa and the people of south africa
ought to be
mr corn
uh
i really don't want to preempt the
president and secretary on this they
sent me here to listen and to bring back
the ideas this is part of a broad
consultative process
they will be meeting extensively with
leadership in the congress they've
already started that
to talk specifically about south africa
and this
this is part of the entire process one
thing i do want to make absolutely clear
is that both the president and the
secretary are very very angry with what
they see happening in south africa in
terms of apartheid they're very angry
about detention without trial without
people not even being charged with a
crime
they're very angry about people being
charged and convicted of treason just
because they organize politically
non-violently
to organize their own communities
they're very angry about the fact that a
black south african can't even buy a
piece of land
in 87 percent of the country
and they're very angry about the fact
that people can't live
where they choose to live
so the basic moral outrage is there and
they really want to consult widely with
everyone to see
what we can do to contribute to a
process of negotiation which is what
bishop tutu is asking for
and we will certainly want to
have a consensus on that throughout all
branches of the united states government
dr hill
yes i'd like our guests to comment on
the regional aspect of apartheid because
in the past we've found that
our struggle for sanctions
must also incorporate a struggle against
aid for unita and other banded groups
would you comment please
i would certainly hope very much that
people here would agree with me that the
policies
towards unita that have been followed in
the united states are
quite unacceptable
to us and have assisted in the process
of south africa's being able to
destabilize her neighbors and we would
hope i mean that the new administration
would realize that
you have to have a comprehensive policy
towards south and africa
senator lautenberg
yes thank you very much i too want to
add my
welcome to dr nowday and to bishop tutu
both of whom i met in my trip to south
africa and to reverend bosack as well i
join you in mourning the death of david
webster who i met during that trip
and i hope that in his memory we will be
able to commit ourselves more
aggressively to abolishing apartheid i
heard today that helen sussman
is leaving government leaving politics
and i was distressed to hear that
because she too was a loyal and strong
fighter i will uh just in the brief
moment to tell you that i think you're
being here
you're
participating in this forum does more to
advance the
cause of the abolition of apartheid than
i think is apparent and i commend you
for doing it i think it's an appropriate
foreman forum and i
think that you leave all of us in the
senate and the congress
committed to do whatever we can to aid
you in your struggle
mr wilkins
first of all to our three guests i would
say thank you for being you
uh secondly i would point out to you uh
that something very significant is
happening in this room
the assistant secretary for africa is
attending an event which is uh sponsored
by transafrica and the free south africa
movement and it would not have happened
inconceivable that that would have
happened any time in the last eight
years and i for one welcome it and uh
thank you for being here ambassador
cohen i think it's a i think it's a very
welcome development
congressman daimler
to our parents what effect is the
trade and arms sales policy
of the uk japan
germany and israel having on the freedom
movement in south africa
and it's already 12 o'clock
[Laughter]
i can attempt to answer that question
but i think if i share this report with
you which i have brought with me
about the key features of the south
african economy and the effects of
sanctions and so forth it mentions the
role of all those delinquent nations as
far as that is concerned and i hope that
by use of the word delinquent will
already indicate to you how it affects
us and how we feel but i will make this
available not only to you but i think to
all participants because i think in here
there's a lot of information that will
help you
and it's much better said than three uh
religious persons can help you hope to
say so i will make this available to you
and that will answer your questions
congressman
leach thank you randall uh as one of the
few congressional representatives of the
party that was founded to end apartheid
in this century their last century in
this country
it strikes me that the best advice to
the new administration
is to conclude that it's not simply
enough to excoriate apartheid
we should affirm an addition that
radical empowerment for blacks not
simply constructive engagement with
whites is our goal
and here it should be
self-advocate that there comes a time in
the relations with states when
fundamentalists change based on
fundamentalist philosophies and order
and while i support sanctions i'd like
to ask the advice of our visitors on
several kinds of
symbolic steps that might be taken
by the administration at an early point
in time
first is if we consider this government
illegitimate
shouldn't we downgrade our relationship
with it and upgrade our relations with
the people and symbolically shouldn't we
consider
reducing from embassy to mission status
or our
embassy in in pretoria secondly
shouldn't we build up ties
with black organizations particularly
the trade union movement and support
if we can identify with solidarity
notion poland certainly we can identify
with
quasi-enslaved groups in south africa
and finally
even though we have very limited aid
prospects
shouldn't we give renewed thought to
renewed emphasis
to support for the front line states
to demonstrate that we identify and want
to assist and help
black governed states in the region
thank you
well
mr congressman you you have said exactly
what we wanted to say
i must thank the archbishop for his
great assistance to the chair
mr ferrari
thank you randall and uh
i think that
the three
speakers with the help of the media
their testimony will go
out of this room and affect the
consciences of more people so that that
constituency will be broadened
i want to ask a question about pressure
and negotiations
from everything we've heard and the
differences that exist between the
voluntary sanctions in western europe
and the mandatory sanctions which are
lower in the united states is at the
heart of the issue
would you consider going to the security
council with what is existing united
states law
for action so that western europe would
have to comply
and would you consider tying that to a
specific date for negotiations so that
if the south african government does not
negotiate by a specific date along the
platform in your proposal that there
would be security council action based
on the existing legislation a second
point on negotiations i noted that
inside south africa
uh the moderator of the dutch reform
church raised the point
in which he said that the suspension of
violence was no longer a prerequisite
for negotiations mr farrar
may i ask you to bear with me we
have that was the end of my question
if they just commented on that
i think the answer is a very clear and
definite one
there is a tremendous
important role which the united states
administration can play
in order to involve the other
governments to take this joint action if
there is this pressure coming here from
the united states
pressurizing on the other governments to
take a united action in this regard
there is no doubt in our minds that that
could possibly be the most effective
action which could be taken and as far
as the drc is concerned i don't think
there's any need to talk about that as
far as we know the black ratiform
churches have taken a very clear
standard they've said that we're totally
against our party and we want to move
into a new situation and if the ydrc
does not come along they're going to be
left behind far far behind i've said
that then i've said i'm saying goodbye
to you if you don't move
before hearing closing remarks from
senator casabaum and congressman gray
we'll hear brief comments from
congressman payne and dr ladna
thank you very much mr randall and to
our guests
i too would like to echo what roger
wilkins indicated about ambassador cohen
with senator simon i had the privilege
of traveling to the aai meeting recently
with ambassador cohen
and i feel he has the grass and the
depth that we need to move this
apartheid dismantling process on just
very quickly i might ask in most
movements
young people have had significant roles
we know that young people have been
involved
in the past
we hear nothing now about
young people's participation either
black or white and just briefly could
you
elaborate
on what is occurring with young people
and are they still being arrested as
they have been in the past
the young people and their participation
in the struggle um
can no longer be denied by anybody it is
very very clear that they're taking a
very leading role
it is no wonder
that the south african government has
hit our youth organizations particularly
hard under the state of emergency and if
you should look at the statistics
you would be shocked to see of those
people in detention how many of them are
young people and in fact how many of
them have always been children
under the age of 18 years old so that is
going on in as long as i think our young
people have such an acute sense of their
own political responsibility and such a
desire to change south africa children
will have to bear the brunt of the anger
of the south african government as they
have done since 1976. there is a vote on
the floor of the house with senator
casabaum's permission
i would ask that congressman gray be
allowed to speak
before you
and you follow him
after we hear briefly from dr ladner i
will make my remarks very brief as chair
person of the board of trans african
forum i want to thank our three guests
for
coming here today
for such an important forum i'll ask one
very brief question i want to know what
is possible for international
organizations concerned with human
welfare foundations religious
organizations what can we do
to
in terms of a systematic strategy to
improve the quality of life of children
and of families especially as
it appears that this systematic
destabilization of families will
continue to occur under the south
african regime
how can we
band together and systematically develop
a strategy to pressure the government to
offset these trends
they are the full answer can't be given
now because of the brevity of time
but i would say there are a number of
key
and important organizations inside south
africa
while constantly keeping themselves busy
with this very question that you are
asking
about health about welfare
about education
about the
liberation of our people along those
lines
and we would gladly wish to make
available to you the list of such
organizations and i we know that from
their side there will be a very positive
response to indicate to you the ways and
means that they see that such support
could be meaningful and to my mind very
important with regard to us
that brings us to the end of our general
discussion we will now hear closing
remarks from congressman bill gray and
then from senator nancy casabaum
thank you randall robinson and let me
commend you and all of those for putting
together this very important forum and
let me thank the participants the three
outstanding human rights leaders from
south africa who have come and come
together
this is a historic occasion for all
three of them together here in this
country giving us a very strong message
asking the united states to assume a
leadership role
in ending apartheid because there has
not been basic and significant change
they have called for negotiations and
said that in order to
bring those negotiations about there
must be pressure applied
in order for people to come to the table
and therefore sanctions are a
justifiable tool
and should be expanded mentioning such
items as oil coal gold transportation
items as well as debt rescheduling
they've also called for a multilateral
approach with the united states assuming
a leadership role in bringing other
nations of the world together in a
conference or through the u n
to apply pressure to the apartheid
regime in south africa
our efforts
hopefully in the united states congress
in the 101st session will be as they
have been in the past bipartisan in 1986
the congress overwhelmingly and
bipartisanly said that we wanted to
change our course on foreign policy
towards south africa
however it must be admitted very
candidly here that we did not fully
implement the sanctions bill the limited
sanctions bill of 1986 because that bill
called for the president to approach
western leadership and other democracies
to join in applying those same limited
sanctions there was no effort for a
multilateral approach
however
let me speak on behalf of the democrats
in the house
we have already declared a policy
consistent with the goals outlined by
our three human rights leaders
one
we will not provide the economic fuel
for the political engine of apartheid
two
we should stand with the oppressed
majority and make sure that our
diplomacy conveys that to everyone in
south africa and to the world
three we understand that if we want
change
then there must be some pain
sanctions may hurt but apartheid kills
and thus it is the policy in the
democratic house
that we will support comprehensive
sanctions such as the ones put together
by our colleague and distinguished
friend from the state of california who
chairs the congressional black caucus
and the 101st session the gentleman from
california ronald dellums and i should
say it is my expectation that we will
once again pass the delam's bill in the
101st congress
fifthly we will expand the president
present limited sanctions at the same
time
finally i would like to say to my
friends who are here from south africa
and to all of us
we need to urge our president
to meet with these three leaders
in fact to meet with them before
he meets with the new head of state of
south africa so that he will know what
is happening from the viewpoint of the
majority population and also send a
signal that is consistent with the 1986
sanctions bill mr president
meet this week with these three leaders
this afternoon
we will have at the white house
the signing
of the legislation reauthorizing the
martin luther king commission and i'm
happy to see coretta scott king here
for it was also martin luther king who
taught many of us in the 1950s and 1960s
that our human rights were tied to the
human rights of people all over the
world and when he received his nobel
laureate
like desmond tutu he talked about those
living
in south africa and suffering
under apartheid mr president
this week
let's fulfill the dream let's meet with
these leaders and get the correct
viewpoint on south africa
secondly we call upon the president to
demonstrate the same
consistent principles of democracy and
human rights around the world if we can
dis if we can demonstrate
outrage over a stolen election in
central america then we must demonstrate
the same level of outrage in a place
where over 70 percent of the people
cannot even vote
we need to see that kind of leadership
and it must be more than just rhetoric
finally
we would also urge the administration
to apply the pressure send the signal to
south africa by joining congress in
considering further restrictions in
limiting the economic fuel for apartheid
support
the same approach
that this nation supports and over a
dozen other countries in the world where
we have economic restrictions and
sanctions if they are valid in those
over a dozen nations in the world today
then they are also valid in south africa
thank you
desmond tutu thank you alan bozak thank
you buyers naughty for coming and
sharing with us
on behalf i believe i speak for the
entire democratic leadership of the
house
we will continue the struggle it is a
part of our consistent human rights
policy
thank you very much congressman grace
and at the nancy kesselbaum
thank you very much congressman gray is
a difficult act to follow
but first i would just like to say to
bishop tutu to reverend nowday reverend
bosak thank you for coming and being
here
you have been an eloquent and dedicated
and courageous voice from south africa
that has not only inspired all in south
africa but around the world
to the importance
of participation by the part of every
individual in the political process in
the economic process
there are many others in this room who
are gathered here who have also been
leaders in a very courageous way in
breaking down barriers
great difficulty standing up and being
counted at an important time
and i
would like to just make a couple of
points in closing that i think
is important to note
one the importance of this forum and the
importance of the freedom of the press
the freedom and power that comes from
expression
and i don't think that was clearly
illustrated in this country
when
transafrica led the way and many others
provided the support system
for the
demonstrations in front of the south
african embassy
day after day which roused the
consciousness of a nation
to
what was indeed taking place in south
africa
there are many of us who might have
different ways in which this would be
addressed but i know that president bush
does take your voice seriously there is
no one more dedicated to the freedom of
the individuals and freedom of
expression and freedom of political
participation than president bush
and i would just say in closing
that the majority rule is not unjust
it's the essence of democracy thank you
for coming
thank you
now on behalf of the south african
delegation archbishop desmond tutu
one of the
advantages of a of a dark skin
is that usually you are not able to
show when you are blushing
i
speak on behalf of my colleagues
outstanding
persons
and we
without being presumptuous
speak on behalf of millions
when we say to you friends gathered here
and to those we will reach through the
media
thank you
alan
has spent
over a month in detention
alan has
escaped barely with his life
bears has been
banned and turned into a
non-personalities they tried try turning
him into a non-person but they tried
for seven years
and i just want to say to you friends
there are many many
other pebbles on the beach
i have not suffered
as much as
either of these my friends
nor as much as many many others
at home
and if
sometimes you have the impression that
archbishop tutu stands out in the crowd
remember as i have said before
it is because archbishop tutu is being
carried on the shoulders of others
there are tremendous tremendous people
at home
white people
young people
who have been involved in the end
conscription campaign
young people
white people
who have been prepared to pay
a very heavy price
well there is an example here but there
are many others
we have a great country
with some extraordinary people
they are not here
but i hope i mean that we have been able
to
to bring them
vicariously here
for as we sit around this table
there are people
who are crying tears
in solitary confinement
there are mothers who do not know where
their children are
because these have become
refugees
friends
we would not want to keep
exposing
our pain
and the pain of our people
we've done that enough
we are
enormously enormously grateful to
yourselves
and i
we speak
on behalf
of people who if they were able to speak
for themselves
this roof
would go
because of the decibels of sound
that would come
from those many many thousands of
throats
and we speak
for white people
we
we say
there are many who know
that they are going to be free
really only
when all of us are free
they know that they are going to be
human
only together with all of us
thank you
for your
contribution
to an
an incredibly exhilarating enterprise
the enterprise
of south africa
coming to birth
in south africa where black and white
will walk tall together
living
as god intends them to live
as brothers and sisters
in the human family
in god's family
thank you
so
yes
[Applause]
archbishop tutu
reverend norday and reverend bosack
on behalf of all of you we understand
the urgency of this situation
and we will marshal all of the resources
available to us to bring white south
africa to the table in time
this brings to an end our program
is we're ready to get started now and
because of the limited time that we have
available there'll be no opening
statements we'll just be taking your
questions
yes i understood specifically uh
reverend bozak said oil what were the
other
items mentioned as likely to be
effective in any incremental increase in
sanctions
the items that i mentioned were
financial sanctions having to do with
the resettling of the debt
oil
air links transportation in other words
coal
and gold those were the five that i
mentioned
yes
you received word from the white house
yet on when the meeting will be with the
leadership and if you have not
and do not what kind of message will
this send
if you do not
receive anything from the bush white
house
well we haven't received word from the
white house
and should we not receive word that
would be
not a good sign
but we expect to but that hasn't uh
been forthcoming yet
can i follow up on that i mean they've
had a month to uh
schedule a meeting um
what does this tell you if perhaps uh
archbishop tutu could comment on that
what does this tell you that a whole
month has gone by and they haven't had
time well i learned naman the
administration is doing a review of its
policies
and
[Music]
we are just part of
the review
but i i would say that for
for the the people involved in the
struggle
that
a non-meeting
would be a very significant signal
from what you know of the bush
administration so far do you see any
difference between the bush
administration and the reagan
administration
any reason to think that policies might
change in your favor
i i was one of
a group of church
leaders
who met with
the new secretary of state
and i came away impressed
at the fact that there was not the
doctrine approach
that seemed to have characterized the
previous administration there seemed to
be an openness to considering
the
viability for instance of sanctions
and
i said i i was impressed
by that particular openness
of course
we want to see the openness
uh translated into effective actions
such as the ones that have been outlined
and may we again stress
that what we want to see
is
the south african government being
pushed to the negotiating table that is
the
the key
issue for us
what would be the goal of the meeting
with the president
simply to have his ear or to extract
some policy commitments
well it would seem to me that
it would hardly be worth the trouble
simply to have the president's ear
i think we would like to
make use of the opportunity to inform
him
of our views on the south african
situation at the moment what is
happening in the black community our
views what is happening within the
government
what the government should be doing i
mean we hear all kinds of things that
there was a there was a piece in the
south african press
that the administration is considering
a kind of a pro quo deal with the south
african government for instance if
they would release mr nelson mandela
then this administration would ask for
sanctions to be toned down
now
i mean that is not a pro quo
uh it's got nothing
that
one would say is is a worthwhile trade
there mr mandela is going to be released
come what may and the release of mr
nelson mandela can no longer be seen in
isolation of some of the other things
that we have mentioned and it seems to
me as if the administration makes that
kind of proposal that it needs more than
ever to be informed as to how black
people would understand that should it
become reality and what would that mean
vis-a-vis the reality in south africa so
it seems to me that we would simply we
would not go simply to have a kind of a
friendly chat but we would like
to talk to the president about what he
has in mind
for for for south africa
yes
how seriously has the
protest movement within the country been
hurt by the continued state of emergency
it is there is no doubt in our minds
that the state of emergency and the many
regulations and reforms of repressions
which have been applied
have affected the
liberation movement inside the country
very seriously
if we
take into consideration that between 32
and 35 000 people have been detained
over a period of approximately three
years
that hundreds of people
have been
kept in prison for shorter or longer
periods and after their release more
than 450 of them have recently been
released have all been served with
restrictive orders and house arrests
the majority of them are people in key
positions of political activity in south
africa
if we take into consideration the fact
that 32 organizations have been
effectively banned from any form of
operation
and thereby cannot even if they receive
financial support they can do nothing
with that
and this is always the case in the in in
the case of the most active peer
organizations acting peacefully against
apartheid so there's no doubt about it
that it has affected them
on the other hand i would like to
emphasize
that as a result of that
the whole movement of liberation inside
the country has been forced more and
more to
operate in silence in confidence and in
a number of cases underground
and as far as the young people are
concerned as far as the students are
concerned as far as a number of other
activities are concerned
much more of that you know is happening
silently without the world outside
knowing what is actually happening
and on the one hand that's inevitable
because of the repressive measures on
the other hand it creates the impression
to the outside world that there is
normal law order peace in south africa
and i would like to emphasize again that
the tension under the service on the
part of the vast majority of our people
is very deep and it is very serious
and if there is any negative or
seriously negative effects which are
going to come out of that
only the south african government can
blame itself because we've warned the
government and said you are playing with
fire at some stage this situation must
explode not only in your faces but in
our faces in south africa the last word
about that to say
that if the impression is created that
the active opposition on the part of the
people of south africa to apart it has
diminished or has been weakened
you're making a very serious mistake in
fact these representations have
strengthened the determination of the
part of all those in south africa
fighting for liberation and i'm talking
now about non-violent actions of
liberation it has made them more
determined and more committed in order
to bring about
liberation in south africa
i know for for
time purposes you didn't want to give a
general statement but could you bishop
tutu
give us something general for cameras as
to why you're here the purpose of your
visit
we
we have come at the invitation of the
transafrica forum
and
various eminent
congress people and senators and
members of the house of representatives
people who
are very committed to the struggle
for justice and peace in south africa
we've come
in order to let the united states know
what the situation is at home but more
than this we have come
to say the united states has an
unprecedented opportunity
of taking the moral leadership in
bringing about an end to apartheid
through forcing the south african
government to go to the negotiating
table
that is
in some the purpose of our
being here
and of course to say thank you
to people for
and what they have done so far in
support of that struggle
yes
in march you and a group of other
anglican primates went to panama and you
issued a statement strongly critical of
sanctions against panama
and you drew a distinction between
sanctions against panama and sanctions
against south africa
observing that the panamanian government
was about to hold elections
they've held elections and we know what
happened there do you have any
uh have you changed your views yet uh at
all on on on on what you said we
we we have a very consistent
position i mean we
we we are not obsessed with
sanctions i mean we haven't we haven't
said sanctions for sanctions sake we are
quite clearly and deliberately selective
and we're saying the inconsistency is
with the united states government
that they can say
sanctions apply to south africa
they hurt the people you want to help
and then in nicaragua in
panama they don't listen to what the
people they actually want
in our situation we see
or many of us say
this is for us
it seems the last non-violent route and
they say ah no no no we we don't we
don't believe you it will hurt you
and they become paternalistic that is
the inconsistency and we we we would say
if these the
american government can
be so upset by what is happening in
panama to the extent of the president of
this country saying to
the army in panama
stage a coup
and and these are people who claim
that they are opposed to violence and
then when it comes to south africa our
people become terrorists when they
they say here is a government that does
not even remotely pretend
it is democratic
it is
and
if people who have tried for over 50
years to use non-violent means
and and in their case
they are terrorists in the case of the
contras no these are freedom fighters
you need to know these are freedom
fighters baloney
yes i'd like to know what you think that
the south african censorship what that
has done in term media censorship has
done in terms of the world impression of
what's going on inside south africa in
the anti-apartheid movement and what can
the world press or particularly the
american press do about the censorship
in south africa
well it's very very clear i mean we have
been talking ever since the state of
emergency um
we were we are talking about the effects
of the press and censorship and
everybody knows that that means that
whatever happens comes out on the other
side doctored or heavily censored or not
at all
and most importantly the viewpoints
expressed by those who are considered to
be enemies of the state
are not are simply not heard now that is
one thing and and it is clear therefore
that whatever comes out in reporting
cannot be the true picture you are
treated
to the opinions of people who are either
not in the situation in south africa or
who are allowed to say certain things in
a certain way or who can say certain
things without our ability to challenge
them
effectively and and that brings out a
picture that is fairly heavily distorted
but in terms of what the american press
can do i i've been one of those people
who have said
that i do not know often what those
foreign journalists are actually doing
inside the country and whether they are
going to enough trouble to get to the
story behind the story or to get the
facts out when things happen and as they
happen i'm also not
convinced that they are
that they are convinced of the necessity
to really go out and and and get the
opinion of those people in the black
community who really matter because that
hasn't happened for many many uh uh in
many cases uh over the last few years
i have also said when you come to a
situation where the foreign journalists
association
is actually hosted by the department of
foreign affairs in a canteen
at pretoria central prison
and they go and they happily go and sub
champagne with these south african
government people then you have to ask
the question what in the world are you
still doing here i mean i uh
i have very serious questions about the
way things are being done in terms of
the press and i think
there is a lot that can be done i think
that the american journalists who are
there can go to a lot more trouble to
find out what is happening i think they
can challenge the restrictions of the
south african government far more
effectively than they do i think by the
way too that south african papers can
challenge the restrictions far more
effectively than they do and that most
of them are just in a situation where
they accept these restrictions quite
happily without ever trying to stretch
the possibilities of what it is uh that
they can't print and that they can say
and that has been that's something that
all of us have been saying for some time
now and if you look at the state of
affairs of the press
um even the so-called opposition
pressure in south africa it is really a
sorry affair and that is a that is a
worry that i am beginning to share about
the enterprising ability and the courage
of
foreign journalists as well as they work
inside our country
yes
and we said that in south africa that
your overseas journalists and people who
are dealing with the media
that they can organize a concerted
campaign of sending in people into south
africa
having the necessary interviews and
where necessary also the necessary uh
videos which they can take and bring
them back
i'm fully aware of the fact that this
could create problems for them but i'm
convinced that the south african
government will only be come to that
point where they will begin to realize
that these restrictions that they've
applied are becoming ineffective when
you have a massively concerted campaign
of the whole media world to send people
into south africa to come and expose
what is happening there and thereby make
these repressive restrictions which are
there practically invalid it can be
done if this is an unprecedented
opportunity for the u.s to take a
leadership role
uh what plan of action do you have
in the event that the u.s does not take
advantage of this unprecedented
opportunity as you characterize it
i would hope that our appeal
to
the american people
would be heard
we we suffered for eight years under
constructive engagement we warned when
constructive engagement came into place
that it would be
unprecedented
unmitigated disaster for our people
which it turned out to be
but we appealed
to the american people
and through
the leadership of such as randall
robinson and others
students and many many many people
in american society were able to change
the moral climate
we would hope
that there would be the same sort of
outrage in this country over a
government
of any political hue
that sought to uh collaborate with the
nazis
over south africa and i am not using
that
as a hyperbole
i i have said before
that it ought to become impossible for
any administration
as impossible for any administration to
collaborate with the perpetrators of
apartheid as it would be
would have been for
an american administration to
collaborate with the nazis can i just
add to that that there is in any case uh
there are indications of a groundswell
already with regard to
the u.s policy in south africa and the
churches have launched a campaign called
from pentecost to soweto and last sunday
on the 14th in many many churches all
over this country that campaign has been
launched and it will go on until
june the 16th and june the 17th in which
the churches will hope to bring to the
capital
of this nation something like a hundred
thousand people to demonstrate their own
willingness to show
this administration and those who make
decisions about policy that there are
many many people on the ground who still
do care about south africa i myself will
be participating in that campaign and
hope to be back here in the city on the
weekend of june the 16th and 17th at the
culmination of that campaign we hope
that that will be the kind of expression
that this administration and those who
have to make decisions in congress will
not be able to ignore
simon in light of the fact that previous
sanctions legislation has primarily been
hung up in the senate
what is your sense of how a sanctions
package might now play in the senate
since the administration has changed and
the senate is majority democrat
i met
last week with congressman dellums
discussing the what can happen in the
senate we intend to push it in the
senate
we do face a procedural question in the
senate and that is can we get 60 votes
to block
a filibuster
and that's an uphill fight frankly in
the senate
but we intend to push i intend to follow
through senator bourne in the forum
mentioned sitting down negotiating with
the administration
to see what we could all agree upon i
intend to pursue
that avenue also
and my hope is that this administration
is going to be more open to uh
to some realistic concrete actions
they did have assistant secretary herman
cohen here at the at the forum i have
had two talks with the secretary of
state jim baker about the south african
situation
clearly there is more openness whether
they're willing to move in a more
concrete way we don't know yet
i'm wondering if mr robinson transafrica
is going to take a more aggressive
stance in bringing a groundswell as
they've suggested from the public itself
will you be more aggressive in trying to
go get that well
of course we're going to try to do that
and we've been doing that for years now
the embassy demonstrations were part of
that kind of campaign
we've had to be of course more inventive
in organizing publicly since the press
restrictions were imposed in
in south africa network coverage in the
united states by a canadian study has
dropped by two-thirds
since those restrictions were imposed
and you know we're very television
dependent country and in the united
states if it's not on television for
most americans it doesn't exist
we think this forum serves uh to
indicate to the people of this country
that the the concern is
at a level as high as it has ever been
and we will continue to push that and i
understand our mission now to be two
things one
to develop uh strong sanctions that uh
uh pressure the south african government
to negotiate
uh as a part of our overall
responsibility in the western community
to bring them to the table with all of
the resources that we can marshal
and we will continue to do everything in
our capacity to make certain that
happens while the window of opportunity
for such negotiations
is still open
yes
by which you'd like to see the steps
you've outlined implemented and by when
you'd like to see the government come to
the negotiating table
well that's really happened uh
in 1910 already i suppose
so the timetable is is is a very short
one it we work simply on the basis of
everything that can happen as soon as
possible
it is it is a matter of historical
record now that if
the kind of pressures that we had asked
for
in 1985 had been put in place on the
south african government the disasters
that have happened in our country and
the number of lives that were lost the
number of people
in jail and the number of children in
exile and killed that that would have
been a totally different situation if
you had had
an administration in the united states
who were willing to do what we had asked
and also if you had had a greater
willingness in europe to respond
positively to those urgent pleas that we
made then the whole situation could have
been changed and by now could have had a
totally totally different impact on uh
on the history of south africa so what
we are saying is we are already
racing against the clock we are already
looking at many things that have
happened that are totally unnecessary um
and were totally unnecessary and so we
are saying as soon as possible
this that we have asked for should be
put in place and as soon as possible the
south african government should find
itself in the position where it would
have no option whatsoever but to come to
negotiating table and talk about peace
and talk about creating the kind of
democracy that south africa's people
have asked for i'm afraid that we have
run out of time the delegation schedule
is very tight i want to thank you all
for coming
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
join us this sunday evening beginning at
6 30 pm eastern time 3 30 pacific when
we'll re-air this american forum on
south africa
coming up next after we break for some
schedule information we'll bring you
highlights from wednesday's session of
the senate and debate on minimum wage
legislation
[Music]
[Music]
washington dc
our zip code is two zero zero zero one
[Music]
just ahead on c-span 2 we'll take you to
the carter center at emory university
for coverage of a conference examining
civil conflicts around the world the
carter center is a non-profit
organization dedicated to resolving
conflict promoting democracy fighting
hunger and preserving human rights
around the world the conference includes
a consultation among the members of the
international negotiation network the
inn is an informal network of world
leaders universities and experts which
spotlights certain international
conflicts and looks to solve them
peacefully you'll hear discussion and
working reports from the conference the
conference was convened by president
carter chairman of the inn and founder
of the carter center you will hear from
south african archbishop desmond tutu
representatives from the united nations
and unicef andrew young
former mayor of atlanta and others we
now take you to the carter center for
this conference held this past week in
atlanta
[Music]
i think it's okay to go ahead and start
although we the
one bus just arrived and i think the
last people are coming in
first i want to recognize the presence
of my friend president aristide from
haiti president rst would you stand up
just a moment
[Applause]
this is a man who brought hope to the
long oppressed people of his country and
in the election it was held
in december of 1990
over the opposition of
about a dozen formidable opponents
then
a
new candidate to politics rsd
received
two-thirds of the total vote
and the outpouring of
affection and appreciation love and
excitement
of the haitian people exceeded anything
i've ever seen in my life
and i think
largely because
there was no
follow-up by the international community
a military coup has taken place
and now i think a revitalized
organization of american states
who will be visited by president
aristide
and some of the representatives from the
parliament in
haiti
tomorrow
will try to
expedite
an arrangement under which president rst
can return to his country
this illustrates several points that we
have been addressing
this week
we
first of all
want to be aware of potential
conflicts
to understand the causes of
war
and to take action if we can to
encourage
non-government organizations and
official agencies
national governments international
organizations to
address the basic causes of war
the remarkable papers that we've studied
on ethnicity and the understanding that
we have
of poverty deprivation hopelessness
oppression human rights violations
environmental degree degradation
all those issues
that lead to
hopelessness
and the preference of war to peace is
something that we need to address
another one obviously that we've
addressed this week
in just a representative way are the
active conflicts
that are still going on within which
people are dying every day
this would obviously be the case for
instance in the sudan
and and in afghanistan
in burma
another issue that we have addressed
are the conflicts that are present in a
dormant stage but where final conclusion
of
peace agreements have not yet been
concluded liberia is the most active
case
and the long-standing differences that
exist in the peninsula of korea and also
in cyprus
and the last issue is the one most
vividly demonstrated by the presence of
president aristide and that is a
follow-up how can we build upon
a successful effort to negotiate peace
or to bring about peace
to hold
follow-up elections where people can
choose their own leaders and have a role
in their destiny
and do this effectively and consistently
and with some
uh degree of international cooperation
these are the facets that we will
address uh in the concluding parts of
our of our session this morning we're
going to have reports back from the
working groups all of you have
participated i want to express my deep
thanks to you
for your persistence and your patience
sometimes the
statements were long and extended but i
think they were the outpouring
of tremendous interest
on the part of the 200 or so people who
have assembled here
and you've seen the difficulty of some
issues the intransigence of some parties
the root causes of some of the conflicts
and i hope we will explore
definitively today some of the actions
it might be take to bring an end to
these conflicts and prevent others
and i'll be calling
as a chairman on on these groups
to make reports
later on in the day
we'll have an address by sunny ramfall
who
has been the secretary general of the
commonwealth countries who has a
deep
breadth of understanding of
the overall picture of world conflict
and then in the afternoon
we've now arranged for a satellite link
uh between this group
uh and the
former uh foreign minister the soviet
union edward shepard nazi you have a
blue card
uh in your seats i presume we would like
for you during this morning session uh
prior to the lunch break
if you have a question that you would
like to propose to sheba nazi
if you would write it on that blue card
and turn it in we would appreciate it
and then we'll go through i won't but
the
the coordinates of our
of our organization will go
through those cards and eliminate
duplications
and after uh
four minister shepard nazi makes his
opening remarks
uh
we'll exchange those questions with him
or perhaps addressing the president or
future situation
and what was the soviet union or perhaps
his own ideas about how to strengthen
the recommendations that we have derived
this week but please do that
uh the white card
uh
we would like for you to say what you
can do what your own organization can do
or it's not
printed for you but if you
have specific ideas that you have
derived from this week or have
frustrated been frustrated in presenting
your own views please put down
your ideas on what you personally can do
or your organization might do to
carry out the recommendations that
you'll be receiving this morning
dale
spencer has asked me to summarize the
discussion
that took place on the first issue
and that's the issue of national
sovereignty
before i
embark on this task i'd like to
recognize the presence of andrew young
andy please stand up
andy has been the mayor of atlanta he's
uh now preparing for the
1996 olympics we hope you'll all
participate
uh and as you know andy was one of the
most
brilliant
representatives to the united nations
that their bodies ever seen he was one
of those who was most effective in
healing
the still existing wounds
or differences that exist between the
rich nations of the world and the poor
countries
on earth and andy i want to thank you
for for for coming and is also one of
our council members and he's been out of
town the last few days we're glad you
could come and join us for this last
session
dale do you have any other announcements
that i should make before we begin the
program
is it your idea that we should have the
reports and then some discussion about
the reports in each case or how
okay
all right well why don't we do this and
i'll be i'll certainly be brief we'll
ask all of the presenters who some of
whom have stayed up all night i might
add
to present uh the reports from the
individual study groups and then we'll
have time at the end for a general
discussion
well i've already made some comments
that address the national sovereignty
issue this was led by brian urcard he
was has been welcome to perform this
duty but he asked me to do it and i'm
not sure that i'm completely qualified
not as much as he
first of all
some of the problem situations we
realize that there are still horrendous
violations of human rights on earth
uh quite often these human rights
violations and the deprivation
of people who are without power and
without authority and who sometimes are
articulate or even homeless and
poverty-stricken lead to internal
conflicts and at this time
in the world
there are no major wars between
sovereign nations in that absence we
need to understand what causes people
who are neighbors to rise up
against one another and even
risk the loss of their own lives to
change an existing situation or to
perpetuate their own role in society
we also have had a good discussion i
think about vital
environmental issues
one of the most serious problems that
has never been addressed adequately
we hope will be
at least examined this year
is it is a total difference in
perspective between
the industrialized nations on earth
and the
less developed countries on earth about
what all legitimate environmental
concerns
things that we take for granted
as part of our own lives
as far as environment is concerned of
almost
non-existent interest to countries that
are still struggling for a livelihood
or decent
production of food for their people
even in the harvesting of timber which
has become increasingly a matter of
interest to the world
or for
us and the united states to preach to
countries
say in southeast asia about how
they should restrict or stop their
harvesting of
of
trees is totally uh
incompatible with with an objective
point of view
the united states for instance is
practically giving away
our virgin forest in oregon and
washington and in alaska at the same
time we're telling
people in malaysia and and in other
countries don't harvest your trees
because they're precious they're 300
years old and they take a long time to
replace them those kind of
misunderstandings
are cause of of differences not only
here but but in other countries and the
loss of
of topsoil
the sedimentation in streams not only
cuts down on the ability of people to
produce food
on their land but also to harvest fish
this results in destification the
movement of people from the ancient
homelands into urban centers
the building up of different political
priorities and the degeneration of
societies
as you may or may not know in africa as
a continent
every year for the last 20 years
there has been a reduction in the food
produced per person
and statistics show that the average
african citizen now has 70 calories less
per day
than
they had
20 years ago
when at that time the diet was
inadequate that is a kind of thing
that can lead
to wars
the flow of arms is another issue that
we discussed
and i think it's accurate to say again
that the superpowers and those who
depended upon us industrialized nations
have been the main ones that put forward
uh sometimes at cut rate prices and even
with political pressure uh the offering
of weapons to countries which helps to
precipitate uh conflicts and massive
loss of lives and it was pointed out by
several speakers uh in this discussion
on this subject it's not just the
formidable weapons the threat of nuclear
weapons or
or the mass destructive weapons
involving
uh chemical or biological warfare but
it's the ak-47s
the uzis and even the pistols
the hand grenades and the devastating
placement of landmines
that causes the loss of life
also as was pointed out increasingly
wars have become much more
lethal
in nature
and the loss of life
shifted from armed soldiers on the
battlefield
or to an increasing percentage of people
who are civilians who lose their lives
defenseless hopeless
sometimes not even understanding the
causes of the conflict that cost them
their lives
this is another matter that needs to be
promulgated by us
national sovereignty is a is a very
serious question to be addressed
as an impediment
to the resolution of conflicts
this exists as a heritage from the past
where
nation states were identified almost
exclusively as homogeneous
populations that were totally separated
politically sometimes geographically
from neighbors
and there was very little breaking down
of the uh borders
between two countries but with the
increase of communications with ease of
travel with the knowledge of one another
the movement of people the rapidly
increasing number of refugees
those nation-state boundaries have
become less and less significant
and divisions among people the
relation directed to people themselves
not just to governments has become more
important but as we know the chart of
the united nations
the constitutions and laws of countries
are still designed to
ignore to a great extent the needs of
individuals and to deal still with
nation states as the ultimate entity
that's to be addressed
this brings about all kinds of problems
one is that one that is frustrating to
all of us and that is in most civil wars
it's not proper for or permissible for
the united nations
the organization of american states and
the organization african unity even to
become involved in
the resolution of a conflict
uh this is prohibited by the charter of
united nations and non-intervention
but non-intervention is is
obviously a good
a good
phrase to use a good principle if it's
defined
or properly but to mean that you can't
even address horrendous human rights
abuses inside a country or even to make
an international effort to resolve a
civil war that is not a proper
definition of non-intervention and we
and we'd like to see the the new
policies
of the united nations an expanded role
of the oas and the oau and others
uh be recognized by combatant groups in
a country to which they can turn
to get help from these international
groups in the absence of that
of course the role of the
non-governmental organizations like like
we represent
is an increasingly important factor
one thing is the lack of coordination
and the duplication of effort of the
ngos
we've we've heard the
brilliant presentations in some of the
groups of what is being done already by
the catholic relief societies
by the mennonites
by save the children and by others the
international red cross quite often
these groups are
prevented from carrying out their duties
effectively
by a war-torn environment within which
they cannot work properly because of
obstruction of delivery of relief
supplies and other relief efforts this
has been most notably publicized at
least in sudan
and when i first began going to ethiopia
there was almost a total prohibition of
a delivery of relief
even to the refugees in in major
official camps so this is another
problem the president and presently as
you as was discussed yesterday in
afghanistan
or where they're in campaign rather
where there's an effort being made to
bring people together the relief
agencies that are there find almost a
non-existent government and are
prevented from delivering supplies
there's another role where the united
nations might be expanded in its effort
to have a coordinator designated by the
secretary general of the united nations
with the support of the member countries
that could help strengthen and
coordinate the delivery of relief
supplies
i think that another thing is that
the international
community
should
join in with amnesty international with
the lawyers committee on human rights
uh asia watch africa watch america watch
now a middle east east watch positions
for human rights and others to have
these
watch committees
strengthened in their effectiveness it's
not just enough to point out the fact
that a lawyer a prominent human rights
lawyer has been arrested and
incarcerated or the fact that a uh an
outspoken newspaper or magazine
has been interrupted in his publication
that this is where a large part of the
effort on human rights is expended
whereas at this in the same country
there might be eight or ten thousand
people who die
in a year's time because of a war going
on but there's no doubt that these ngos
designed to expose human rights
violations need to be strengthened in
their effectiveness by both governments
by other ngos and also by international
agencies
i think that another issue that we
discussed if i remember was
was a guarantee of security for
non-state peoples
when i uh
left the white house there were
several seven million
refugees in the world
that was in january of 1981 10 years ago
there are now 17 million
refugees
and this doesn't include the displaced
persons i think all of us understand the
difference a refugee is a person
displaced from one's home who has moved
into another country who has no country
within
within which to live if they don't leave
their own country
but are displaced from their villages or
farms or homes
and take up a
non-acceptable residence within that
country they're displaced persons that
don't come under the purview
of the u.n high commission on refugees
they don't get the allotted food and
medicine and clothing per day that is
allocated by formula
and as i pointed out to some rose and i
visited about 40 000 dinka tribesmen who
had been forced out of their southern
halls by the war and now living on top
of a garbage dump on the outskirts of
cartoon they are not included in the
refugee figures and the number of
displaced persons is
arguable but the point is that this is a
rapidly increasing problem that is not
presently being addressed
what action we should take i'll conclude
my remarks by saying that first of all
is an early warning system that we hope
to evolve to let the world know what is
going on where are the danger points
where might we see
civil war
in prospect what can the international
community do
to try to prevent
a war breaking out what can we do to
alleviate the suffering of people who
might become so desperate that they take
up arms
this is a very important important
consideration the second is to
strengthen
and to create mechanisms to deal with
intra
national conflicts that is civil wars
there's an abysmal vacuum now in the
world
society
in dealing with civil wars
uh and there's just an embryonic effort
now being made particularly this
conference to say how can we deal with
these civil wars which quite often are
ignored
uh by the world community partially out
of frustration if we know something
can't be done i believe nothing can be
done about a civil war we are naturally
inclined as human beings to ignore it
and to say well it doesn't exist or
that's not my responsibility
but to deal with the special problems of
ethnic groups of increasing numbers of
refugees of human rights violations
within a country
those standards need to be updated and
quite often it was pointed out
abusers of people
use the somewhat outdated
1949 geneva convention rules
to permit them to deprive
people of their own human rights and
quite often the geneva standards instead
of being used to protect people are used
to justify oppression
of the same people
the national sovereignty
actions again to create the mechanisms
for
monitoring and responding to the ill
treatment of ethnic groups i think this
afternoon it's very likely
that uh mr sheba nazi if he's asked
questions would describe the problems
within the former soviet union in
dealing with ethnicity
as long as there was a totalitarian
communist government
or in the soviet union or ethnic
differences or grievances human rights
abuses were concealed
but with so-called
glasnost and the openness of a society
these differences became better known
and are now very likely to expand
or in their
adverse effect we've seen this with the
war between the cruds
and the serbs and yugoslavia
fragmentation of that country and we
presently see it in chevron's home
uh republic of georgia
where only yesterday the
leader who was forced out
a few days ago by pressure from his own
people has had has returned
about 150 miles from tbilisi and he's
called for the movement into the policy
to re-establish
uh his role there so so so i think
ethnicity is another factor that we will
have to
learn about and how to
address these are some of the ideas that
were presented in this very exciting
discussion
that was held
led by brian ercart and the council
members and the audience
the next report that will be made
concerns afghanistan
sonny ron paul led that discussion and
he will take charge of this part of the
program
mr president yesterday afternoon i
gave colleagues a thumbnail sketch
of that discussion that we had in the
working group on afghanistan
and i am going to ask in a moment the
rapporteur
of the working group to present the
an account
of our discussions but let me just say
at the outset that
with with afghanistan we're dealing with
a conflict
that the world is forgetting
as the high-profile involvement of the
superpowers and major powers
has very largely ended at least in an
overt way
so the world has turned its attention
away from afghanistan
but the end of that massive involvement
has not brought peace to afghanistan
afghanistan remains at war
the people of afghanistan remain in a
horrendous situation
seven million
of them are either refugees five million
refugees in in pakistan largely 2
million displaced persons millions
literally millions
maimed and suffering from the aftermath
of war
so afghanistan is very much an area of
conflict
and represents in a very special way
that state of war after war
we had the benefit
at that time of having with us
uh
afghans
uh
who have played important roles uh in
the evolution of this conflict uh and it
was quite remarkable i said to you
yesterday that we managed to get up on
the balcony and that was true
it wasn't a room in which the conflict
was being waged but in which afghans
were coming together
and saying these are the ways in which
we think you can help us to solve this
conflict because we know that we have to
solve it
i want to invite our rapporteur against
that background
to convey the essence of that discussion
which as you will hear focused very
substantially on the faith now being
reposed by afghans in the united nations
and in the process that has been started
by the united nations
and promises to bring peace to
afghanistan
uh the rapporteur is dr robert
canfield who is a social anthropologist
uh professor of anthropology at
washington university and i would like
to invite him to come up to the
microphone
and convey to colleagues the essence of
our conversations
i want to thank you mr president for the
invitation to come
and uh all i want to express my
appreciation to all of the others who've
been involved in making this uh
conference so successful and i
consider it a special privilege
a great deal you've already heard about
the suffering in afghanistan and the
difficulties i thought i would list
briefly the barriers
to
the resolution of this conflict we
fortunately did not
become involved in the the interminable
discussions about causes
and that
was i think very useful to us we had as
has been said a wonderful group
very fine uh group of very
knowledgeable people to be involved in
this discussion
uh one of the barriers that was
especially stressed was the lack of
legitimacy
the the group
is of course familiar with the lack of
legitimacy of the government of kabul uh
which was the basis of the uprisings
against
the kabul regime but since
the soviets left
the legitimacy of the leadership of the
resistance groups has also waned
substantially so that there is a a great
vacuum now
of an authoritative recognized uh group
of people who can be considered
appropriate leaders for this resistance
in relationship to that lack of
legitimate leadership their
legitimacy of leadership there's also a
lack of accountability for the huge
amounts of funds that are being
funneled into this country and that
is part of this difficulty of
establishing
structures that can
can make governance and leadership
possible
another
major barrier to
the resolution of this conflict are the
internal divisions among the afghans
themselves they're
especially in the last three years
there's been not only internal division
among the resistance groups but direct
fighting and in terrorist acts among the
afghans themselves
uh
a point that uh is is very crucial in
this conflict is the import is the is
the role of the foreign powers
in this conflict you're aware that the
invasion of the soviet uh union
uh was the beginning of the war
as we know it
but many powers have been involved in
in this uh conflict now many powers have
uh have invested heavily in this and in
fact uh we understand that uh uh until
the the coup in in the in the soviet
union uh the kgb continued to be
involved in kabul but there are on the
other side number of
international presences large amounts of
wealth and advice
being still funneled into this area
there are still abundant
supplies of weapons
um in the in the area
uh the country is armed to the teeth all
sides
uh and they're of course as i say many
more than than the two sides that are
often discussed
there's a tremendous distrust and fear
now
among the afghans about the emerging
situation the uncertainty about the
future
there have
have long been
tensions among the ethnic groups in the
country but the minority groups within
afghanistan are particularly uh
sensitive to the uh to the important uh
prominence that the push students have
uh have had in afghan history uh and uh
now the tension between the ethnic
minorities most of whom are essentially
persian speakers as opposed to the
posture speakers
is a continuing uh
basis of tension in the country the
country is also divided and has
historically been divided among uh
religious sects which
additionally
cross cuts these uh these social
loyalties and continues to undermine the
uh the possibilities for
the development of uh a sense of trust
among them
uh there there's a great deal of
uncertainty about the status of the
populations in in kabul
the status of the people who in kabul
have been
under the kaaba regime many of them
bureaucrats
and it's not simply that the country is
divided between those who support and
those who oppose the kaaba regime
because most of the people in the rural
country land
countryside have relatives in kabul so
that the country
is is torn
over these loyalties by this by this war
in that sense
there's of course the continuing sense
of uh
of of uh fear uh a sense of uncertainty
about their personal well-being and
their personal
uh their future um another barrier to
to the resolution of this conflict is
the narcotics trade afghanistan in this
period of 13 years of war
has
become the largest producer of opium uh
they're producing uh
2 000 metric tons of opium rosin a year
200 tons of heroin
and this has helped to finance
this war and therefore has has made it
become a special problem in the in this
there's of course a shortage of funds
for reconstruction but also for the
development and maintenance of a
government
at the time that the soviets withdrew
in 1989 that
there was a great deal of interest in
supporting the afghan reconstruction
perhaps there were funds then we we had
the sense that there were more funds
then we don't sense that the funds for
what needs to take place
are uh are in or are in place at the
present time let me add to this list
something that's not there is uh the
huge damage to the society
that has taken place uh as has already
been mentioned there's been a great
human cost but besides that there is the
the cost of the dispersion and
alienation of the educated afghans the
afghans who might be most prominent in
the reconstruction of this country have
been dispersed all over the world and
many of them have lost contact with
the
with their own homeland or
become so engrossed and involved in
other things uh other
problems uh that it may be difficult to
bring them back in
to to the reconstruction process
and uh moreover there has been a
collapse
of under general understandings about
what a government should look like
and so that when we talk about the
reconstruction
of afghanistan and the establishment of
a new government we are referring to
not only
putting things back together but
constructing a new system entirely
presumably possibly a new system
entirely there are some encouraging uh
dimensions of the situation
as this group will know the united
states and the soviet union have agreed
to withhold the support for the flow of
arms into the area which has been a
major development
the other interested nations also
are
coming on board with this process and
they're indications of a growing fatigue
among the afghan groups on various sides
and hopefully there may
be a willingness now to
to allow mediation uh to take place
the strategies that we have in mind to
to to stress
uh uh have to do primarily with
with this uh tremendous difficulty of
reconstructing an administrative
structure through which
a nation can be reconstituted
the steps need to be taken for
the formation of a legitimate government
now a crucial part of that
is the uh is the role of the
international uh community the
international community as i say has
been involved in this war
uh i have have had interests in this war
uh now it's very crucial that um
that there be a unanimity among the
various
powers involved
in the process that should take place
and uh to to to support
the formation of a nation government
that will be broke
that will uh have a government a nation
that is in in shreds
and uh will take some time to actually
be
reconstituted in any meaningful sense so
that in this transition period the role
of the international powers is strategic
we
we feel that the focus of support should
be on the un process
that is already underway
that's uh that
united nations officials have been on
the scene working for some time
they've had a tremendous a number of
years of experience
and uh
as was mentioned they may have they may
be the only ones who have been in
contact with all of the elements of this
resistance and therefore are in a
position to uh to to understand
and to to to oversee and sponsor this
kind of reconstruction
uh project
um
the un program itself
entails the success
cessation of all hostilities on all
sides
the cessation of the shipments of arms
but a point that needs to be stressed is
that there appear to be some elements
who have been involved in the war
who have ceased uh
shipping arms
but
are continuing to supply
large
amounts of funds
for armed shipments
and
we hope that that will very very soon be
be curtailed the un program entails the
the gathering of an afghan community
that will represent a credible and uh
impartial transition mechanism for the
reconstruct for the development of an
electoral process
on the basis of which a new government
can be formed
we we especially want to stress
since my time is short i want to
especially stress one other part of the
picture
the importance of insisting that all
parties
honor and assist in the enforcement of
the un declaration of human rights as as
president carter carter mentioned in his
presentation we want to
to provide an environment that is
inhospitable to to the violation of
human rights we want to encourage ngos
to to use their their powers to to
collect uh to to coordinate their
activities and at the same time
to contribute to this process i've been
given a note
may i
which is to
i'm having trouble reading this
maybe you can get somebody to rewrite it
and we'll read it later on
thank you dr thank you sorry
i might add parenthetically and i won't
say this again that the secretary
general
of the united nations
has
informed me that he's going to come
and meet with me personally and we'll
share with him all these recommendations
i need not repeat that again but when we
cover the u.n
uh presence we deliberately chose a
couple of instances where the u.n is
playing a very large role
so we'll encourage a more active pursuit
of of policies and plans already
promulgated by the u.n and also offer
the services of ngos
to participate in the resolution of
these conflicts
i'd like to ask all the uh presenters
to follow the example of of the one
that's just completed to watch uh down
here for the time limits because we have
as i said 11
of these presentations to make we want
to stay on time
the next one is on angola
and uh
bishop desmond tutu conducted this
this discussion appreciation also to the
secretariat of the inn and
staff persons of the qatar center
our meeting
on the angola group
in the angola group was
conducted in a very good atmosphere a
very friendly
uh gathering
and it was wonderful to see
former enemies
getting on like
well a house on fire
english has some very funny expressions
but there you are they did they did get
on like a house on fire
the group identified
21 barriers
and as an example of the rapprochement
that has happened between
those who were erstwhile enemies
the two
persons one representing unita and the
other representing
the government of angola
helped to choose six of the 21 and
arrange them in order of priority
the
first part of our work was to identify
barriers
and
they
put at the top of their list electoral
issues
it is quite clear that it is going to be
important for the incoming government
of
a peaceful angola
that there is no question at all about
its legitimacy and so in the matter of
electoral issues they were asking for
help
and with voter registration
electoral laws
helping to build
political parties
but especially
on the question of
the campaigning surrounding the
election
and um the need for international
monitoring of that whole process
and
the
experience of the united nations in in
namibia would be something that would
come in
um
very handy here
the second set
of barriers related to the
demobilization of
the
two armies
uh the need
for containing
those
um who would be united in the new
national army of
angola
and a very crucial problem
the problem of
um
the mines scattered all over
that beautiful country
and the cost
astronomical cost
for the angolan government if they were
to pay the cost of having to remove
those mines
another set of barriers
related to what do you do
with
demobilized soldiers
persons who may have guns
and who are floating around in the
country needing food
that they pose a very serious danger
that there will be a breakdown of normal
life law and order and that they will
contribute to disruption
what is going to happen to the several
thousands of um internally displaced
persons
and
again
what is the cost
and of training
the soldiers training the displaced
persons so that they will take their
place
in a normal society
those were some of the problems
the
strategies that were
identified
when
the need to have an
international entity that would convene
a
a meeting of relief agencies so that
their work was coordinated
the need to involve
persons and groups
for
monitoring the elections
and
to call a meeting of donors
for
the
country
is
one that is
suffer has suffered considerably as a
result of the war
we need to have programs
for the
demobilized and there were specific
actions
directed to different persons
that are recommended
the
first is to urge
the
angolan president
and the leader of unita
to request
the united nations secretary general
formally
to appoint a special representative for
angola and we
were able to
hear of the experience
um
in afghanistan of the special
representative there and the
tremendously useful work that
he has been able to put in
the second is to request the secretary
general of the oau
formally to support the
request of the ambalance
to the united nations
for a special representative of the
secretary general of the un for angola
to ask president carter
to contact the secretary general
requesting him to appoint a special
representation so that we we get these
requests coming from
different directions underlining the
importance um of the particular
request
and then to urge those
parties that were involved
in the conflict external parties
especially
to contribute to
the costs
that the country is going to incur
when it seeks to deal with the
problems of demobilization and those
countries the united states
russia portugal
and the european community
is asked to join that effort
and it is important that
something is done and done
urgently to remove minds
so that
normal
life can resume
the group asked that the
inn
begin
to move into the possibilities of
monitoring the elections and as we've
said
the important thing there is to ensure
the legitimacy of those who will
ultimately have won that election so
that they are acceptable
urging
ngos
especially those operating in angola to
work with
the subcommittee of the joint political
and military commission
in
retraining troops
helping them to
be reintegrated into
civilian life
and then
to ask
the oau
to help organize a conference a regional
conference in southern africa on
demobilization because
there are a number of countries there
which have had experience or are in the
process of demobilizing
different armies and there are learnings
that can be shared
and
to urge
the angolan government
um
together with unita to create a body
that would coordinate
um
the
retraining
this is
angola is
the first fruits
of the ending of the civil war of the
cold war
and it presents a wonderful opportunity
for the world
to cooperate
to bring peace
where formerly
there was war
destruction destruction
and disruption
thank you
i was contacted this morning uh by
representative of the government senate
they would like for the inn to help
coordinate the election in angola
as has been mentioned earlier we
helped with the election in zambia the
last day of october
we've already scheduled full
participation in coordinating the
election in liberia and
i think if the proper invitations come
from all
interested parties we would do this
in angola
i might say we have to work with other
major
ngos
and others like the national democratic
institute who have the staff and
capability to train
poll watchers
to orchestrate the proper election
commission role
to help us supervise the conduct of the
campaigns and so forth
and
in
zambia by the time elections were held
on a crash program we had 3 500 trained
poll watchers who were present in almost
every place that people cast votes and
that was the essence of
the reason for success
the next uh presentation will be on
burma
this discussion was headed by mrs marie
angelique sabanee
thank you very
much the burma group
is going to present a very short summary
of our discussion the discussion were
quite lively
and then we will issue a
more lengthy report
the buma working group
included representatives
of non-governmental organizations
inter-governmental organizations
ethnic minority groups
and the national coalition government
of the unions of the union of burma
the group considered
and identified
constructive proposal
aimed at resolving
the political and military conflict
in burma peacefully
through direct
negotiation
the group regretted
the absence
of representatives of the state law and
order reconstruction council slog
the group calls for direct negotiation
without delay
the burma working group commanded the
vision of president jimmy carter
and the good offices of the
international
negotiation network
the working group
and president carter
are convinced that the time has come for
direct negotiation
the leaders of the nations of the
association
of southeast
asian nations
and of other interested countries
including
china
japan
the united states and the european
community
and also the united nations
are obliged to redouble
their efforts to promote
the climate
and circumstances
for direct negotiations
president carter's personal role
in this process will be welcomed he
could be supported
in this task by eminent person from asia
the conflict in burma
has caused great human suffering
the conflict elicits powerful human
emotions
the people of burma
and the nation of burma
are destined to elevate
and honor
the highest aspirations of the human
spirit which burma and its people
deserve to achieve
through immediate direct negotiation
leading to national reconstruction so
then we will issue a more detailed
report thank you very much
the next presentation will be on
cambodia campus
dr kumar
you might find it convenient to come on
the
cambodian
consultation
as
i said yesterday was
an exercise in discussing
the comprehensive
peace plan
and the issues which are concerned
with peace building
and this
consultation
was
particularly focusing
on the critical issues
which are coming up during the interim
transition period
in
fully
implementing
the existing u.n plan
for cambodia
now this cambodian settlement also
is
a reflection of the of a settlement
after the cold war
and sees the united nations
in his best
role
not only as a peacekeeper
but also as a peace builder
in reconstructing
a war-torn society
which has been deeply divided
for decades
therefore it is imperative
in the new world order
that is being promulgated
that all efforts must be made and given
to the united nations to implement fully
the program
which it has undertaken
now in terms of the barriers
for
the settlement
we cannot ignore the past mistrust
amongst the
parties to the conflict
there has been a heritage of civil war
and conflict
and these perceptions and misperceptions
are bound to reappear and reproduce
itself
during the priest process itself
with a danger
of covert
non-compliance
within the military provisions
of the peace plan itself
the critical issue which was identified
is the insufficient
money for government essential services
this is due
to the withdrawal of soviet aid
the privatization of state enterprises
where the national budget has been cut
drastically
where the public service is literally
collapsing
and unless
immediately
funds are made available
to
consolidate the administration
there is a danger
that the un peace plan
itself
be endangered
in that there will be no administrative
capability
to implement the proposals within the
local context
the other issue
is the diplomatic
obstacles to aid
and particularly here
in that the bilateral aid agencies
must immediately
consider ways of supporting
development
projects and programs
without waiting
for the formal government to be
established after the elections
and i think it is this critical period
which is very very crucial
and where
president carter
was requested to urge
to the secretary general
the importance of intervening
during this very critical period in
consolidating and sustaining the process
now
in terms of the strategies
the implementation of a comprehensive
political settlement
and
this
means that
even within the free elections which
have been
considered
there is a need for a support
to that election process
and for all the other elements
of the
peace
plan which also requires the
participation
of non-governmental organizations
and other agencies
and looking at the lacuna
and the gaps within the program
so that private agencies could be
supportive
of that general effect
as in all cases
the question of the transfer of
knowledge and development of human
resources is critical
given the fact
that very little expertise and local
expertise
is available
there is a need for contingency
operations
so that skills and expertise
from all over the world could be
deployed at short notice
so as to fully develop an integrated
plan
for cambodia
in terms of actions
what was brought to attention like in
most cases
of
situations of this kind
is the need for coordination
it was stressed again
the need for full funding and political
support
for the united nations peace plan
particularly since the un program in
cambodia
is not yet fully funded
and this requires high level
intervention
and the media
to push though government donor
government
to pay up
on their obligations
and this is a very critical issue
for where public attention
has to be sustained
in the
obligation to pay
in terms of actions again it was
reiterated
that
not to allow the existing administration
to collapse
and that this interim period
this would become a critical factor
which should be brought to the attention
of the secretary general
now in terms of the monitoring
capabilities
it was also suggested
that independent monitoring
by non-governmental agencies
be requested to monitor
the peace plan and the implementation
of the police plan particularly the
issue of human rights
the issue of compliance
and so many issues
for independent agents to be involved
now
on the question of resources
what was pointed out
was that cambodia lives within a dynamic
market oriented economies of southeast
asia
and that the dynamism of
these market economies
could possibly be
a way in which
cambodia could very quickly
become
beneficiaries and
benefit also from the
from the demonstration effect
of its neighbors through investment
plans and trading
it was also noted that there were very
rich human resources
within the region itself
non-governmental organizations
various other agencies who could be
called upon
for training training of personnel
where the non-governmental organizations
could play a role
in training
a vast harder
not only in administration
in translation
the judiciary
in the
in the in the in in conflict resolution
training was identified as a critical
variable
in building a competent administration
for the future
and in this context
the knowledge of overseas cambodians
should be deployed
by developing a roster
of the expertise available
internationally for the development of
cambodia
thank you very much
i only participated in a brief time in
this discussion but one of the crucial
elements there pointed out by save the
children and other
humanitarian agencies was the inability
to deliver services
to the people because of an almost
non-existent government
we face the same kind of problem as a
matter of fact since i was in the white
house i pointed this out to the group
when following our own
government's
bombing and the use of agent orange in
cambodia during the vietnam war
an action that was
lied about even to the u.s
congress and to the american people at
the time
we felt responsible for what has
happened in cambodia since then
at the end of my term i think in 1980 i
couldn't go over to see the problem of
the refugees who had assembled in the
eastern part of thailand but i asked my
wife rosen to go and she took a group
there and and there was a pinup desire
among ngos and government agencies to
deliver supplies to refugees and others
who were pouring out of cambodia into
adjacent countries that the problem was
that they couldn't get any coordination
in this effort when you have a hundred
of or so
different agencies trying to serve the
same people quite often they conflict
with each other you couldn't get ships
unloaded you couldn't get trucks
allotted so when rosen came back
we asked the u.n secretary general that
time to come to the oval office we
explained the problem to him
he assigned a top level coordinator to
go into that troubled region
and and very shortly the supplies were
delivered the relief services were made
possible to alleviate the suffering this
is one of the things that might be done
now in cambodia as was discussed is to
ask the
new secretary general to appoint a
high-level u.n official just to
coordinate the delivery of supplies and
relief services to the suffering people
of cambodia even prior to the time when
a dependable government can be formed
and maybe later elections held i think
that's what the the role that we can
play
as as a group here of non-governmental
uh agency leaders
the next presentation will be on uh
cyprus
again again former secretary general uh
ramfal led this group
thank you president carter
uh the group on cyprus was very
substantially
constituted
by
members of the cypriot communities
who came to atlanta
to take advantage of this opportunity
uh
it gave it a very special character
not of a of a negotiation
uh but of a meeting place
uh where the issues could be discussed
with with frankness in a very real and
positive way
and an exploration made of the pathways
to solutions
i said yesterday that it
it was characterized by a high level of
civility
uh
i said to the parties themselves and i
i hope they accepted it
without any suggestion that i was
attempting to be patronizing that
coming out of the ancient cultures of
greece and turkey
they seemed to bring to conflict
a very special measure
of
of civility
but there is perhaps a danger in that
too
uh that one could
be so civil about conflict
uh that it perpetuates itself into
making discord a way of life
uh and the parties were very conscious
that the this was a long-running
conflict in cyprus
uh and that while time had helped in
some respects it was not a positive
factor now
uh that there was need to move on
speedily uh to carry forward the work
that had already been done and the
achievements that have already been made
and they're very substantial
largely through the inter-communal
process in the hands of the united
nations
to carry it forward to completion
and they were aware
that the international community itself
is becoming impatient uh of uh a
perpetuation of the conflict and will be
exercising its own influences in a
variety of ways to bring the most
friendly pressures on all the parties uh
to bring that conflict uh into
resolution
we explored many dimensions of the
conflict and i will invite the
rapporteur in a moment to present the uh
the discussion to you
i would like to add that
the parties did identify as you will
hear a number of instances
some of them that might sound very small
but which together help to
bridge the gap
uh that still exists to create points of
contact to build areas of confidence
that can all contribute to a resolution
and a removal of particularly some of
the psychological barriers that stand
are still in the way of solutions
and that in that process there is a role
four facilities like the inn for the
good offices of individuals like
president carter uh all working to
assist uh the united nations process
i'd like therefore uh without adding
more to the to the presentation to
invite uh dr nicholas stavrou who is a
professor of international affairs uh
here at howard university and who is the
editor of the mediterranean quarterly
copies of which i see
floating around freely
to
come forward as the rapid tour of our
group and present the discussion to you
dr stavros thank you mr chairman thank
you president carter it is my pleasure
to do so
with the wise counsel of the chairman of
the group we bypassed history and the
finger pointing
we did not
dwell a great deal as to who did what to
whom in the past but instead we've
concentrated on
particular barriers that affect the
resolution of conflict strategies to be
pursued
and be utilized in the specific steps to
be taken
it was indeed a pleasure to note that
both parties have long time ago
uh
realized that bisonality and
bicameralism are not barriers any longer
but bridges towards the resolution of
the conflict
it was a serious issue 1974 it is no
longer an issue therefore that is uh
to be indicated as progress
however the fallen virus emerged and one
identified them without the
extensive commentary
there are serious psychological barriers
between two communities
i do not want to dwell on issues that
i'm not an expert how do they develop
but the fact is that there is a gap that
persists
and this is reflected in misperceptions
of each other's intentions
it is reflected in
characterizations of each other's
national culture in many respects
particularly by the press
and it affects communication between
the two groups
stereotyping of each other has been one
of the problems that has been reflected
as well in in in the past and it
persists some extent today
other bodies that exist are economic
barriers
the two communities have little exchange
in economic sphere and that is to us a
serious
matter which prevents final resolution
there is also the problem of physical uh
actual physical divisions that makes
elimination of psychological barriers
even more difficult there is what do you
know to be a green line that is not a
wall but serves the same purpose and in
fact it does not serve the resolution
there are fears persistent in both
communities but which have different
origins
the greek community is fearful of the
larger so-called turkish threat from the
other side
they would point to the problems of 1974
and before
the turkish community too is fearful of
being reduced into equal minority within
its own country and be marginalized in
by the majority
these fears are realities we cannot
the group realize them and point them
out
a more serious body in our opinion that
develops and grows is the gradual
drifting apart of the two ethnic groups
and the emerging linguistic barriers
the pre-1974 generations knew each
other's language
that is
gradually disappearing and that of
course does not help
the resolution the conflict in the near
future that is precisely the reason that
the participants thought time is of
essence
quite often questions of sovereignty
raised these questions affect even
elementary exchanges
the transit of the mail
issues of passports
travel
processes and so on all of these are to
a great extent affected by the question
of sovereignty who does put the stem on
a piece of paper is important to both
sides
a serious barrier has been the role of
the press which exacerbates tensions on
both sides i will add here that the
press of the motherlands both grease and
turkey is also responsible for this for
this gap that's creating cybers
it is
my impression uh and it is a fact
actually that the group was
in consensus concerning the specific
strategies to be pursued
and these strategies involve the
following
everybody agree that economic incentives
for the development of north and south
jointly cooperative should be given high
priority
undertaking of joint cooperative
projects without raising political or
sovereign equations is a priority that
has to be pursued
encouragement of individuals with high
standing and prestige
and respect on both sides to cross the
borders
and meet ordinary citizens of both sides
is another way of breaking the
psychological barriers
consideration of ways where ordinary
cypriots of both sides could meet
and just meet without any agendas
two areas have been identified the ghost
town of augusta and the libra palace as
meeting meeting places
there is a beautiful it was a beautiful
town from augusta which is now literally
goes down taken over by
rats and cats
there is no reason why this cannot be
reopened under you and auspices there is
no agreement however as to how this is
to be done and i have to stress that as
well
there should be examination of ways
under which cultural athletic and other
events can take place
and i'm glad to note ambassador young's
presence here today background she can
arrange to have the cyprus olympic team
come to plunder in in
in the olympic games
cooperation enjoying projects in the
environment in similar matters are
issues that
both sides agree and could be pursued
and intensified
a forum could be provided for separate
intellectuals of both greek and turkish
origin to meet and assist in the
development of a sacred consciousness
and mutual respect
i have no specific suggestions here but
backup centers like the car the center
could facilitate such a process
it was suggested that an ngo
organization could undertake a long
long-range examination and evaluation of
the role of the press in cyprus greece
in turkey
to see what does it do
to the exacerbation of the conflict and
what can it do to resolve it currently
it was also suggested that consideration
be given to teaching each other's
language
in public schools
it is inexcusable in a country of half a
million people
that the two communities would not know
each other's language
that was not the case before 1974 at
least in the higher schools both in each
other's language
as a confidence building measure and for
humanitarian reasons the missing persons
station should be given high priority
that is an issue that has been on the
agenda since 1974 there are several
thousand people missing both greeks and
troops and several american citizens as
well
the following action steps
have been identified and recommended
the group recommends that
issues be defined
that is issues which are a win-win type
issues to be pursued
utilize ngos provided they do not
undermine ongoing processes under the un
auspices and i will come to that in a
moment
the issue of missing persons both sides
agree to cooperate on that should be
pursued
expansion of joint projects that have
united nations endorsement and possibly
the expansion in other areas
an example that was mentioned yesterday
was the nicosia master plan which
it was suggested should be expanded to
include the entire island
that has a u.n endorsement
built upon ongoing projects incorporate
on environmental issues and in
such areas as indulgent species and
there was a specific project that has
been mentioned the saving of the turtles
uh which is in the list of integer
species
development of project that could
encourage mutual respect
we are not specific on that and that is
deliberate
work towards the elimination of physical
barriers to human interaction we are
talking about the actual division of the
island it was agreed that the u.n
process was to be endorsed and supported
it was stated that progress has been
made and has been made
and it should we recommend that the
process be assisted by all parties
including
the carter center and inn
it was the group's perception that time
is of essence and therefore all concern
must take that factor into account these
are the steps that we identified
we did not deal with resources for
obvious reasons uh i was it was stated
yesterday that cyprus has
a fairly good economy and the standard
of living is much higher than both
greece and turkeys
we're going to break just a second one
thing you may have noticed is that this
is a cypress room
within which we are meeting
it's not an accident that the carter
center considers his cyprus issue to be
uh profound importance
um
i think one of the suggestions that did
have the carter center's name on it that
we might provide a forum here
for non-official
sypia turks and greeks to meet here
to discuss some
issues of all kinds including obviously
this list would be a very
interesting project
george paris cavities and his wife
thelma were the ones that were generous
enough to give us the funds to build
this room and i think if we go back to
uh mr paris comedies that he might very
well finance
or help us finance
a forum within which
cypriots both turks and greece can meet
and maybe
give
rejuvenated momentum to the finding of a
permanent resolution of these
differences with a unified
country and adherence to human rights
we're going to take a a break now
further in which uh yes
before we do it might be possible for dr
canfield to add his postscript oh yeah a
footnote on afghanistan
it's not necessarily not necessary
fine
dale
10 minute break
take 10 minutes and please be back in
your own time
thank you mr president
i was sharing the
korean peninsula
session yesterday
and um as i said yesterday it was
a very
productive session in a very
nice atmosphere
and with the
people who had
composed the group with great knowledge
and i was thinking of it
afterwards that
who is carrying the process
which we felt we took part in
yesterday who is carrying that process
with him or with her
and uh i think i was
glad to to notice that we had the
representatives the former
representatives
uh of both
north and south korea
as
in the form of the ambassadors the you
and ambassadors in the room
and
for me i think it's
important to
to have the feeling that
that productive atmos atmosphere and
the
all that what we discussed will be
forward
in in the further process
so
i will now give the floor to
day spencer to go into to report from
what happened during our session
uh you know that dale spencer is a
lawyer and
negotiator who serves as director of the
conflict
resolution program here at the carter
center
and in this role she has collaborated
with the president
jimmy carter between
to develop the inn council
if there's one thing i've learned in
eight years of working for jimmy carter
it's that you need to be brief
so i will
and in fact i'm going to digress from
the pattern that we've established of
going over many of the points that are
in the agenda and the overlays and in
the packets that you have in front of
you and i'm going to assume that you can
read those for yourself maybe have
already done so or certainly will do so
later and what i want to try to capture
for this group in my few minutes
is a little bit of that spirit that mrs
palmer referred to yesterday because as
i observed when i was asked to make this
report the korean conflict has been
going on virtually for my entire life
and it's a bit daunting for me uh to be
called upon to speak about a conflict
that's that's been around for that long
about which i feel so inadequately
prepared uh to address but nonetheless i
have the responsibility so so let me
share with you a few observations about
the meeting yesterday it was exciting it
was exciting to hear representatives of
both north and south korea talk about
this moment in time
to hear them describe such things as the
movement that is now taking place on
that peninsula
to have them say that for the first time
in 40 years and i know i'm telling my
age here
the two sides are both showing the
political interest for peaceful
coexistence and reconciliation
koreans are talking
koreans are taking charge and what is
interesting about how koreans are taking
charge is the fact that previously when
korean talks would be scheduled it was
considered by the old four plus two
formulation that is the superpowers
convening the two koreans in a dialogue
and what the koreans are advocating for
very passionately in our session is that
that notion is sort of the tail wagging
the dog if i may to use an alabamia
expression and and what they think it's
time for is more of a two plus four the
koreans to decide when and where their
talks should be held and for them to
choose whether to include international
participants in those talks and i think
they serve fair warning on those of us
who are in the international community
who have an interest in this issue
that we must tread lightly that we must
tread at their invitation and within
some of the parameters that they'll be
setting uh for us but nonetheless given
that that new formulation of of the two
fl
excuse me two plus four or whatever
formulation the koreans decide to set
for their talks in their peace process
they were excited by a recent movement
that we have all been watching in the
form of the prime ministerial level
talks
the fact that there are now parallel u.n
members on the part of the korean
peninsula
the fact that there is now a signed
reconciliation agreement and that they
are moving toward the uh removal of all
nuclear weapons from the peninsula and
the recent cancellation of joint us
south korean military exercises were all
cited as examples of this progressive uh
movement in the uh peninsula they
pointed out to those of us who were in
the working session that the korean
conflict is unlike many of the other
conflicts that we've been examining in
our in our discourse this week it's not
racist it's not ethnic in nature in some
ways it was largely brought about by
what was intended to be
a temporary division of a nation and
that temporary division has been
maintained over decades of time with
adverse consequences for both halves of
the korean peninsula
they
they talked about their economic
disparities and the problems that this
poses for both sides
pinyong has a concern about being
absorbed uh by the south the south seoul
has a concern that they cannot
absorb pinyong and if there were
development as we have seen uh in
germany for example there's great
concern about how the economic
disparities would be handled by the
parties
i want to point out a mistake the reason
i'm not relying too heavily on our
overlays is because we do have a mistake
in the section on barriers we refer to
the power imbalance in asia due to what
is abbreviated to be world war ii
actually in our discussions yesterday
the concern was raised about the current
power imbalance in asia our interns who
are college students who were
transcribing the notes last night
misperceived the remark that was made by
our rapid tour but but coming back to
the concern that the koreans expressed
yesterday in our very productive
discussion
it was a concern that the real danger
that they face right now is not between
north and south korea as it may have
been in previous years but their
concerns are external in nature they are
concerned about the power imbalances in
asia that exist right now and what those
imbalances hold for the future of their
nations
i think all of them expressed optimism
that that they are working toward
internal transformation
and normalized relations between north
and south korea and in that regard they
advocated a number of actions that some
of us took to be very positive in nature
they suggested for example
mayor young that there would be a
movement toward joint north and south
korean olympic teams uh that there would
be movements toward efforts to take
steps to have reunions of korean
families who have been divided
arbitrarily and have not seen each other
for some time an improvement in
communication between north and south
korea so that so that levels of
suspension suspect and distrust can be
reduced
and a
interesting idea was proposed that
former american veterans of the korean
war uh be invited in large numbers to
visit the peninsula on both sides and
and to reconnect with koreans that they
have known and to see and and have a
reconciliation process
in both north and south korea
uh president carter one last point that
i'll make and and try to end these marks
is that uh they did it extend both north
and south korean representatives
extended an invitation uh to the inn uh
to visit the korean peninsula they
particularly expressed a desire to have
you come they also expressed a desire to
have you lead a high-level delegation of
imminent persons and and and make a
fact-finding mission as it were and
report to the world they're very
concerned that there be improved
relations between our own government
that is the united states government and
the north the democratic people's
republic of korea and that if there
could be such a high level fact-finding
mission they think that this might go a
long way to alleviating some of the
tensions between the united states and
north korea and it might improve the
chances for
this internal cooperation along the
boundaries
thank you
the next presentation
will be on the sudan
and under total
control
of
desmond
thank you very much
in the language of communities
we had full frank
friendly discussions
for most of the time
they did become a little difficult
and i think we want to stress
the fact that those who came
and um
it was a wide spectrum
representative of the sudan
we articulate
intelligent
and spoke to one another
and were able to laugh together
the situation looks murky
and almost intractable
and yet
we were saying
to
them if
it can happen in south africa
that
an africana white
minister of defense
could
be on first
name speaking terms
with someone he
was regarding only a few months before
as a terrorist
and that they could sit down in south
africa
and sign
agreements
then nothing is impossible
we identified
barriers
the country is a large country
it has a population that is polarized
stratified
there is diversity of religion
islam chris christianity
african traditional beliefs
and the whole problem
of
tolerance
it is not
a homogeneous
community
and even within one of the major players
there is tension
the north is not
a monolith
there are divisions there as well
and
because of the nature of
the
conflict
people
have come to mistrust
one another
and
the suspicions
have been exacerbated
everybody
and this is one of the
wonderful things about the meeting and
about the sudanese people
all
wanted
an end to war all wanted peace
and that is what was identified as one
of the strategies the war has caused
wide-scale unacceptable suffering
many many many civilian casualties
and
the strategies
would be suggested by
the nature of the problems
it's the ending
of the war the fighting
the hope that there could be a voluntary
move
out of the south by
government
troops
making it easier for relief
to be administered
and to recognize the reality
it is it is the largest country
in africa
and and therefore a redefinition of its
regions
to
accommodate
all the differences
to
be able to recognize that diversity does
not necessarily make for
division
and separation
and hope that religion could be removed
from
being
and
a political football
and accepting
that relief will be provided
if there are the administrative
structures
to enable that to happen
part of
the hope was that people
would
be allowed a measure of
self-determination
in the different regions because
many were fearful of a
centralized
structure
when
the regions in the periphery tended to
have the thin end of the of the stick
but they they should be provided with a
constitutional model
that made it clear that it was possible
for people to cohere perhaps in one
country as a confederation
that
it would be important to have
a constituent assembly
that would deal with constitutional
issues representative of the peoples and
political parties
that there would be hope that
they could develop a task force
which would
under
international supervision and assistance
manage the process of transition
one of the most hopeful things was that
the
participants from the sudan all almost
unanimously agreed that there was an
important
role for
[Music]
ngos third parties
and that these
could in fact be
an important catalyst
for
beginning the process of reconciliation
by
letting the parties that were hostile to
one another
and
make gestures
that would begin the process of trust
building
and perhaps the one most important item
[Music]
which was banded about
and and seem to have the greatest
possible viability
was
um
the hope that
uh perhaps president carter would be
able
um with other ngos to
convene a round table
conference of all parties
this was a bone of contention um the
composition of those of the participants
but the suggestion was that um if such a
a
a round table or should we say when such
a round table conference
were to take place one of the first
steps would be
for
um
the inn
to
have a catalog of the points of
agreement between the different
parties because they do have
a very substantial
consensus
and that that would be an important
psychological
step forward
the spla and the government
were willing to be meeting
but
possibly
once that meeting um
between the two
happened
elections might be held
and then a
constituent assembly or constitutional
conference held
the possibility of a unilateral
ceasefire
by the spla
for
a specific period of time
under international supervision this
would again be part of the attempt at um
at indicating that it is possible to
move towards a stable peace
and that
in response to
the
declaration of a ceasefire by the splas
plm
the government would then
abrogate the emergency laws
lifting them
under
international supervision
releasing political prisoners
enabling um
humanitarian relief
um to happen allowing freedom of
movement
freedom of
discussion freedom of speech
and assembly of the citizens
there was a commitment on most of those
participating from the sudan
to
the process of democratization of the
sudan
because that was the cry
from the heart of all of them
the violation of human rights and that
was happening in their country
and the fact that
people were held in detention without
trial
mr president i
i i said if it could happen in south
africa
[Music]
it surely can happen
in
any other part of the world where we may
have what appear to be intractable
problems
people
in in in south africa
it's obvious that when you hear even an
intractable
issue
discussed
in this forum and with the um
leadership of
of uh leaders like desmond tutu that
the intractability seems to fade away
and you begin to look at the
practicality
of steps that might lead to peace and
you see the broad
area of agreement that already exists
and the relative insignificance of the
disagreements
and the tremendous benefits that come to
people who are suffering
and i think the sudanese
issue
is one in which we have been deeply
involved and i hope that we will
continue in the future to
support
rosa and i and spencers
spent six days
negotiating between the two sides in
nairobi
and it was obvious to us then
that the possibility for peace is
genuine and real and i hope that this
conference will stimulate a renewed
commitment on the part of the government
and the opposition
uh forces to
renew those efforts and
if it's
advisable to bring
scholars and experts here not to
negotiate but to
define more clearly the issues and
expand on what was done very briefly
yesterday afternoon and i think we might
very well
find that to be possible the next
presentation will be on on liberia
and uh should i recognize you directly
this time dr spencer bill spencer who's
been you've spent a lot of 1991
in liberia and then yamasucro which is
her second home now
we were fortunate yesterday in the
liberia section
for two reasons
at least
one we were fortunate because
the peace process that was launched by
the economic community of west african
states some
time ago
has reached a certain juncture that
liberians can now conceive of themselves
on the path to peace through the conduct
of democratic elections
we were extremely fortunate in that in
our session
we had all five members of the newly
constituted liberians elections
commission and the significance of this
fact is that they come from both sides
of the current political divide within
liberia and they came to that session i
thought in a spirit of great harmony in
a positive spirit in which they were
earnestly seeking to work with those of
us who were privileged to be part of
their discussions to find ways in which
their country could be transformed from
the ravages of war which they have known
since christmas eve of 1989
toward peace through democracy
and in our discussions uh we talked
about some of the barriers some of the
things that are preventing them from
getting on with it that is to say
holding those elections
and and one of the significant barriers
is the fact that right now in liberia
there are two entities that each claim
to be the government
of liberia there is one that is based
principally in monrovia
which is the interim government of
national unity which was chosen by
an all liberian conference
this is the government that is led by dr
amos sawyer then there is a second
government that is seated at barnga that
is the national patriotic reconstruction
assembly government that is led by
charles taylor and each of these
gentlemen um have some claim to make
that he is the rightful leader of
liberia and so that alone presents
significant barriers uh to the liberian
people in terms of how one orchestrates
an election in a country that is divided
under those circumstances it's further
complicated by the fact that ninety
percent of the country
is controlled by the national patriotic
front of liberia
and and until just this week the front
was able to control most of the roads
now we learned in our session that two
of the major arteries leading into
monrovia have just been open and so
there is a a decrease in tension at
least brought about by the opening of
those roads uh just this week but
nonetheless there exists currently a
significant security problem because uh
there are heavily armed
members of the national patriotic front
in ninety percent of the country there
are also two other armed groups uh in
the greater monrovia area and there is a
need to move all of these armed
previously warring parties toward a
process of encampment and disarmament so
that elections process
can begin and democratic elections can
be held
all of the liberians
recognize the significant barrier of
reconciliation if you can imagine a
civil war in a country of two and a half
million in which virtually half of the
country has been uprooted by the
fighting
about ten thousand people approximately
have been killed but half of the country
has either fled or been internally
displaced in just the past two years so
there is a great deal of work that needs
to be done in terms of reconciliation
but i think the fundamental barrier that
the liberians identified for us
yesterday afternoon
was a problem that liberia has known
only too well in the past and that is a
a critical lack of resources
these members of the elections
commission came here with such hope and
they come at such a moment in time with
an opportunity for liberia that has not
previously been present in this conflict
and they also came to us with empty
pockets and they said in our session
that they are here for training they're
in the united states because they want
to learn how to organize democratic
elections they've come to the carter
center earlier this week for that
purpose they're going on to washington
our government has brought them here at
some expense in order to train them but
when they go back to liberia they do not
even have the money to open an elections
office and so there was a feeling of
frustration at least on my part and i
suspect on the part of many other people
in our session
that but for money
we would begin to see almost immediately
some tangible progress in the liberian
conflict i'll come back to that in a
moment
we identified some key strategies in in
resolving this this problem in liberia
and they included the obvious
disarmament and encampment and
demobilization of all of the warring
parties
uh they included the institution of
reconciliation processes
and obviously the search for resources
in order to permit them to have
democratic elections process in their
country
we also identified specific action steps
that liberians and others could take in
order to further this process including
uh continued cooperation between ecowas
and the warring parties and that is
cooperation in the sense of encamping
and disarming all of the warring parties
echoes is the economic community of west
african states again it is the body that
has been principally responsible for the
peace process and i'm pleased to report
that abbas bundu the uh secretary
general or executive secretary abbott i
hope i have your title right uh of
echoes was with us in our discussions
yesterday
um
they
they came to a conclusion that there is
a need to issue an appeal
to the international community for
assistance and i'll come back to that
point in just a moment
members of our own government were
present that is to say the united states
government representatives were present
and they encouraged the elections
commission to develop a budget for the
elections process and they agreed to
work with them next week in washington
so that this budget would be specific
and detailed enough in order to
further the uh funding process
a particularly thoughtful observer in
our session said that there was a need
for
a number of joint commissions
of liberians on both sides of the
current political divide so that they
began to work together in harmony on
commonly shared problems and she
identified several commissions that
could be uh formed very quickly but a
recognition of the need that there has
to be a joint approach to the solving of
liberia's problems in general
if you uh bill if you would put up the
section on resources in our our liberia
report you have it in front of you in
the document that was in your chair this
morning
these resources i i would submit are are
more of a wish list
than a than a list of currently existing
resources these are kinds of resources
that are needed in liberia and they have
some of them in measured quantities they
don't have nearly enough of any of them
and and certainly with respect to the
number one item on the list support for
the interim elections commission as i
said before they have virtually nothing
and and it is because
that
time for liberia
is of the essence
there was an agreement reached in
yamasucra in
late november
that this next 60-day period would be
the period in which all the warring
parties would be encamped and disarmed
and the opening of those roads this week
marks a
significant stride along that path and
we've started a momentum now within
liberia and time is of the essence in
order to continue along that path
so our
group our working session uh requested
that this entire
organization all of you gathered here
today
urge
that the governments of the united
states
the united nations the organization of
african unity the economic community of
west african states the european
economic community and all donor nations
and organizations should immediately
provide all possible financial and
technical assistance to the
regional peace effort in liberia
the repatriation of refugees and the
conduct of free and fair elections and
take all possible steps to underwrite
with technical and financial assistance
the demobilization and reabsorption of
previously armed forces in liberia
one final footnote to our discussions
and it's something that president carter
has commented on earlier the
international negotiation network has
already made a commitment uh to work
with the liberian people and with the
national democratic institute in
washington to help organize these
elections but we too are constrained by
the same lack of resources that the
liberian people feel and that again is
the need for money thank you
we have two remaining presentations to
be made one on the psychological
dimensions of conflict and the other one
is sustaining the piece how to follow up
a peaceful resolution with
elements that might make that piece
permanent
the first psychological dimension of
conflict will be by
dr valmik volker
the presenters of this program under
the chairmanship of elizabeth palmer
where
harold saunders joseph montville and
myself
we have been working together for some
years so this presentation is from all
three of us
i believe that psychology is always
using diplomacy and international
relationships
to attain
psychological advantages
as well as for propaganda purposes like
even the shape of a negotiating table i
understand sometimes becomes a problem
and i heard the story that they wanted
to give some kind of medication to fidel
castro so that his beard would fall off
and the idea was that he would appear
less manly so his followers would not
follow him
well
that is also psychology
but however seriously speaking
what we try to offer here
where
we try to offer services of
in-depth psychology that works towards
understanding obligatory
large group processes like ethnic issues
ethnic relationships
and healing of conflicts
the presence of in-depth psychology on
this program
is
an acknowledgement that we have
scientific knowledge about human
behavior to be applied to political
analysis
and i
like myself
diplomats historians political
scientists need to work together i mean
we just don't want to make these ideas
just from clear blue sky we have to
invest time energy and years
any real understanding of international
relationships conflicts and wars
requires
an analysis of irrational
as well as rational forces for example
many regions
of um
in both of
the the developed and developing world
is then to lose economically
by gaining autonomy
by perpetuating military competition or
by even glorifying a particular leader
rationally they may know these things
yet they choose to
fight for independence must be some kind
of psychological need for it
or they choose to continue to compete to
be the original power
even they're going to lose economically
or they even choose to continue to
support a dictator
some indulge in large-scale
daredevil attacks that result in
thousands of deaths
which is clearly irrational
the emotional investment in one's
individual in-group identity evolves
into a type of power
that may be
as effective
as any other weapon
and that allows the group to accept and
tolerate
shared
what we call masochism that is to say
extreme suffering
peculiarly become accepted by a group
and shared sadism extreme ability to
torture other human beings can be
accepted by the group
this power cannot be measured by
rational
and physical means
therefore
those of us the psychoanalysts who
decided to get away
from behind the couch and really go to
the field
and work with people like harold sanders
for years
we may have something to offer about
understanding the human nature
we in the meeting we basically
focused on
the meaning of ethnicity
and
as i don't need to tell you this is
going to be at this ethnic issue is
going to be
around for some time to come
and we focus on other large group
processes
and we offered
some observations
some rituals
how ethnic groups relate to each other
they relate to each other on a spectrum
from normal
playful rituals to malignant ones
they they
they ethnicity is not
a pathological phenomenon we human
beings evolved in groups
and therefore the politicians and
diplomats and other people
need not see ethnicity as pathological
if they do they're going to give
regressive responses they're going to go
and smash it because it is bad
however if you think of ethnicity
something normal which may become
exaggerated
then we may devise more humane responses
these rituals they were
they they ethnic groups try to be not
the same because they want to keep their
identity
they compete
uh we gave examples
of relationship between arabs and
israelis cpr turks and cypriot greeks
competition between them and i would
like to join my
countrymen
mr stavrou
in thanking ambassador yang for inviting
the cypriot athletes to come to atlanta
i hope that some ways can be found so
the turkish secret athletes can come too
so both sides human rights can be
exercised
um
furthermore
we talked about
strategies
and i'll give you only one because i
want to finish
as the ritual between the two groups
become more malignant
there are signs there are red flags or
yellow flags for example
dehumanization is necessary before we
make much destruction
before before
the you kill other people
you have to make them
dehumanize you have to make iraqis
cockroaches
before you can bomb them
or you can make the other
snakes or monsters
and
there are expressions of such
rituals in the press for example
in the
in the
speeches of
leaders and one of the strategies that
was suggested by my colleague joe
montville and ambassador akhtan
was that maybe inn can evolve
a group to measure dehumanization and
the suggestion was that if this was done
in yugoslavia
we might have some
measures to prevent the bloodshed
at the very end we talked about the
application of psychological insights
in track to diplomacy in confidence
building measures
and
i'm going to stop now but they were very
good discussions from the floor we could
have had another hour or two
to listen to colleagues and some of
these recommendations you can see
on the screen
the next session will be on sustaining
the peace
we've had
very heartfelt discussions about
defaulting
on
post-peace
obligations
that have
precipitated
a loss
of achievements that have been so
laboriously
realized and we're going to call on dr
harold saunders
to give that presentation
thank you mr president it gives me a
very warm feeling to be engaged with you
once again in the
effort to immunity and
even resolve conflict this time on an
even more global scale than when we
worked together before so it's a
pleasure to be back with you and mrs
carter
the president has already on several
occasions during our meetings introduced
the subject and underscored forcefully
its importance
in our group yesterday morning we were
privileged to have president aristide
say
something about the process after his
election
and before his
exile from haiti
president carter also spoke forcefully
about the
problem of the new leadership in
ethiopia and its lack of resources to
carry through
the commitment to a democratization of
that country
i think we've also seen
references on the screen here during the
presentation
this morning on other conflicts of how
this subject that is the
what happens
after a peace agreement is reached after
an election is held
what happens
to sustain the gains made in those steps
we focused
briefly on
the question of why peace agreements
fall apart
and you have seen several analyses here
of why that has happened in certain
circumstances but then we moved on
principally to the subject of what can
be done to sustain the peace
once it is arrived at
now before because of the complexity of
this problem and indeed we are talking
about
social and political processes that
cross the entire spectrum
of a group's experience
because of the complexity of that
subject
there was a felt need expressed by a
number
of commentators in our group
for a conceptual framework large enough
to encompass the full range of possible
responses to the many dimensions
of this problem
such a framework
we concluded is essential
if leaders are to rise above a tendency
to see
the solution to this problem in terms of
single instruments or single processes
for instance there is a tendency to say
if we can just have
a democratic election
that will deal with the problem if we
can just bring people to negotiate that
will deal with the problem or even more
broadly if we can engage in a process of
democratization
that or economic development that will
resolve the problem the answer is all of
the above are essential parts in
differing circumstances of dealing with
this problem so one needs a conceptual
framework
large enough
to permit those involved
to get their minds around the totality
of the problem
and to bring resources
and instruments to bear in mutually
reinforcing ways so that one can address
the breadth of the problem
the key to the development of such a
conceptual framework
is to think of a prolonged
continuous political
process as one speaker put it
we are always
in a transition between transitions
the phrase peace process was used by our
chairman general obasanjo right at the
opening of our session
in referring to the conceptual framework
which is necessary
now as we all know or at least as
i think
the phrase peace process was coined by
those of us who
became intimately involved in the
arab-israeli peace process right after
the 1973
war
we coined that phrase because we
realized very quickly that we were just
not just mediating
to be sure the united states government
twice under president carter
mediated five arab-israeli agreements in
the years between 1974 and the egyptian
israeli peace treaty of 1979
but as we look back on that
experience i would say that until the
political leaders like president sadat
president carter
acted to change the political
environment the mediators didn't have a
chance change is not initiated in the
negotiating room it is
initiated in the political environment
and it's the political leaders who use
political instruments there to change
relationships so that negotiations
become possible or i might even submit
so that some problems can be resolved
without negotiation even perhaps without
elections but elections are
an excellent example of a political step
to move toward resolution of conflict
and president carter himself has pointed
out that it's an instrument that can use
be used when the problem is too tough to
negotiate
so
in the arab-israeli peace process we
learned this lesson
of a
series of specific instruments like
elections and negotiations used in the
context of a broader political process
now in our meeting
one member of the group
simply spoke of three stages a
preparatory stage
a stage of reaching agreement on ending
the conflict and taking certain measures
to move beyond it and then a period of
implementing the agreement it's a fairly
simple statement of a process
another member focused on a process in
which democratization
is the centerpiece and he spoke of four
stages
one
is negotiating the rules of the game in
a pre-election period
a second is the election itself a third
is
a period of democratic transition
in which those who
lose are given reason
to believe that they still have a stake
in the ongoing process
and finally there is a period of
prolonged uh democratic consolidation
in which there's a gradual broadening
and deepening of the civil society
now it doesn't make much difference
whether we talk about three stages four
stages five stages my only point here is
that we believed it worthy of attention
to
develop and refine our thinking about
the stages of the process what is
important to us at this point
is not the details
but recognizing the need to think in
terms of a process
this is important
because it recognizes that we are not
talking about a single instrument
negotiation or elections it's important
to recognize that we're not that we are
talking about a protracted process that
cuts across the entire spectrum of human
experience and it's important to
recognize that we want a framework large
enough to encompass a broad range of
possible
activities
and particularly a broad range of
resources that can be brought to bear on
these problems
and we concluded that a first
practical task is simply to cause
leaders to recognize this process
to recognize that
making and sustaining the peace is not
simply a matter of a few discrete acts
but a complex ongoing process that
requires perseverance hanging in there
over a prolonged period of time it's a
different way of thinking
from the traditional view of a linear
series of actions and responses
it is not linear it is a continuous
political process working at many levels
using many resources at the same time
indeed it's a different way of living
and i would venture to say that peace is
never made it's always in the making and
unless we learn to live in the midst of
that process continuously until the day
we pass from this earth we will not
sustain the peace it requires a
different way of thinking about how our
world works and that's why i say the
first practical task here is to sell
to the leaders of the world the concept
of this process of peace making
now
if we think of a peas process as working
through a variety of stages over time
and then recycling and picking up some
of the earlier stages to go on we also
need to think of
the work that needs to be done at the
same time on several different tracks
and it was here
that the four papers prepared for
our deliberations came into play and i
might say they were for outstanding
papers
the first was a paper and i will not go
into detail about these i will simply
mention them and
some of the details will be
on the screen here but there is no
question that we need to think about the
election process
and all of the things that go into that
not just the act of monitoring elections
but as president carter has several
times pointed out the need to train
people to run an electoral system
and to train
people or to educate people to use the
press widely
one of the uh in presenters in our group
said mr president that
it may very well be that an important
part of election monitoring
should be
assurance of access to
by all parties in the election to
television and i know you confronted
that in nicaragua but he would put that
simply
on the agenda he said a
a single channel television country
is just as despotic as a single party
political system and until you have
plural parties and plural television
channels uh you do not have the
potential for a fair and open electoral
system
a
second
track on which we need to
work is with the media we had an
impassioned and brilliant presentation
about the the way in which media
resources can be used as power
in this changing world
it was a reprise on the discussion the
day before
about the permeability of national
sovereignties
one example only was the
uh the comment that
a few television cameras a few
small
television recorders that happened to be
available to a particular organization
in a warehouse in moscow and could be
taken into the russian white house in
the days of the august coup
were responsible for
the world's beginning no being able to
observe
from the outside what was going on
inside the russian white house during
those days the statement was made
that the people who supplied those four
or five
television instruments
may have demonstrated the use of more
power than all the armies of nato
because they could intervene in the
political process effectively and the
armies of nato could do nothing but
stand by and be prohibited from
intervention in any meaningful way well
this is just one thought that
demonstrates the resource that the media
offer
in bringing parties together
i happen to be
a participant in kicking off a
non-official dialogue between indians
and pakistanis through a television
network from washington to new delhi to
islamabad
technology today can
a produce of resources available in the
resolution of conflict
a third track on which we must work is
the military track
a
first-rate paper prepared on this by a
group of
people with pentagon and state
department experience
really laid out for us in considerable
and thoughtful detail
the elements in the process which are
related to the military
and the the importance of this track was
brought home by the simple statement
that oftentimes in the kinds of conflict
situations we're dealing with
we happen to be dealing with a
government that was put and kept in
power by the military
or we are dealing with an insurgent
movement seeking to put itself in power
by use of the military so you're dealing
with political processes where the
military
is uh central
and the stages or the
areas of activity mentioned here on the
board
simply recognize the importance of a
process in which one moves a military
establishment
from a central role in supporting a
dictatorial system
out of the center of the political stage
and then move it gradually through
various processes of
grouping in encampments training
former soldiers to play a role in the
civilian economy restructuring
uh new
security forces for a new political
system and so on again
thinking about this as in terms of the
process involved helps us to think in an
orderly way about the stages one needs
to go through the instruments one needs
to use and the problems one needs to
identify at various stages in the
process
and one needs to put what goes on on the
military track alongside what may be
happening on the electoral track because
it may very well be that an agreement to
hold elections can be reinforced by
certain agreement on another track that
is an agreement to begin the
demobilization of military or
redeployment or something of that kind
so while we work on different tracks
through this process it's important to
keep them all in mind
at the same time so as to play back and
forth across these
tracks
there was a paper on the
necessity to broaden
civic cultures
as an underpinning for a in a plural and
a growing pluralistic society to create
those centers of power and influence in
the society which can balance each other
off in an electoral system
i would suggest that perhaps we
suffered a an error of omission in not
having two other papers but i say this
simply because i want to add two other
areas of study perhaps to thinking about
this field we certainly should have had
a paper
on the uh role of economic development i
don't mean long-term strategies of
economic development but the beginnings
of economic development president carter
has pointed out how the lack of
resources just to get some things
started a judicial system in ethiopia or
what have you uh found her because of
the lack of resources and many of the
development organizations say oh that's
not sustainable that's not long term at
but we need to focus and the ngos may be
the best equipped to do this on the
short term involvement in the beginnings
of a process which later on the world
bank or somebody else can call
sustainable so that subject needs to be
added to the agenda and i'd say there's
a sixth that came up in
uh briefly in our discussions and was
mentioned in some of the reports this
morning
and i would i would say that one needs
to think about the religious or
spiritual dimensions of
that track
where reconciliation can come about and
there's work that's going on among some
people in this room to identify uh how
the great religions
in those parts of them that focus on
reconciliation can play a role in this
kind of process now just to conclude
i want to say that
if we are to think in terms of a peace
process working simultaneously on these
many tracks
then it will be apparent
that
these the work
in each track will be spread through
several stages
one must think in terms of those stages
and think of terms of those tracks and
stages in relationship to each other
now the purpose in constructing a
framework like this
is to persuade policymakers to take a
comprehensive view
of the peace process to give them a
sense of strategy
to repeat it must be one objective
simply to sell policy makers to think in
this way to think comprehensively rather
than to focus simplistically on what any
one instrument
now
now i would like to present to the
audience
would you all talking about on the right
please
be quiet
now i'd like to introduce to the
audience someone whom you've all gotten
to know
i'm sure with great appreciation favor
during the last two days someone who's
been my friend for years
when we first had the vision
of what inn might do in the early part
of 1987
this distinguished leader came here to
give us sound advice
he is from what's presently known as
guyana
he served in top positions in that
government he served three uh terms
as uh secretary general of the
commonwealth organization which might be
the most difficult secretary generalship
of all
and he has been involved in some of the
most notable
worldwide assessments
of peace and development and human
issues including environment and poverty
that the world has seen the bryant
commission the palmer commission the
bruntman commission
he played a major role in that now he
serves on a really broad foundation and
it's my great pleasure to present to you
my friend sonny ron falls
[Applause]
president carter
my colleagues on the
council of the iron n
i am
i'm here as a kind of double bill
filling
first of all fill in while you wait for
the big screen
but secondly
and in a very real way i stand here
in the place of
javier perez de queira
who as we heard at the beginning
uh sadly could not be with us though he
so
very much wanted to be
he is as you know the just retired
secretary general of the united nations
and i want to start by adding my tribute
for his service to our world community
and i should like to begin this address
with recalling our own last meeting
my meeting with him
for its relevance to our work here this
week
in inaugurating the
international negotiating network
it was really
almost a year ago nine months ago in
april
1991
and the world of course had already
changed
in significant ways
we were not to know
how much more change
actually lay ahead
and i was calling on the secretary
general with the
former german chancellor willie brandt
to give him the first copy of what we
call the stockholm initiative
on global security and governance
entitled more simply
common responsibility
it was a statement i think some of you
have seen
it is one that was endorsed by several
heads and former heads of government
by current and former
foreign and finance ministers and by
very many eminent internationalists the
world over
some of us on the inn council
our co-chairman president carter and
edward shernatzi in particular
were among them
now for me
that visit to the 30th floor in april
1991 was a kind of re-run
because 12 years before
willie brandt who was already then a
veteran world statesman
had called on the then u.n secretary
general to present the report
of the independent commission on
international development issues
a commission he had
established and chaired
at the urging of
bob mcnamara who was then the president
of the world bank
and i was with willie brandt as a member
of the commission
on that occasion
the branch report had been a challenging
document
calling for the urgent for urgent
international action
to avert economic decline in much of the
developing world and that was a message
that was being conveyed at the very
start of the 1980s
it was called
perhaps rather starkly
north south
a challenge of survival
and it was followed a year later
from the same commission by another
smaller report called common crisis
updating that first one
and warning that a debt crisis
was in the making that would threaten
economic disaster
for much of the developing world and
indeed for the world economy as a whole
i think it's fair to say that many
people were moved
by those reports
moved to concern
and a few were moved to action
but by and large western governments
really didn't want to hear
monetarism market forces
something of a culture of greed
were ascended
the third world's call for a new
economic order
had been rather decisively rejected
in the 70s
and the north-south dialogue had been
effectively closed
they did not want to hear brett
that was in the beginning
of the 1980s
three years later it was really no
different
they did not want them to listen
to olaf palmer
all of palmer who's with elizabeth
is with us today as a member
of the inn council
they did not want to listen to olaf when
his own
commission
on international security issues
published its report
common security
a report that called for a major push on
disarmament
and for new approaches to collective
security
through strengthened peacekeeping
arrangements
centered on the united nations
in fact
all of palmer's commission had called
for precisely the kind
of preventive peacekeeping
in advance of conflict
that
as i shall try to illustrate later would
more probably have tripped saddam
hussein
on his first aggressive moves
against kuwait
the question then is really this
on that visit
to the secretary general last year
was i any more
certain
that the world in 1991
was ready to follow the path we were
urging
on common responsibility
than it had been in the 1980s
and the truth is that i
was not more
certain
and yet
something
was different
and still is
we had lived through the 1980s
and entered
the 90s
with a record that
everyone would recognize
as being tangled
and disquieting
rich countries
and rich people in all countries
have grown
richer and the poor
everywhere
including the poor in rich countries
have grown poorer
communism has collapsed in
economic and political ruin
and the cold war
has ended
and has ended with some gains for
nuclear disarmament
but does the post-war era closes
the adjustment from century plans to
market economies
in eastern europe
is pointing up a crisis of uneven
development in that part of the world
and as we have repeated so many times
here this week
new freedoms
are unleashing
new
tribal tensions ethnic
linguistic
sometimes religious
and the gulf crisis
despite the
spirit of triumphalism that persists a
year later in some quarters
that crisis had been anything but a
glorious experience for the world
and rather especially for the united
nations
that was neither able to avert the
crisis
nor to resolve it
in a peaceful manner
the cold war
is over
so is the post-war era
the challenge for us i suggest
is to ensure that the era that succeeds
it
is not an era of dominion
but one of democracy in our global state
at the moment
despite all the emphasis
and the correct emphasis
on democracy within nations
there is not much sign of democratic
instincts
prevailing among
the power brokers of the world
more and more
the g7
looks and all too often acts
like a self-appointed prize idiot
we surely have to convince these leaders
of major western democracies
that the democratic ideal
has a longer reach
than national frontiers
democracy at the national level
but authoritarianism in the global
homeland
are really contradictions and terms
espousing the former is right
making it a masquerade
for sustaining the latter
is massively wrong
i fear that one of the most dangerous
of our current realities
is that in the 1990s
the democracies of the west
have learned that there are large
political
gains
in military and ideological triumphs
and serious dangers arise from this
the west may easily assume
that its ideological political
and economic victories
over its cold war adversaries
now somehow give it the right
to police the entire world
that temptation
will be a very
heady one
and there will be many supremacists
in many countries
to urge the democracies on
but the real strength of democracy
lies in its values
and lies in societies staying true to
those values
and i am certain that any attempt to
embark on a new kind of imperialism
would present not only massive
contradictions
but massive resistance
from within western societies themselves
and i'm sure that that resistance can be
expected to be vigorous
but what we do need to
be careful about
is whether an arrogation of authority by
some governments
can be entirely ruled out
notwithstanding
that resistance from within them
and we do need to ask as well
whether if that were to happen
we can rely on resistance
from the weakened societies of the
developing world
can we rely
on ourselves
we do need a new order
but the newness really has to start
within ourselves
not new
wine skins
for wine that is really centuries old
if the new world order looks
much like an old order with a new name
we would need to recall that
pax britannica when it held sway
was really a very highly selective piece
the crimea the
chinese opium wars the boer war
were all allowable
during that period of peace they were
allowable because they were winnable
winnable by the custodian of peace
and the prevailing mood was not really
the peace of the world
it was the glory
of an ordered world
one ordered by the prevailing
superpower
the answer i would suggest to you is
inescapable
the reality of the human neighborhood
today requires us urgently
to seek a compact
on establishing a strengthened system of
global management
the old order
is passing
and a new order
must be established
either we allow that new order to be
determined by the fortunes of power
or we help to shape it
in a very conscious way
and help to make it
responsive to contemporary human needs
and that challenge i believe has been
underlined
by so much of our consultations here
this
week what is clear
is that we must repose
maximum faith
in the united nations system
but in a system
strengthened
and
streamlined and adjusted
to the newness of the end years of this
century and the first years of the next
a system succeeding the post-war
arrangements that were ushered in in
1945
at san francisco
and yet the remarkable thing
is not how out of date is the charter
agreed in 1945
but how very relevant it remains
some change of course is necessary
but it is not dismantling and
redesigning that are required
but some new approaches
to partitioning
more of an
open plan
that allows space
for all people and for all issues
issues that have now become so
increasingly
interrelated and which allows and
enables the united nations
truly to become the guardian
of peace and security
in their true meaning
it is very much in that context that we
have been meeting here
reflecting
on the changes of the 1990s
looking ahead to a new era
of common responsibility
in doing so i believe we have been
conscious
that if we are to establish structures
and programs
of international peace and security
we have to lay the foundations
in ethics
although still very largely
on trodden
that is in fact the path we have been
trying to chart
somewhat haphazardly
really for most of this century
certainly the 1920s
were years in which we began to grope
for a working internationalism first
through the league of nations and later
after its failure and the disaster that
followed through the united nations
that our efforts have been haphazard
is testimony to human frailty
in sustaining enlightened change
once the crisis that inspires it
seems to recede
it is easily disparaged
as utopian thinking
more recently
as the vision thing
but it was the shared vision of men like
roosevelt and churchill
for example practical political
men of the world
imbued with strong nationalist sentiment
it was their vision
that led to the united nations
the vision of course that roosevelt did
not live to put into words himself
but left truman to convey
the founding conference at san francisco
words that are still in our ears
we still have the choice at truman
between the alternatives
the continuation of international chaos
or the establishment of a world
organization
for the enforcement of peace
for the enforcement
of peace
they were of course correct in 1945
we could not have developed civilized
national societies
unless we had put in place a collective
security system
under which the whole society
accepted the responsibility
for securing the safety of every person
and the security of every person's
property
in most countries that is the basis
on which people are persuaded that they
do not have to carry a gun
or sleep with a gun under their pillow
we have law enforcement agencies to
protect us and to deter bullies and
burglars
in our world society we call them
aggressors
but we have not civilized
our world society
by accepting
a truly collective responsibility to
deter them
the result
is what we have
seen and talked about so much this week
national armies
and weapons
and a military culture
which rests on the fashion which often
passes for patriotism
of each country bearing arms
and of course tanks and warships and
bombs and missiles and standing armies
or relying on the arms of allies
whose interests are seldom noble or
altruistic
we really cannot stop the resulting
militarization
which in poor countries of course is
obscene expenditure
in the face of human need
unless we develop global law enforcement
arrangements
backed and in a sense symbolized
by a global emergency system
if we had had that system in place
as the palmer commission had
specifically recommended nearly a decade
ago
kuwait could have dialed the un
secretary general for help in those two
weeks when iraq was threatening
aggression
and an international fact-finding
mission and international military
observers could have been in kuwait in
24
hours no massive movement of troops
no torturous security council debates
and resolutions
swift international preventive action
a trip
for would-be aggression
saddam hussein
might have moved nonetheless
burglars in our national societies
do still venture
but he would have tripped
and the likelihood is he may not have
chanced it at all
without either the ethic
of collective security
as part of our internationalism
or the rudiments of a law enforcement
system in our global society we really
virtually leave it to the strong
to restrain themselves
and of course as we know from time to
time
they do not
in the era ahead therefore
all countries need to be zealous
and to be energetic
in truly restoring the united nations to
a place of primacy
in the enforcement of peace
interventionism
a word as i've said already that i would
like to see banished along with its
practice
interventionism
must be only on the basis of a regime
through which the peace and security of
the world
is in the keeping of no one state
but reflects directly and genuinely
the authority
of our entire world society
in the absence of collective authority
and control
by the united nations
of any act of peace enforcement
the aftermath is not the beginning of a
new
enlightened
internationalist order
but the ascendancy of militarism
in our human society
but i think we have been
mindful here
as well
of another aspect
of this new era
and another feature
of security
tacitus a long time ago
reflected that with war
we make a solitude
which we then call peace
but that is not the only kind of
solitude that we tend to make on earth
or the only one that is relevant to
peace
what about the
deepening silence
of the world's millions overborn by
poverty
people for whom
life is survival
really only until tomorrow always
just tomorrow
millions who simply
pass away from want
without ever really knowing
the reason why
one thousand million
of the world's absolute poor
who today
at the height of what many would
describe as human prosperity
who today remain trapped in a vicious
cycle of deprivation
are those people
at peace
surviving
on the very edge of life
do we even dare
to speak of peace in our time
while they endure
the ravages of poverty's aggression
against their basic humanity
when we talk
of preserving peace
what is it that we preserve
for
them in all too many
of the conflicts
that we have explored this week
the poor
the vulnerable
often
women and children
have been the front-line victims
why
we recognize that the national society
cannot be at peace
if power and privilege and prosperity
are the prerogative of only a few with
deprivation degradation and despair the
lot of many
if that is so at the national level
how can our world society be at peace
when such disparities prevail within it
such yawning disparities
between the few who prosper and the
great majority trapped in poverty
and you know it really is the few who
prosper
today the industrialized countries of
east and west
account for a quarter of the world's
population
just 25
but together they consume
around 80 percent
of the world's commercial commercial
energy
about 80 percent
of the world's metals but 85
of its paper with all that implies in
relation to the world's forests
and over half
of the fat intake
of foods
and i could go on with a much longer
list
is it any wonder
that poor and hungry people that other
75 percent
eat next year's seedborn
just to stay alive
that they over exploit thin soils they
overgraze fragile grasslands
that they cut down disappearing forest
stocks for firewood
for several
billion people in the paddy fields of
asia or in the scorched grasslands of
africa
or near in this hemisphere in the urban
slums of latin america
whose life is one of degradation and
hopelessness
in the midst of plenty
the moral dimension of their insecurity
is as palpable as the insecurity itself
we have come to
act now
and to adopt attitudes and institutions
which must bear
on these perceptions
as we pass
from a world of separate worlds
to one of
an inseparable humanity
we have to build a major bridge
in our mind
and i believe it would help
if we took on the agenda of peace and
security
issues now inescapably linked to the
peace of the world
and the security of its people
as we come to the
end of this
consultation
i want to ask you to
and invite you
to reflect on
all that we have shared together
and all that it implies
to reflect how momentous
is this time in our time
but how fragile are the blooms of peace
and the prosperity as well
to ponder the state of our human
neighborhood
to recognize
that while the
weak grow weaker the strong
grow stronger
to recall that amidst the great gains
for democracy
in national societies our world society
gets less democratic
but i invite you above all to share the
conviction
which i think this week's consultation
has confirmed for me and i hope for you
namely that we can rise to the great
moral challenges that confront us
that there is a spirit of human
solidarity
stirring in the world
that many are ready to show by their
example that they care about their
neighbor
and recognize that their neighbor now is
everyone on earth
this time is a specially
propitious one
for the resolution of conflicts
some of which developed some of which
were sustained
by the environment of the cold war
as that environment has gone
so go
some of the barriers to progress
there is in many areas of conflict
a tide that is favorable to solution
it is a time of hope i believe
for those who work for peace
in all these areas in all these ways
guided by
all these instincts the inn
offers its help
to augment the institutional efforts of
the united nations
to help serve the high purpose
of easing conflict and tension through
good offices and dialogue
through working at negotiation
at the rock face of potential conflict
pursuing no interest
no national or sectoral
or any other kind of interest
other than that of conflict resolution
and the enlargement of peace and
security
in the full meaning of those concepts
for all the world's people
we all i am sure you would agree with me
president carter and the carter center
a very large debt of gratitude
in developing this facility
for making the world of the 1990s end of
the 21st century
more worthy
of our own high opinion of our
civilization
it is a facility we must use
to achieve that purpose thank you
some of the
participants even
one at least one of the council members
has to leave to catch a plane
so we'll go ahead and uh
if the members of the press
if the members of the press who have a
question would just stand i will
recognize you in each case
give your name and the
medium that you represent and address
your questions preferably to the other
members of the council i'll ask answer a
few questions by default
who would like to yes
please thanks very much
[Music]
you've departed by not telling me who
you are
fine
yes the question was what have we done
in the last two or three days
that's a hard question to answer briefly
but i i think that everyone would agree
that we've had an exhilarating and
perhaps unprecedented opportunity
to analyze the the global affliction
of multiple wars
some quite fresh in their birth just the
last few months others having been
excellent for 40 years or more
and what we've tried to do here is to
analyze first of all the causes of war
ethnic problems geographical disputes
and so forth that have
been made better known to us and which
we might join in
assuaging before they break into
violence in the future we've discussed
such things as inherent poverty the lack
of the industrialized nations to take an
interest
in the stricken
unfortunate people of the world we've
talked about environmental degradation
and so forth as a cause secondly we've
discussed some of the ongoing peace
initiatives some taken by the united
nations some taken by others
this has been important because two
particular examples the united nations
has been involved for many many years uh
one obviously is cyprus and the other
one is korea
more recently of course uh in campo
chair the u.n has played a major role
we want the international agencies and
individual nations with all their great
resources to play the primary role in
addressing these conflicts but we also
feel that the non-governmental
organizations including
obviously the humanitarian groups like
the icrc the international red cross uh
save the children the catholic relief
societies and others can play a role
also dispute resolution efforts that
exist in some of the great universities
and other centers of the world have long
been
underway even before the international
negotiating network has completed can be
joined in and we hope to form a closer
teamwork or a sharing of responsibility
by all those involved to prevent wars
and to resolve wars
those that are that are hot wars now
where people are being killed every day
is the highest priority of all perhaps
you you know those from having been here
several days sudan is the one that comes
to mind most frequently we hope to
evolve new plans new approaches
new forums within which people of sudan
might come together not in an official
capacity but just to share
with each other plans for the future to
speak perhaps for even the government
and revolutionary forces what are the
common uh
commitments that everyone has what are
the remaining differences how might
those be addressed the same thing was
applied in the case of cyprus we might
very well bring cypriots together here
turkish and greek cypriots or just in an
informal
uh way to assess that dispute in a much
more definitive form that was possible
in a brief period of time
those are some of the considerations
that present themselves the last thing
that i'll mention that we've discussed
in some depth is what can we do after a
peace agreement is forged it might take
40 years it might take four months to
make sure that the war does not resume
what can we do if democracy is finally
established in a peaceful environment to
prevent a military coup
replacing the democratically elected
officials as was the case in haiti
recently and we had president aristide
here the president of haiti those are
the kind of things that we have in mind
one suggestion that has been forged here
is that the development of a better life
for people
the prevention of war the sharing of
wealth is now done in a in a harem
scarum totally non-coordinated way
and and one of the concepts the proposal
has been made to me privately that i
haven't shared with the group before is
that we might assemble here 40 or 50
representatives of the top
sources of development aid
humanitarian aid in the whole world and
try to get some better cooperation from
them in sharing responsibilities in
particular countries that would include
not only ngos not only the un
development program not only the world
bank and the imf but it would include
the governments of japan
and perhaps the usaid
so that we could say what can we do now
to rejuvenate
uh democracy in haiti what can we do now
to prevent a recurrence of the war in
ethiopia so
maybe too voluminously that is what we
have tried to do
in the past we'll be sharing uh the
views expressed here with the secretary
general of the united nations uh with
president bush and the secretary of
state and others who are interested
including you noticed uh foreign
foreign minister chevron nazi who might
build upon
what we advocate the final thing that
they would want me to mention i know is
that we will present in the now this
year and in the future of an annual
state of the world conflict report to
kind of encapsulate for academicians or
for the news media for private citizens
for world leaders an assessment of what
is going on in the world
quite often it is not even recognized
because all the wars now are civil wars
and quite often even government leaders
like presidents of the united states are
not even aware of how many wars there
are what is a devastating effect other
than what might be
and public done what goes on next what
what will put into
motion the things that you've talked
about over the past few days do you have
a deadline do you have
an agenda or a plan to follow to bring
well i hate for all the questions to be
addressed to me but i'll be glad to
defer to to any of my colleagues let me
say briefly that first of all we will we
will
edit and publish to all the participants
the a summary fairly definitive summary
of all the proceedings here
secondly we will take these eight
particular
test cases you might say that only are
representative in
nature of about four times as many major
wars and say how can we
build upon what is presently done and
expand the present efforts to find peace
by bringing in
new ideas new participants and maybe by
stimulating
a long dormant efforts that are not
presently making uh much progress the
annual report is another that i describe
to you and so this will be done without
fail there's no doubt about that and
i've already mentioned the sharing of
what we have advocated here specifically
with the secretary general of the un
uh he will be coming uh here
uh
as soon as he and i both can schedule a
visit we've already discussed this in
detail and i'll spend a lot of time with
dale spence another with him
describing what what the recommendations
made to the united nations specifically
and when it involves other countries i
will personally be responsible to make
sure that secretary of state and or the
president or the foreign minister in
those countries know what
recommendations we have made
well let's let's see
beth
but it's not a matter of my sending them
it's a matter of them being invited and
us sharing as a council what should be
done
let me ask bishop tutu to respond to
that because he's taken a a new interest
i think in the last few days perhaps in
haiti and he's been deeply involved in
others
also he's a he's the main one who's an
expert now on what's going to be done in
sudan bishop tutor
yes i've been put on the spot
i think what many of us
hope for
is that
our association with president carter
will assist in
increasing
our individual
credibility
because i think that that has
an important bearing
on whether people
want to invite you
i don't think that anyone of the council
will
be presumptuous and say
they
impose themselves on any one particular
situation
um it'll often be
that people invite you
and we will then
have at our disposal what we didn't have
before
the resources of the center
and um
where
we were doing things
um
sort of instinctively
um
you will know that there are in fact
scientific ways of doing it um and so
you you won't keep
um kicking against
goats
i i believe that
people are going to
be saying there is
a credibility
an integrity
and
might i say so maybe a kind of status
that
will have come from
um
the association with the president
and the fact that i mean he has
been successful
himself
um
is something that
will be catching
and and
[Music]
infect others
because
most of the time
in my small experience of
dealing with conflicts as at home
it is where the people trust you
whether people trust you to be fair
and even-handed and
i think i mean that
those of us who have the privilege of
being on this council
um
hope
that we can make a small contribution
to the resolution of
those christ but we will not
be wanting to impose ourselves on anyone
last night we had a private uh night
before last we had a private uh meeting
supper with president rst
i was sitting there
near him as was bishop tutu it was very
interesting to me to see that when they
got down to sharing what might be done
in a spirit of compromise
or forgiveness there was a natural
affinity between bishop tutu and and
former uh father
priest aristide
this is a very significant thing because
we have a varied makeup as you've
noticed
among the council members
last october when it was very likely
that the entire gamut of efforts in
bringing free elections to zambia were
likely to collapse
mrs elizabeth palmer
because of her own stature and and the
trust of people
that people had in her because of her
own humanitarian leadership in unicef
and otherwise and the statue of her
former husband
uh made it possible for her to go into
zambia to meet with the disparate groups
as representing the inn and keep that
election on track
and because of the uh
prestige
of sonny ramfal
on a completely separate issue we called
on him
to communicate with president kalunda to
modify the state of emergency that was
imposed
that was preventing a free campaign
but sunny rainfall having been the
secretary general of the commonwealth
nations
of which zamber is a member and well
known by the zambian leaders
was much more qualified to do this than
was i
so i think the diversity of our council
members and the willingness of all of
them to participate
is a great resource in the future and
i'd like to confirm what what bishop
tutu said we don't go into a country
uh unless we feel uh
that we that our presence there would
not be duplicative or competitive
and before we hold an election or
participate in a peace talk or mediation
obviously we have to be invited in and
publicly encouraged to come in by
all the major uh political players
including adversaries who might be
in a a bloody and hot current war
yes sir and i'll get you next let's get
right here
i've just gotten a signal from dale
spencer twice a year
uh
as you've noticed we've had uh council
members coming and going most of them
have been very assiduous in staying here
but but these are very busy people they
have major responsibilities of their own
uh mrs palmer for instance who just left
is one of the top
world
leaders in unicef
and they've made a great sacrifice in
coming here chevron nadzi would have
been here but he's had urgent causes
i've told a group before from the state
of the republic of georgia to come there
and help them with their peace effort
and he stayed in moscow an extra few
hours to talk to us
uh this afternoon prayers to cuellar the
former secretary general of the u.n
would would have been here except that
he had a high
call from peru to go back and take care
of long overdue
personal and family problems he even had
to miss
the el salvador and peace
signing because which he had helped to
orchestrate so but so we have a a
a very high level and wonderful group
and i think twice a year would be
adequate we hope to follow this
conference up by the way
with i would say at least one conference
a year for the next few years to
consolidate what we've done to learn
from these experiences to improve
perhaps on the on the results uh to
monitor what
action has been taken as a result of our
recommendations and so forth
mike bucky with wabe radio here in
atlanta i'd like to ask all the
panelists if martin luther king were
alive today since we are celebrating his
birth this week in atlanta would he be
hopeful or sad about the state of the
world today
i'm going to ask one of his associates
to respond to that
andy young
yeah i'm always going to be hopeful and
and i think this is exactly a
continuation
of the efforts of martin luther king to
resolve conflicts without violence
and i'm extremely grateful to president
carter and all of the participants
for
honoring the
celebration of martin luther king's
birthday by really and truly carrying on
the kind of work that he prophesied
i don't know that he would i think he'd
be really pleased and surprised
at the state of affairs between the
united states and the soviet union
uh
the world's you know the fact that we
can talk about these
uh
problems together
and that we've had people from
various sides of the same issue in the
same conference
that's an enormous amount of progress
just to say that
the very fact that now at least
those who used to call the
non-governmental people
are part of any process of conflict
resolution for me i think this is
something that martin luther king would
have loved to to be
yesterday
then uh
i don't mind trying to answer but since
since dale spencer's been there would
you object to her giving an answer the
question is what specifically will be
done now to resolve the uh liberian
conflict
in the report out which we gave earlier
today we
noted that uh the next steps to resolve
the liberian conflict include notably
the holding of national elections free
and fair elections that would include
international observers and the carter
center's international negotiation
network has accepted an invitation from
both the interim government of national
unity the national patriotic front of
liberia and the economic community of
west african states to serve in a role
of organizing a team of international
observers to monitor such elections
we are concerned that as a barrier to
that elections that elections process uh
there still exists a condition of lack
of adequate security within the country
we are concerned that another barrier is
the lack of any
funding for the activities of the
liberian elections commission and and we
have urged in our earlier discussions
that a number of international groups
and organizations take all steps
possible to assist the liberian people
and particularly the liberian elections
commission in organizing that process
immediately time is of the essence
um
an initiative here at atlanta project
atlanta
what i'm asking is
your ability to concentrate on the
problems here at home not somewhat
compromised by the many requirements
that imagine it on your time
internationally anytime asking is there
well
there has to be enough jimmy carter to
go around you know
whether it's adequate or not
well i think from the very initiation of
the carter center which is before the
inn was born
i saw as a major and permanent
commitment of my life
the addressing of
conflict resolution
and the inn has grown from that original
concept are joined by people like many
of our council members who have been
involved in the process even longer than
i have
so i that will not be something that i
would ever relegate to a secondary
position as far as i've had invitations
in the last few days you know to come to
afghanistan to come to burma to come to
cambodia and obviously i'll go back to
to liberia and sudan well there's a
limit to how much foreign travel i can i
can make but i think that the formation
of a larger and larger staff and a more
adequate
budget and particularly these other
council members is a tremendous
magnification of what any one or person
can do
as far as sudan
i think that for instance if bishop tutu
went to sudan it would be much more
effective than my going
uh this was not a possibility from the
inn point of view at least a few
years ago and and i'm not speaking for
bishop two two i i have no aversion to
doing it whenever he would let me but uh
you know
i think in this conference he and i have
both learned a lot i've learned from him
he's learned from me so as we share in a
conference like this it makes everyone
here all 200 of us much more able to do
an expanded role than we could have in
the past so i want to share
the responsibilities and i would also
like to perpetuate this effort
you know i'm a fairly older person and
and in a few years i won't be able to
travel to burma or to go and negotiate
you know 20 days between the eritreans
and the ethiopians or to try to bring
together two disparate groups in sudan
to hold an election in haiti but but i
want to make sure that the inn
has a permanent substance and a growing
reputation so that the identity of one
person even a former president would not
be crucial at all to its success
of course yes i think that i don't want
to belabor this group who may not be
interested with the project with the
atlanta project but but i think that
that as i've said a couple of times here
the the greatest element of
discrimination is is against
poverty-stricken people one of the
greatest causes of wars that we're
addressing is a is a poverty
people the poverty of people who who
feel that there is no hope in life and
eventually they're willing to give their
lives literally
to provide
food for their families
or the assurance of of housing and as
they are deprived of basic human rights
because of a lack of attention from the
rich world
that is a cause of war so i don't feel
that they're incompatible and what we
learn in atlanta
in addressing the plight of the poorest
people in our as our neighbors i think
can ultimately be extrapolated i don't
really see a total incompatibility
between the two
yes
this to anybody sir wants it or any of
the eight target areas that we've been
talking about for three days closer to
peace today than they were on tuesday
as a result of something specific
that happened
let me have a shot
peacefully
the fact that people
from opposite sides of
a conflict situation
have been able
here
to sit down
and to
speak
the truth
in love to one another
is an important contribution
because
i think one of the most important things
that
we learn is when you have a conflict
situation
you look on your adversary
perhaps as not quite as human as you are
and
once you
engage with one another
as
human beings you make the the profound
discovery that the other guy or guys is
is human
and
the people who will have been here will
take that back with them and i believe
that that is an important contribution
it's an important contribution to
to know that there are specific things
that can be done
nobody starting
on tuesday here thought that
we were going to produce a magic wand
and by waving this
um
presto the
the the solution would arrive
but it is
i think important to have shown people
who have been
traversing
a a tunnel
that for them looked gloomy
but there is a light
at the end of the tunnel
and there some of us said i mean
successes in other areas
where problems that seem to be
intractable
give hope
in areas where
it doesn't seem as if
progress is possible
and so we have people from very many
parts who
even through their suffering and having
been through a crucible of anguish
come through that
and that enables others to
to feel a hope
and and i think too that
although this is not easy to
[Music]
compute
when people have been suffering
or are suffering
it is important for them
to know that there are people who care
the world is not
entirely careless
and uncaring that there are people who
are prepared to
invest time and money and energy
to help solve their problems
and i think that is important
and to that extent
there will have been
some movement
one of the most
memorable
lines
in the scholarly papers that we have
received
is
it's acceptable
to kill
a non-human
and the point is that we dehumanize
the people with whom we disagree
i was in the navy during the second
world war
and
every japanese was a japan
and every german was a hun and every
italian was a whop
and we use these epithets
so that as we kill people we don't
acknowledge to ourselves that we're
killing another
uh
child of god another human being
for many israelis every member of the
plo is a terrorist
and the fate of a terrorist is to be
executed not all of course
but but this is a this is a sense
that we hope to
subvert
in the world community
and i would say in answer to your
question that every one of these eight
conflicts are nearer to solution
than they were twos and i would also add
the conflicts that were not studied here
specifically
in sri lanka
and somalia and mozambique and chad and
rwanda in western sahara
just to mention africa
because what we have learned here from
one another i think will be conducive to
opening up opportunities
for seeking resolution of conflicts that
people didn't know about before
we had here all the week the secretary
general of the organization of african
unity salim saleem and i would assure
you in fact he told me this he's going
back to addis ababa
as a leader of this african organization
with with a renewed concept
that the oau can now begin to do what
the oas has recently begun to do be very
active and aggressive in going into
civil wars to try to find a solution to
them and i met yesterday with with
former president obasanjo who told me
that they are now deciding to form
a committee of elder
african statesmen committed to peace
you know this is i think this it can be
a remarkable new development where uh
adversaries in africa can turn to this
distinguished group
uh obasanjo and julius naire and kenneth
calendar and bishop tutu i understand
but be part of that uh just to say come
and help us in our country we don't know
where else to go they might not want to
go to the u.n so i would say that the
technique
of addressing conflicts that we have all
uh
learned about this week
has will be a permanent benefit
and i think we've all seen a much more
clear concept of what the u.n can do
that it's not doing now
and maybe some policies of governments
that should be changed to prevent wars
and some policies of the international
community in the commercial or or
financial realm
to make sure that peace once found can
be perpetuated i think all of these
factors can be beneficial in the future
in the resolution of the conflicts on
earth we've we've run out of time we
promised everyone that we would adjourn
uh in a timely fashion it's now
approaching 3 30 in the afternoon and i
i want to close by expressing my deep
thanks
to all of you who have come to join in
with us as participants and particularly
i want to express the thanks for all of
us
to dale spencer to bill spencer to bill
yuri and the others who made this
possible
[Applause]
that concludes our coverage of this
conference concerning civil rights
around the world for more information on
this event you can write to the carter
center of emory university one copenhill
atlanta georgia and the zip code is
three zero three zero seven
coming up in just a few moments we take
an in-depth look at healthcare in
america
[Music]
next you will hear from south african
archbishop desmond tutu he was at johns
hopkins university in baltimore last
night to deliver the school's george
huntington williams memorial lecture
archbishop tutu the first black to head
the anglican church in south africa has
been a long time advocate for nonviolent
reform in that nation and has been a
supporter of international economic
sanctions the annual williams lecture
was established 75 years ago by the
family of the late hopkins geology
professor the speeches are given by
distinguished public figures on topics
of widespread contemporary interest we
now bring you archbishop tutu's remarks
[Music]
so
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon and
welcome to the 1992-93
george huntington williams memorial
lecture
george huntington williams was professor
of inorganic geology and the first
professor of photography at johns
hopkins in the 1880s he founded the
university's department of geology known
today as the department of earth and
planetary sciences
this series
was established in his memory in 1917
one of professor williams contemporaries
described him as probably the most
gifted crystallographer
in the annals of american geology
and i'm very pleased to note that
several members of the williams family
are with us this afternoon
the williams lecture may be on any topic
of widespread contemporary interest
and surely there is no topic of greater
or more widespread contemporary interest
than that that will be offered this
afternoon
previous williams lecturers have
included julian huxley dean rusk uthaunt
boris yeltsin and of course most
recently and very memorably just last
year barbara jordan
and now it is not only a great pleasure
but really a high honor for me to
introduce to you this year's williams
lecture
archbishop desmond tutu is known around
the world for his courageous and
outspoken pursuit of racial justice in
south africa
in 1984 he was awarded the nobel peace
prize for his leadership of what the
nobel committee called the nine
non-violent struggle for liberation
as the first black secretary general of
the south african council of churches
from 1978 to 1985 bishop tutu used the
international forum provided by that
post to advocate the end of apartheid
his strong criticisms of the south
african government and his calls for
economic sanctions against south africa
were bitterly resented by the government
and led to the confiscation of his
passport
his voice nevertheless
continued to ring around the world
and he continues to work today for
racial conciliation and an end to
violence in south africa
bishop tutu was born in 1931
his father was a school teacher and the
future bishop also worked for several
years as a school teacher after
graduation graduation from pretoria
vantu normal college and the university
of south africa
in 1958 he began his ordination training
at saint peter's theological college in
johannesburg
following ordination as a priest he
continued his theological training at
the university of london
where he received a master's degree in
1966
bishop tutu's steady rise both in the
leadership of the anglican church and in
public recognition and influence attest
to his truly extraordinary qualities
in 1975 after the years he had spent
teaching theology and serving as
associate director of the theological
education fund of the world council of
churches he was named dean of
johannesburg in 1976
he was named bishop of lesotho
in 1978 as i have said general secretary
of south african council of churches
in 1985 bishop of johannesburg and in
1986 archbishop of cape town in 1987 he
was also named president of the all
africa council of churches and in 1988
chancellor of the university of the
western cape
positions which he continues to hold
bishop tutu has always stressed the
central importance of his religious
calling
once describing himself as a simple
pastor passionately concerned for
justice peace and reconciliation
in a magazine interview conducted the
day after the recent memorial service
for the 42 who were massacred he
declared nonetheless
i am always hopeful a christian as a
prisoner of hope
ladies and gentlemen join me in a warm
welcome for archbishop tutu
[Applause]
thank
[Applause]
you very much
[Music]
mr president ladies and gentlemen
friends
thank you very much for
your very warm welcome
and the very great privilege you
have acquired me in
inviting me to be
one of the lecturers in this
distinguished series
i bring you greetings
from your sisters and brothers in
southern africa
i don't say south africa
the church
to which i belong
and of which i am archbishop
has dioceses in
mozambique in lesotho in swaziland in
namibia
and even on
saint helena
and
of course in the republic of south
africa and so to come and say i bring
you greetings
from all of
those in these areas
is to say
we want to
express
to you
a very deep
thank you
for your support of our struggle
today
mozambique may be
being
seeing
a peace that it has longed for for so
many many many years
namibia is an independent country today
because of the support that people like
yourselves have given us so i bring you
those greetings and i greet you too
in the name of our lord and savior jesus
christ
good afternoon
well that is
uh a somewhat lousy response isn't it
yes
[Music]
maybe we should try again good afternoon
slightly better
slightly better thank you very much
we we don't always get such a rousing
welcome
at home things are changing of course
but
the city of cape town is very well noted
for graffiti and on one occasion they
had
graffiti that read
god loves alan busack and
tutu which is very nice and then
somebody
added the gods must be made
friends
quite extraordinary
changes have happened in the world in
the last few years
we might just be guilty of becoming
blase
and taking them
somewhat for granted
i don't know whether you remember the
cartoon i think it was in newsweek
it showed
a russian
astronaut
one of those who had been
orbiting the earth for a few months
uh
returning home
and
as he was due to lend
he he said well i'm much looking forward
um to being welcomed by comrade
president gorbachev
and he was told well
mikhail gorbachev is no more
president
then he said oh i'm so happy i'm
returning home to the soviet union
and he was told well the soviet union is
no
then he said well i'm looking forward to
drinking some vodka
and he was told well it will cost you
a zillion
rubles
poor guy
at home
um they tell the story
of
one of the
tramps coming to the door
of
actually one of my colleagues and
knocking on the door and saying
and as he stood there she decided she
would give him a blanket because it was
winter
and he turned to him and said no man
these are
new times and this is the new south
africa
a blanket
where is the duvet
it is quite staggering to think of what
has happened in south africa in just a
short
three years
in 1989
to protest against the iniquity of
apartheid
the churches
engaged in what was then called the
standing for the truth campaign
which coincided with the defiance
campaign
of what political
organizations were still not prescribed
we decided to contravene apartheid laws
which we said did not oblige obedience
because they were immoral and unjust
in much the same sort of way that the
civil rights movement in this country
preached
jim crow
laws
we decided
to break the beach apart aid laws
in a place near cape town
when we went to our designated venue
we had to run the gauntlet
of several roadblocks
manned by police armed to the teeth with
shotguns
dogs
tear gas and quirks
the bull whips that they
use to such good effect in which you
often saw images of on your television
screens
and signs had been put up
to announce that
the beaches were out of bounds for
humans
because quite surprisingly
the police
were using them to exercise
their dogs
it may have been a freudian slip
dogs could walk
on god's beaches
but we because we were black
could not
because the laws decreed
that we might not do so
alan busag and i on that occasion
took a stroll on this holy ground
to make our point to claim god's
speeches
for god's people
and can you imagine
we were the indigenous
people to whom that land had belonged in
the first place
and we had out of our generosity and
hospitality
welcomed those who were then foreigners
from across the seas
and now these
people had expropriated our heritage
and had now made us aliens
in our homeland
it's a story that you will have heard i
mean about how when missionaries came
to africa because
we had the land they had
the bible
and they said let us pray
and we dutifully shut our eyes
and when we opened our eyes
lo and behold they had the land and we
had the bible
of course they placed in our hands
in this exchange that seemed so unequal
something that was so utterly precious
because
as most of you must know
the bible is one of the most subversive
the most
revolutionary thing
you can have
in a situation of injustice and
oppression
the police officer in charge of police
operations on that day
when we were
demonstrating against apartheid laws
ordered us to disperse
and warned that
they would be ready to use even
live ammunition
to ensure that the crowds did disperse
now i never
they were ready
to use even live ammunition
ready to kill
in order to stop us from walking
on god's beaches
whilst it was okay for dogs to exercise
on those sacrosanct
pieces of land
you you wouldn't have thought that
people could be quite so dumb would you
they tell the story of how the south
africans
got a little upset that um at the time
the soviet union when it still existed
in the united states uh
we're getting all the kudos for
their space programs
and so
there is this character called
fundamental
who is
not endowed with a great deal of
intelligence and
he announces that south africa is going
to
launch a spacecraft to the sun no less
and and when they say to him but i mean
fundamentally you know long before it
gets anywhere near the sun
and
it will have been burned to cinders
and he says you don't think we're stupid
we serve africans we're going to launch
it at night
well here they
prepared to kill in order to defend the
laws of a party to defend the immorally
indefensible
that is
the backdrop that is as it were the
before picture that is where
we come from
because that is the kind of thing that
was happening just a few
three years ago
and then the south african government
called
the racist election of 1989 september
and the disenfranchised and those who
wanted a democratic non-racial
dispensation
opposed that
election
and demonstrated against it peacefully
in cape town
at about that time about 20 people were
killed
and we said in the churches
that cape town should protest the death
of these innocent peaceful protesters
and so we matched in september 1989
more than 30 000 of us
marched in a mammoth peaceful and
disciplined demonstration
for justice reconciliation and peace
we marched
in cape town first
and then
they marched in the rest of south africa
we marched in cape town first
and they marched thereafter
in europe
and the berlin wall fell
freedom began breaking out all over the
place
even in the most unlikely spots
dictators who had thought themselves
firmly in the saddle
began biting the dust
biting it comprehensively
somewhere designated themselves life
presidents
discovered that they suffered from a
universal failing they suffered from
mortality
and their former docile subjects had an
awkward propensity to hank her after
freedom
making things a little uncomfortable for
repressive authoritarian rulers
why did freedom break out so
exhilaratingly
even in south africa which had looked
for so long
a a hopeless case
why did freedom come
i want to suggest a few reasons why it
did
mr gorbachev who has fallen on somewhat
unhappy days
was a crucial factor
class lost and perestroika
were important ingredients
they were catalysts
setting in motion the thaw
which was to see the end of the cold war
which ended
in the collapse of
communism
for a very long time south african
governments used to be able to invoke
the
ogre of
communism
they they used to be able to use
the scapegoat of soviet expansionism
in what they called the total
onslaught and they
depicted south africa as the last
bastion of western christian
civilization
and under
mr p.w porter the predecessor of mr
degleck they adopted what they called
the policy of total
the total strategy
when no holds were barred against all
who were identified as enemies of the
state
really
those who
were opponents of of apartheid
and the kind of activity the south
african government and its agents
engaged in
ranged from
sort of ordinary innocuous study tricks
through
vilification and harassment
even including
assassinations performed by death squads
and this is being revealed
regularly
even by government-appointed judicial
commissions in south africa
had a mr brezhnev been in charge
in the kremlin
it is unlikely that we would have seen
the unloosening of the tight communist
system
it is unlikely that what
then followed in the train of glasnost
and perestroika
would have taken place
and it is important friends for us
to acknowledge
the importance
of the individual person
an individual person can make a
difference
you can make a difference
your contribution is in fact an
indispensable
ingredient
in the whole
process
of freedom
and it is not correct for any one of us
to be saying no what can puny i do
i've always said to people remember
the sea
is made up of
drops of water
it is when
a number of individuals
decide that something is sufficiently
important for them to form a coalition
that in fact
change does take place
and so
we acknowledge the role
that was played and played so
effectively
by
mr gorbachev
but it is equally
true
that
had we had somebody other than
a mr neglect it is unlikely that the
kind of initiatives he announced on
february 1990
would have happened
it is still
something like a dream
i said watching him
make his speech in parliament
on the 2nd of february 1990 and i sat
there pinching myself
i said now you know
this is the kind of thing
i would like to hear
from
a south african state president and
clearly this is a wonderful dream i am
dreaming
and and someone is soon going to shake
me awake and i will awake to the ghastly
the horrendous realities of the
apartheid dispensation
no but we will not dreaming
here was this man actually speaking
about
his willingness to release political
prisoners including nelson mandela
here was a man speaking about their
willingness
and their readiness to unban
black political organizations
something that
is almost certainly would not have taken
place under
his predecessor mr porter and so
one must acknowledge
whatever
one's political
alignment
one must acknowledge the crucial role
the critical role that mr declared
played
in setting in motion the kind of
initiatives and the movement for
democracy that is taking place in our
country
and i would want uh to salute him for
his courage
i do not always agree
i have often disagreed very vehemently
with the kinds of things that this
government has done
but it is it is it is to be churlish not
to acknowledge that he did do something
that in a sense was an unthinkable
for
many who form his constituency
and now the prospect
of a new dispensation
is
realizable
and we think
that even now despite the upheavals
of the violence
the political grandstanding of many of
the political leaders
that
we will get there
that south africa will be free
that
all of us in that great country
which has almost everything
but
but new the new south africa
will come to birth
you know
they
they they say that uh
at one time a south african was having a
conversation with a zambian
and
in the course of the this discussion the
zambian said well you know our minister
of naval affairs
what
minister of naval affairs i mean how can
you have a minister of naval affairs
when you are completely landlocked
and the zambian said well
don't you have a minister of justice
[Applause]
[Music]
we we have an incredible country we
really do
with some quite quite remarkable people
and we do have the possibilities
of becoming a paradigm for the world now
one is not saying that in any arrogant
kind of way it is just that south africa
does in fact have most of the world's
problems either writ large or rich small
i mean you have this disparities between
what you might call the first world and
the third world
you have
all the tensions and problems of race
and
if
no no no no
when
when we get it right and we must
then the world will say ah
in fact it is possible for people
as diverse as those who live in south
africa to cohere as a community
to learn that
our differences
do not make
as we so often
tend to develop them into things that
separate
that our differences were given to us by
god
so that we would know our need of one
another
that
we are in fact
made
for togetherness
we are made for
living in a delicate world a network of
interdependence
it's actually quite exciting
you know when you think
of what the scriptures say about us
human beings and that is why i was
saying to you that the bible is in in
fact an incredible instrument in the
hands of those who
may want uh to throw off the shackles of
uh
oppression because one i mean one of the
things that the scriptures say about
each one of us is
you are created in the image of god
now that is dynamite
when you say someone is created in the
image of god you are saying that person
stands for god
and that person is made for freedom
and that is why you are able to say in
moments when
repression is at its most intense
you say
to the perpetrators of injustice hey
you have lost
you have already lost because
you are really trying to take on god
when you perpetrate in justice
you are going against god
and you have had it
and we already be nice to you
we who are in the struggle for goodness
and justice
we we we invite you join join the
winning side
the scriptures
speak so wonderfully about us that we
are different
precisely in order for us to know
just how much we need one another
that were made for complementarity for
interdependence for belonging together
that we are really
as we've sometimes said to our people
when after that mammoth
demonstration that i was speaking about
of the 30 000
i said to to this huge crowd
why don't you wave your hands in the air
and they did that
and there was a wonderful wavy and i
said
just look at just look at just look at
your hands
as as they did this they looked and we
said
you are
the rainbow people of god
the black the white
all the colors
wonderfully wonderfully and that is why
you are a rainbow
i mean if you're one color you would not
be a rainbow
you are a rainbow precisely because you
are different
and and isn't it marvelous that when you
have a garden
it will be beautiful if it is a garden
of roses yes
but if it is a garden of roses of
daffodils of carnations i mustn't
mention too many because i don't
actually know too many kinds of flowers
but i mean
isn't it i mean when when you are hit by
this splash of color
diversity
is something that we should celebrate
to say
i am a jew
and i am proud
to be a jew
i am black and i am proud to be black
in any case there's not very much you
can do about it i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
and you say we don't need the
contributions that come from i'm good
i don't mean that i have a hotline to
heaven but i know
god did not make a mistake in creating
you you
it was not a divine mistake
and according to the scriptures
you are not an afterthought
see when god says some wonderful things
god says to jeremiah
before
i formed you in the womb
i knew you
now that one that wouldn't get in very
good marks at medical school would it i
mean
i mean how do you know someone before
they have been
even conceived
but
the incredible assertion that has been
made is that you are not an afterthought
that god has blended you
and we don't believe this that god has
planned you from all eternity
you and you and you and you and you and
you
that you're not an accident
sometimes said i mean some of us might
look like accidents but i mean
nobody nobody is an accident
isn't it is it incredible
i mean just
just
if if we could but savor
the meaning of this
that i am
because god created me
and god created me because god loves me
and i met her
i am
the result of love
the affirmation that that gives to each
one of us
that we don't have to do anything to try
to claim
value
we already have that value
and it comes as a free gift
we don't have to do anything
we just have to be born
and we're there
and our value is an infinite value
and there is nothing anyone can do
ultimately to reduce
or erode that value okay
so we say
mr gorbachev mr deglerk
and we would say
it would have been totally unthinkable
that the the process of freedom
would have been begun at home
without a nelson mandela
and this is not to engage in a
personality cult
you see if
as mr neglect did do when he went to to
the prison
he had met
a man
consumed by bitterness and anger
wanting
to revenge
it is unlikely that mr declared would
have taken the risk
of releasing him
and what he encountered
as we have encountered
this incredible man
so
filled with
magnanimity
with
a dignity
and it is not here alone when you meet a
walter solo and many others
it is incredible
their capacity
to love
i met them soon after they came out of
jail 27 years in jail
and what is your crime your crime is to
have the audacity to say hey
i'm a human being
no that's all they were saying i am a
human being with inalienable rights
inalienable inalienable means
i don't ask for them
from other another human being
they are rights that are god given
i don't go no one goes to another human
being and says give me my freedom my
freedom comes from god
[Music]
and and so
it was important for
the processes at home
that there was
a nelson mandela with whom mr de clerk
could engage
we said when we spoke about mr gorbachev
that individuals
make a difference
the clerk made a difference
nelson mandela made a difference
you
can make a difference
you can make a difference
you have made a difference
we went around asking please
can
you help us
in the struggle help
uh impose sanctions on the south african
government
and for a long time in this country
the administration was totally
set against sanctions
and we had this incredible thing you
went on to campus of the campus of the
campus and there was this remarkable
thing of young students
now they were not the only ones but it
was the students
particularly
right around the country
demonstrating
protesting
boycotting
and boycotting
on behalf of people
what more than 10 000 miles away
you could have said about the vietnam
war that some of them might have been
doing these things
because their brothers might have been
involved in in the draft or that they
were involved also out of self-interest
but i mean why
why
worry about people over there
it was an incredible demonstration
that despite everything that everybody
has said about people being selfish
inward looking introspective
worrying about number one
that this is not true
that those students
in a remarkable way were actually able
to change the moral climate in this
country
so that it was
not just possible
for
for your for your congress to pass
a legislation a sanctions legislation
but that they were able to master even a
presidential veto override
and i think i mean that
we want to give a very warm hand
to
young people to students
here
everywhere students in the recent past
and students now
because you are saying and you are
saying to the world
you know that there are there are things
that are more important
than
exam grades
you know i mean i i sorry
[Music]
but in a very real sense you are saying
there are things that are far more
important than those
and you are saying
[Music]
this world
can in fact be a better place
you're saying that
isn't isn't that exciting
now you did make a difference
you did make a difference and i want to
give you
a real humdinger of a of a of an
applause i mean i can't do it all by
myself but will you join me in giving
you
as i was i was saying to people on one
other occasion that i have to be careful
how i do these things on one occasion
we're in in
australian way there were about 2 000
students uh young people and i said you
know the trouble is we don't
celebrate who we are let's give
ourselves a warm cheer and they did that
and then i said how about giving god
a a standing ovation and they gave god
hey it really nearly took the roof off
and
without thinking at the end of that
operation i said thank you
but i i i mean i don't now
want to argue i mean anybody who says
well did sanctions work
t did they hurt the people you wanted
actually
you can engage in that
luxury if you want i know they worked
they
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that namibia is independent today
because of sanctions so
there we are
the other reason
is
after
decades of repression the southern
government thought
they had
knocked the stuffing out of our people
and they were amazed
that even in 1989
our people could engage as they did in
those protest
it seems to me
there is an incredible
quality in human beings
you don't have to teach human beings
really accurately about freedom
you don't have to tell them that
repression is wrong is unnatural
people know instinctively
we are made freely for freedom and
their spirits fall towards freedom
as a plant turns towards light
in the kind of tropisms that you learn
about i don't know a great deal about
that but i mean it's a nice little
example
you don't you don't have to teach people
about about freedom
you don't have to tell them that it is
unnatural to be repressed
and so
our people stood up
and the government of south africa knew
that they were going to have to use
unbearable levels of repression
unacceptable to the world to put us down
and that is why you are able to say
no matter what happens no matter how
many guns may be used no matter how many
prisons may be filled no matter how many
people may be killed
it is an inexorable truth
that freedom
will prevail in the end injustice and
oppression and lies cannot have the last
word
and they know it the perpetrators of
injustice know it
they know it
in the pit of their tummy
as they try to carry out their
injustices
and we have to tell them injustice
repression
hey
they are more expensive than freedom
freedom is cheaper than repression
you don't have to spend so much money on
on all kinds of efforts to maintain
yourself
and then
i think the last
the last
reason why
freedom why freedom now
i myself believe
that
the weakness of people down the ages
for freedom
for truth for justice
that these are not things that when they
happen
evaporating to the ether forever and are
destroyed and are lost
people killed and
tortured in prisons
for justice
we may not hear those cries
but they are not for nothing
those who are killed for truth
those deaths
are not for nothing
all of this
it
penetrates
into the atmosphere
because this is a moral universe
right and wrong do matter
truth will out
is is it it's wonderfully exhilarating
you know it you know it you know it does
happen i mean if you have gone into a
room where two people
were quarreling
you didn't hear them you didn't see them
and if they heard you come in
and they were suddenly smiling with one
another
almost all of us have god antennae
sufficiently sensitive to say ah
something wrong happened here
there is something there is something in
the atmosphere
equally you don't have to be told this
is a happy
home the walls
exude the happiness
you know it you know it when you walk
into a happy home there is something the
vibes tell you this is a happy home
and so
all of this has come to a head
in our day
so that freedom breaks out all over
so that a student can stand in front of
a tank who will ever forget that image
stands in front of a tank and whilst we
are all holding our breath thinking that
the tank is going to run him over it it
swerves away from him
and he goes and stands in front of it
again
and he turns it away okay yes
they were massacred
but china won't ever be the same
and those deaths
are not for nothing
and so friends we are going to be free
in south africa
all of us
black and white
it's going to be a glorious country
and we're going to say hey
hey why were we so stupid
for so long
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
archbishop tutu thank you
so much
for being here and for all that you have
offered this afternoon both to those who
are in this hall
and those who have joined us by way
of electronic connection and other halls
throughout the university i'm pleased to
tell you that just for a few minutes
archbishop tudo has agreed to answer
some questions of those of you who are
with us in this hall this afternoon
and i will moderate it and if i may see
a hand i'll take the first question just
over
way for here has been going on
and some people are saying um
in cades south africa cannot be only the
referee and the player at the same time
it's not the right way so condesa is not
the right way to go and there's another
thought which says that
maybe in their negotiations we needed a
neutral body and a neutral place where
there can be a good congress for a
domestic democratic south africa
and some suggest the um oau or whoever i
would like to hear from you or the
church's role in trying to break this
conflict of
a neutral body and do away
i have to repeat the question for
the the people in the other room
the question is
there is something called kodesa the
convention for a democratic south africa
which has been the forum for
negotiations for a new dispensation in
south africa um
the question is what what does the
church or what do we believe or to
happen in view of the fact that there
are those who say
cordesa is presently structured
is not the most appropriate
vehicle for the negotiations one that
the southern government cannot be
player and referee at the same time that
you need a neutral
chairperson and perhaps a neutral venue
outside of south africa
the answer
we would want to see
negotiations happen and happen as
quickly as possible
we would want to facilitate that process
at the present time those
chairing are in fact a charge of the
supreme court but if
if the international community
does want to assist us this may be one
of the roles that the international
community
could and should be playing
that of ensuring that
the
the ground
is leveled out for all the participants
and and it may be that that would be
better done
if
we we did have a neutral independent
um
chairperson convener or of this
particular convention other people think
uh the convention has a weakness as well
in so far as
the people
have been excluded i mean it is sort of
closed sessions and that may be another
uh feature that needs to be changed when
the multilateral
discussions uh take
take off again
another question
yes
bishop tutu when you were here last time
our students had shanty towns and they
had demonstrations a part of that
movement that you talked about
four or five years later now what role
do you see for our students here and the
students across america
to help in the process
[Music]
um
it's been wonderful to be back five
years as we went down the line and to
see what they did then
had a significant impact on
what has followed
i i would say that they
they want to remain as committed to
justice
uh
a
now as ever before
in fact most who
one
is that racism is
rearing its ugly head i mean we're
seeing the new nazis um over there um
there was nearly someone elected as a
governor
somewhere around here
for some people racism is
is becoming
respectable
and and i think it is important for
young people to remind
us
that it was racism that gave us the
holocaust
it was racism that gave us slavery
because racism that gave us the
lynchings
racism that gave us the awfulness of
apartheid
i think i mean again that uh
one hopes that they will continue to be
imbued with the idealism it's it's it's
it's been remarkable i've been to places
like
panama and
honduras
and met young people especially from
this country in the peace corps
who don't get
banner headlines
who go into the most remote villages
to work to teach
and i think we want to salute them
i mean all those unsung young people
who are saying it is possible
to make this world different
to make this world more compassionate
more caring
and
and they are sitting around here
those people who
are capable of making that kind of
difference to
to turn this society
which has i think unfortunately
relegated
the disadvantaged
onto the sidelines
[Applause]
[Music]
but yeah i mean
we've got all these wonderful people and
then i mean they must they must say
we do belong
in a global village
and we have just this
globe
to care for
yes
in a nation that's built on the
principle of white supremacy do you feel
that a commitment
based on changing laws is truly a
commitment for justice
in a in a country in a society
based on white supremacy
do you think a change of the laws
is a commitment to justice it depends on
what kind of change
you know i mean
i think that
much into the king junior said something
like uh
they
they you can't legislate to make someone
love you
but you can legislate to stop them from
lynching you and you say that that was
very important for him
[Music]
and i think actually that i mean laws do
help
to change people
it's not everything
but
when the barriers are removed and people
begin certainly in south africa people
are beginning to be surprised
that some of the most awful things that
they were expecting to happen
were not happening
that you
who your neighbor is
really is a matter for whether they can
afford to be where you are
not
what is your skin color
skin color is a total total irrelevance
you know you know that lovely story
about uh how god created people and put
them
you know out of dust uh
putting the first lord into the oven to
to fire them like you do bricks and uh
god got busy with too many things and
forgot that he had put the slot into the
oven and when he rushed
to open the pantry cinders and
they
they say this is how black people came
about um and then
god put a second lot in and this time
god was over anxious and opened the oven
too quickly
and these were under done and
and this is how white people came about
yes
but it doesn't tell us anything of any
significance
you know about people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
archbishop tutu um you said that america
has the um
unfortunate
um
ability of placing to decide those who
are disadvantaged
here on this campus which is supposed to
be a bastion of higher education the
black students constantly have to
legitimize themselves
we constantly feel harassed and
unwelcome
the surrounding community
is constantly at odds with the
university which serves as an ivory
tower
and
every single year this university
graduates hundreds of students who go to
all different realms of society and who
become policy makers
what can you say here today
to the 1200 people in this room our
university president all the people who
have come to enjoy you speak and so that
they can go home and say well i've heard
desmond tutu speak what can you say to
hold them morally and
consciously to the points which you
speak for and hold them obligated to
helping freedom break out all over the
world
[Applause]
what do i say here
in order for all of us to be
committed to
the kinds of things that lead to freedom
uh to an acknowledgement that all of us
count
well i've already said them
because i have i mean and
i it is up to all of us it really is up
to all of us
to
apply
what is appropriate for our particular
situation
for all of us
to stand for the truth as we understand
that truth
to stand for it in a way
that
commends it to
others you know
to be persuasive in
making people accept the position
you espouse and i i i would say i mean
you would be a wonderful example
of just that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you for being
here
the meeting is adjourned
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the annual williams lectureship at
hopkins was established 75 years ago and
is given by distinguished public figures
on topics of widespread contemporary
interest
if you would like further information
about this program you can contact the
johns hopkins university in 212
whitehead hall
3400 north charles street baltimore
maryland the zip code is 21218.
coming up next a debate between missouri
candidates vying for the governorship of
that state
join c-span sunday for a special edition
of american profiles
first you'll see an hour-long interview
with governor robert casey the
pennsylvania democrat is serving his
second term
next we'll spend 60 minutes with
governor william weld he is
this live call-in program begins later
this morning at 8 a.m eastern time 5
pacific
next from pretoria south africa the
presidential inauguration of nelson
mandela
as president mr mandela would serve for
the next five years as the leader of
south africa's government of national
unity
at age 75 he's south africa's first
black president in the country's first
democratic multi-racial elections nelson
mandela leader of the african national
congress defeated president f w de clerk
of the national party
the african national congress won 62.6
percent of the vote the national party
twenty point four percent and the
encarta freedom party 10.5 percent
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
is
is
we have a
is
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
us
um
[Applause]
well
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
is
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
20 were fairing as prophecy this is what
we have said in the past and the
struggle continues
our
[Applause]
will you please join your husband on the
podium
this is maura
okay
so
[Music]
oh
happy
so
this is the french the wife of the
french president
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
what's her first name daniela
[Music]
of spain
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is a live picture from south africa
where we're awaiting the inauguration
ceremonies to begin for south african
president-elect nelson mandela
representatives from the international
community continue to arrive
a few moments ago you may have seen
benazir bhutto the prime minister of
pakistan and her arrival
more than 150 000 people are expected to
be at today's inauguration joining
hundreds of international
representatives
vice president al gore leads the
american delegation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
h66
just stay with them
[Music]
so
[Music]
god
[Music]
that still has not arrived
would you be playing
okay
[Music]
yes
here
[Music]
my
hey
oh
[Applause]
oh
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
doors
foreign
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you
um
until we meet once more he is wishing a
happy birthday
[Music]
oh
so
so
no
you're looking live at south africa
pretoria for the inauguration ceremonies
of south african president-elect nelson
mandela those ceremonies expected to
begin in just a little bit
representatives from the international
community continuing to stream in for
today's festivities more than a hundred
fifty thousand people expected to be on
hand
vice president al gore along with his
wife tipper gore and the first lady
hillary rodham clinton leading the u.s
delegation
prince philip is leading the british
delegation
many other americans and foreign
dignitaries on hand today
in fact two planes carried the 44-member
u.s delegation for today's inaugural
rolling including hillary rodham clinton
tipper gore and many prominent black
americans including jesse jackson
representative john lewis of georgia
benjamin chavis executive director of
the naacp
also in the group two clinton cabinet
members commerce secretary ronald brown
and agricult agriculture secretary mike
espy
as well as congressional black caucus
chairman cuisine fumey of maryland
also colin powell former chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
and the mayor of the city of baltimore
curt schmoke is on hand today
[Music]
so
so
uh
wow
thank you
ah
so
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
know
yes
so
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
live from pretoria south africa
this is the inaugural ceremony for
president-elect nelson mandela
we expect the festivities to get
underway very shortly foreign
dignitaries continuing
to enter the grounds for the
inauguration
nelson mandela has been a member of the
african national congress since 1944
he founded the anc's youth league which
worked to end apartheid by using mass
action including strikes boycotts and
civil disobedience
in 1963 mr mandela was sentenced to life
imprisonment for sabotage and attempting
to overthrow the south african
government
then in 1990 his release from prison was
authorized by then south african
president f w de clerk
in july 1991 in durban at the first
national con conference that is of the
african national congress since its
banning in 1960
nelson mandela was elected president of
the anc replacing oliver tambo
and late last month under mr mandela's
leadership the african national congress
won south africa's first democratic
multi-racial elections
in its first order of business the new
south african parliament elected nelson
mandela president
[Music]
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
is
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
go home
we should probably take a picture
[Music]
yeah sure
i
feel very confident about the future i
think it's a great day for south africa
we finally there that which we have set
out to achieve has been achieved
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
the designated executive deputy
president mr f w clapp and mr
[Applause]
so
just
yeah
uh
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
jackson
how do you feel about this day oh we're
very excited about this day it's a
celebration for the entire world
so
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
time
oh
ah
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
oh
yes
live from pretoria south africa south
african government and international
representatives continue arriving for
the inauguration of nelson mandela as
president of south africa
in addition to the swearing-in ceremony
for nelson mandela two additional
members of the new south african
government will be sworn into office
today
f.w de clerk the outgoing president and
taboo mbeke will be sworn in as
executive deputy presidents
also following today's inaugural vice
president al gore who's leading the u.s
delegation will meet with nelson mandela
as well as his two deputy presidents
the vice president will outline a new
three-year 600 million dollar u.s aid
package to south africa
we continue to share with you the sights
and sounds of the inauguration ceremony
for nelson mandela from pretoria south
africa
okay
uh
[Music]
what's
ah
god
no you're not
ah
oh
alright
oh
you guys
thank you
[Applause]
so
thank you
so
[Applause]
three
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
well
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen
the deputy president
it's a good day for all of us isn't it
is
me
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
so we would like to ask everybody to
take their assigned seats please
live from pretoria south africa the
inauguration of south african president
nelson mandela emissaries and leaders
from around the world are in attendance
at today's ceremony all told over 150
000 persons expected to attend
on your screen now of course
cuban president fidel castro
moments ago tabo embeke one of the two
new executive deputy presidents arrived
the outgoing president f.w de clerk who
will also be sworn in today as an
executive deputy president
arrived a few moments earlier
leading the u.s delegation is vice
president al gore his wife tipper gore
and first lady hillary rodham clinton
two planes carried the u.s delegation to
south africa for today's inauguration
as well as the
vice president his wife and the first
lady many prominent black americans
including jesse jackson representative
john lewis of georgia
and benjamin chavis executive director
of the naacp are in attendance also in
the group two clinton cabinet members
commerce secretary ron brown
and agriculture secretary mike espy as
well as congressional black caucus
chairman quisem fumay of maryland colin
powell former chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff and baltimore mayor kurt
schmoke
the vice president will meet with nelson
mandela hours after today's inaugural
as well as with his two deputy
presidents he'll outline the new
three-year 600 million dollar u.s aid
package to south africa
nelson mandela has been a member of the
african national con congress since
1944.
he founded the anc's youth league which
worked to end apartheid in south africa
by using mass action including strikes
boycotts and civil disobedience
in 1963 mr mandela was sentenced to life
imprisonment for sabotage and attempting
to overthrow the south african
government
you can see now the arrival of nelson
mandela for the inaugural ceremonies in
1990 mr mandela was released from prison
by outgoing south african president f.w
de clerk
uh
thank you very much
[Music]
you just wait for the minute they get
older
of the building
and it is
[Music]
good morning good morning good
morning good morning
ladies and gentlemen
the president
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Applause]
the choir will now lead us in singing
the national anthem
[Applause]
[Applause]
just
[Applause]
[Music]
from
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
the honorable chief justice h corbett
will now proceed with the ceremony
um
designated executive deputy president
please proceed to the table
so he
also believe the umps yet of lair
foreign
[Applause]
thanks
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
will the deputy president-elect mr tabon
begin now proceed
to be inaugurated
will you please take the oath of office
in the presence
of those assembled here
and in full realization of the high
calling i assume as executive pres
deputy president
in the service of the republic of south
africa
i taboom veron begin
to hereby swear to be faithful to the
republic of south africa
and to solemnly and sincerely promise at
all times
to promote that which will advance
and to oppose all that may harm the
republic
to obey observe uphold and maintain the
constitution
and all other law of the republic
to discharge my duties with all my
strengths and talents
to the best of my knowledge and ability
and true to the dictates of my
conscience
to do justice to all
and to devote myself to the well-being
of the republic
and all its people will you please raise
your right hand and say so help me god
so help me god please be seated and sign
the oath
[Applause]
we now request
the president-elect of the republic of
south africa
mr nelson holy sacha mandela to proceed
to the table
will you please take the oath of office
thank you in the presence
of those assembled here
and in full realization of the high
calling
i
assume as executive
president in the service
of the republic of south africa
i
nelson honestly
mandela do hereby swear
to be faithful to the republic of south
africa
and do solemnly
and sincerely promise
at all times to promote that which will
advance
and to oppose
all that may harm the republic
to obey
observe
uphold and maintain the constitution
and all other laws of the republic
to discharge my duties
with all my strength
and talents
to the best of my knowledge and ability
and true to the dictates
of my conscience
due to justice to all
and to devote myself to the well-being
of the republic
and all its people will you please raise
your right hand and say so help me god
so help me god
[Applause]
please
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
we need to keep moving
these
[Music]
that's one minute
[Music]
we're presently experiencing technical
difficulties with our live signal from
south africa
as soon as we're able to correct the
problem we'll return to the inauguration
ceremony of south african
president-elect nelson mandela
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we're continuing to work on the problem
with our live signal from pretoria south
africa
as soon as we're able to clear up the
difficulties we'll return to the
inauguration of nelson mandela
in the meantime
a vignette on the south african flag
on april 26 through the 28th south
africans will cast their votes for new
government in accordance with the system
of proportional representation of voters
once the new democratically elected
president takes office a new flag will
represent the republic of south africa
here's a look at the different flags
that made south african history
possibly the first flag to be used by
south african administration was the
netherlands orange white and blue
first flown by dutch explorer van rebeck
in 1652
dutch settlers or boards became the
direct ancestors of today's afrikaners
when britain gained control of the cape
colony in the 18th century the british
union jack replaced the netherlands or
van ribeck flag
to escape british rule many offer
connors migrated northward to lands
occupied by black africans and formed
the transvaal republic and the orange of
free state with their own flags based on
the dutch flag
two wars broke out and in 1902 the
british defeated the opera connors and
incorporated the board territories into
the british empire
the british also subdued black africans
and in 1910 they formed the white
controlled union of south africa which
had a number of flags on the brief
peace
peace
unto everyone
whether near
or far away
for i shall heal you all
saith the lord
in the name of allah the beneficent the
merciful
alhamdulillah
[Music]
all praise and thanks to allah lord of
the worlds
and may his blessings and peace be
bestowed upon his prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and his family and friends and all
prophets and messengers
allah says in the holy quran
s
oh people
i have created you from male and female
and have made you nations and tribes
so that you may know and understand one
another
the most honored amongst you in the
sight of allah is he who is the most
god-fearing
allah says in another verse of the holy
quran
adam
and we have honored the children of adam
o allah
let us
know and understand one another
let us adhere to thy command
let us honor one another
for thou hast honored the children
of our father adam
o allah we are in thy hands
we have now reached the position o lord
where the leaders have been chosen by
the people
give them those who will lead us grant
them strength wisdom and courage to
undertake the difficult task
to govern our country justly and with
fairness
we appeal to you o allah to grant this
government of national unity the scope
to carry out its task
let there be reconciliation and love let
us move forward united in our
responsibility seeking frontiers which
will bring prosperity
give us strength o allah to dispel all
hatred and enmity
let love and understanding reign over us
oh allah we went through turbulent times
there was violence which resulted in
loss of life and property
we seek thy forgiveness
for not being able to stem out the
violence
we now seek calm and peace in our land
your prophet muhammad said allah
and peace is from thee
and peace will return to thee
we now ask your allah
to give us a life of lasting peace
grace us with national unity and
stability
we thank thee for the first democratic
elections ever held in this country
and we thank the o allah for this
momentous day wherein we
will we have installed our leader
president nelson mandela the head of the
first democratic government of south
africa
oh allah give him strength wisdom
courage and understanding
and guide him and those with him and
those around him to govern our people
with justice
allah says in the holy quran
and when you judge between man and man
judge with justice
alhamdulillah
let us pray
thank you god our father that by the
death and resurrection
of your only begotten son jesus christ
our lord and savior
you have overcome sin and death and evil
injustice and oppression hatred
separation and alienation
[Music]
before our very eyes we see a miracle
unfolding and our dreams becoming
reality as the sun shines on a new dawn
for us all black and white together
thank you god for freeing our country
from racism and oppression and for
liberating all our people
thank you for the courage of those who
initiated change
[Music]
in
thank you for bringing those who were
previously enemies around the same table
to achieve a negotiated settlement thank
you for the miraculous way in which you
transformed the election into a
corporate act of nation building thank
you god for all those here and overseas
who have supported us with their prayers
and love
thank you god that you have chosen this
your servant to be the first president
of a democratic south africa where all
of us black and white together will
count
not because of irrelevances such as race
gender status or skin color because of
our intrinsic worth as those created in
your image as redeemed by the precious
blood of jesus as being sanctified by
the holy spirit bless our president with
wisdom good health and all the gifts
necessary for this high calling bless
his colleagues the executive
deputy presidents and members of the
government of national unity bless this
beautiful land with this wonderful
people of different races cultures and
languages so that it will be a land of
laughter and joy
of justice and reconciliation of peace
and unity of compassion caring and
sharing we pray this prayer for a true
patriotism in the powerful name of jesus
who died and rules again and reigns with
you o father in the holy spirit one god
forever and ever
please say after me god bless south
africa
god had children
guide her leaders
and give her peace
for jesus christ's sake
uh
amen
i would now like to call upon one of our
foremost uh national poets zwakimbuli
[Applause]
let me dedicate my poetic praise
to the symbol of resistance let me
dedicate my poetic praise to the symbol
of hope and inspiration let me dedicate
my poetic praise to the fountain of
wisdom and inspiration i talk of nelson
holy sacha matiba i talk of nelson
matiba
some pico monsilla velvet pencil a m i
talk of a leader like golden diamonds
like diamond and gold you have gone
through the past of time in order to be
refined you have gone through all forms
of life i talk of nelson holy class
mandela i like an oak tree you have
survived all kinds of weather comrade
mandela you are a hero you are a veteran
you are a stalwart you are a catalyst to
unite you are the father of the new
nation in the making jesuit ezekiel um
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i want to take this
historic honor and introduce to you the
new south african president
of the republic of south africa nelson
holy sasha mandela
[Applause]
it is my great pleasure to announce
the president of the republic
of south africa mr nelson holy shacha
mandela
[Applause]
your majesties
your royal highnesses
distinguished us
comrades and friends
today all us do
by our presence here
and by our celebrations in other parts
of our country
and the world
confer glory
and hope
to newborn liberty
out of the experience of an
extraordinary human disaster
that lasted too long
must be born a society
of which all humanity
will be proud
our daily dues as ordinary south
africans
must produce an actual south african
reality
that will reinforce humanity's belief
in justice
strengthen his confidence in the
nobility
of the human soul
and sustain all our hopes
for a close lost life for all
all this we owe both to ourselves
and to the peoples of the world
who are so well represented here today
to my compatriots
to my computers
i have no hesitation and say
that each one of us
is as intimately attached to the soil of
this beautiful country
as are the famous jacaranda trees of
pretoria
and the mimosa trees of the bushfire
each time one of us touches the sun of
this land
we feel a sense of personal renewal
the national mood
changes as the seasons change
we are moved by a sense of joy
and exhilaration
when the grass turns green
and the flowers
bloom that spiritual and physical
oneness
we all share with this common homeland
explains that the depth of the pain we
all carry
in our hearts
as we saw our country tear itself apart
in terrible conflict
and as we saw it spend
outlawed
and isolated by the peoples of the world
precisely because it had become
the universal base
of the pernicious ideology
and practice of racism and racial
oppression
where the people of south africa
feel fulfilled
that you know humanity has taken us back
into its bosom
that we
were outlaws
not so long ago
have today be given the rare privilege
to be host to the nations of the world
on our own soil
[Applause]
we thank
all our distinguished international
guests
for having come to take position
possession
with the people of our country
what is after all
a common victory for justice
for peace
for human dignity
we trust that you will continue to stand
by us
as we tackle the challenges of building
peace
prosperity
non-sexism
non-racialism and democracy
we deeply appreciate
the role that the masses of our people
and their political
mass democratic
religious
women
youth
business
traditional and other leaders
have played to bring about this
conclusion
not least amongst them
is my second deputy president
the honorable
fw de clerk
[Applause]
we would also like to pay tribute
to our security forces
in all the rugs
for the distinguished role
they have played in securing our first
democratic election
and the transition to democracy
from blood-tested forces
which still refused to see the light
the time for the healing of the wounds
has come
the moment to preach
the cousins that divides us has come
the time to build is upon us
we have at last
achieved our political emancipation
we pledge ourselves
to liberate all our people
from the continuing bondage of poverty
deprivation
suffering
gender and other discrimination
we succeeded to take our last steps to
freedom
in conditions of relative peace
we commit ourselves
to the construction of a complete
just and lasting peace
we have triumphed
in the effort to implant hope in the
press of the millions of our people
we enter into a covenant
that we shall build the society
in which all south africans
both black and white
will be able to walk tall
without any fear
in their hearts
assured of their inaudible right to
human dignity
a rainbow nation
at peace with itself and the world
as a token of this commitment
to the renewal of our country
the new interim government of national
unity
will as a matter of urgency
address the issue of amnesty
for various categories of our people
who are currently serving terms of
imprisonment
we dedicate this day
to all the heroes and heroines in this
country
and the rest of the world
who sacrificed in many ways
and surrendered their lives
so that we could be free
their dreams
have become reality
freedom
is their reward
we are both humbled
and elevated by the honor and privilege
that you the people of south africa have
bestowed on us
as the first president of the united
democratic
non-racial
and non-success of africa
to lead our country
out of the valley of darkness
we understand it
still
that there is no easy road to freedom
we know it well
that none of us acting alone can't
achieve success
we must therefore end together as a
united people
for national reconciliation
for nation-building
for the breadth of a new world
let there be justice for all
let there be peace for all
let there be work
bread
water
and salt for all
let us know
that for each
the body
the mind and the soul
have been freed
to fulfill themselves
never
never
and never again
shall it be
that this beautiful lord
will again experience
the oppression
of one by another
and suffer the indignity
and suffer the indignity
of being the skunk of the
world the sun
shall never set
on so glorious
a human achievement
let freedom reign
god bless africa i thank you
[Applause]
we will now conclude by singing of the
national anthems
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
first
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
you're watching a live picture from
pretoria south africa you've just seen
the inauguration of
nelson mandela